dr charles severance is one of the
world's most popular software
instructors and he's the instructor for
this c programming course this course is
a little different than some of our
other courses dr chuck is going to take
you through a classic and important book
on c programming you will occasionally
have to pause the video to do some
assignments to check your comprehension
it's going to be a challenge but it will
definitely be worth it if you want to
have a deep understanding of the c
programming language and if you're
completely new to programming you may
want to watch dr chuck's python for
everybody course first
welcome to c programming for everybody
my name is charles severance and i'm
your instructor for this course
this course and website is dedicated to
learning the classic version of c
programming language from the 1978 book
written by brian w kernighan and dennis
m ritchie
this book places the reader in the
middle of the 1970s transition from a
hardware-centered computer science to a
focus on writing portable and efficient
software c was used to develop operating
systems like unix minix and linux
programming languages like perl python
java and javascript and ruby are all
written in c
software like early tcp networking stack
implementations that made the internet
possible were written in c
and the first web browsers and web
servers were written in c
writing software in c enabled major
advances in computer architecture and
performance
operating systems compilers and
utilities could be recompiled to work on
a new hardware platform once we had a c
compiler for the new hardware
so much software has been written in c
over the past 40 years that there's a
very good chance that much of the
software that you use every day was
either written in c or written in a
programming language that was written in
c
so we study c less as a programming
language to use on a daily basis and
more as the foundation of modern
software and computing
in many ways c is the technology
equivalent of the rosetta stone in that
it provides a connection between the
programming languages of the past and
the programming languages of the present
the name cc4e in www.cc4e.com
refers to the original unix command cc
which was the command that you used to
compile your c program
cc stood for c compiler and it is
featured on the first page of the first
chapter of the knrc book
programmers like me from the 1970s and
1980s typed cc on unix systems like the
att 3b2 to compile and run their first
hello world program in c
this material is being presented under
fair use as we are making use of
material from a copyrighted work that is
out of print and not broadly available
in any format the book is also not
available in any accessible format we
are making use of this material in a
teaching and research context with a
focus on studying its contribution to
computing history
the material is available for free and
online to anyone who wants to learn
about the history of a c language
computing and computer architecture
welcome to the course
[Music]
welcome to c programming for everybody
my name is charles severance and this is
my reading of the 1978 c programming
book written by brian kernighan and
dennis ritchie at times i add my own
interpretation of the material from a
historical perspective
chapter 0 introduction
c is a general purpose programming
language it has been closely associated
with the unix system since it was
developed on that system and since unix
and its software are written in c
the language however is not tied to any
one operating system or machine and
although it has been called a system
programming language because it is
useful for writing operating systems it
has been used equally well to write
major numerical text processing and
database programs
c is a relatively low level language
this characterization is not pejorative
it simply means that c deals with the
same sort of objects that most computers
do namely characters numbers and
addresses
these may be combined and moved about
with the usual arithmetic and logical
operators implemented by actual machines
c provides no operations to deal
directly with composite objects such as
character strings sets lists or arrays
considered as a whole
there is no analog for example of the
pl1 operations which manipulate an
entire array or string
the language does not define any storage
allocation facility other than static
definition and the stack discipline
provided by the local variables of
functions there is no heap or garbage
collection like that provided by algol
68.
finally c itself provides no input
output facilities there are no read or
write statements and no wired in file
access methods
all of these higher level mechanisms
must be provided by explicitly called
functions
i would note that the lack of a heap or
garbage collection feature in c is both
one of the great strengths of the
language and at the same time is likely
the reason that the average programmer
will never develop or maintain a major c
application during their career
c provides a simple feature using malloc
and free functions that allow a
programmer to request a certain amount
of memory be allocated dynamically use
the memory and then return the memory to
the c runtime library for reuse
for example to convert a jpeg image to a
png image our application will read the
jpeg data into memory then convert the
image into a png image in memory and
then write the png data out to a file
we don't know how large the images will
be in advance so we request whatever
size we need from c and then give it
back when we're done
the term heap refers to the memory that
c manages on our behalf when we need to
borrow a bit of memory and give it back
later
there are a couple of issues with a
simple heap implementation
first if we forget to call free when we
are done with a memory we have created a
memory leak and our program will
eventually run out of memory and abort
c places the onus of giving back any
dynamically allocated memory on the
programmer
modern languages like java javascript
and python keep track of when we stop
using dynamic memory using a dynamic
memory layer that can automatically
reclaim the memory
the more difficult problem is after a
series of calls to malik and free the
heap space becomes fragmented and some
cleanup is needed this cleanup is called
garbage collection
efficient memory allocation and garbage
collection has been the subject of
decades of computer science research
the java language has built a number of
increasingly effective garbage
collection approaches over the years
kernighan and ritchie in one simple
paragraph define most of the problem as
out of scope for the c language which
makes it a bit challenging for us to
make good use of dynamic memory
allocation in c but when we do it
properly it performs very well
if you are currently using a language
like java python or php
every time you create a new string
through concatenation without thinking
about memory allocation remember to
appreciate the decades of work by
computer scientists that made it easy
for you
kernighan and ritchie knew that garbage
collection was difficult so they left it
out of the c language and put it into a
run time library
back to chapter zero
similarly c offers only straightforward
single thread control flow constructions
tests loops grouping and subprograms but
not multi-programming parallel
operations synchronization or
co-routines
though the absence of some of these
features may seem like a grave
deficiency you mean i have to call a
function to compare two character
strings
keeping the language down to modest
dimensions has brought real benefits
since c is relatively small it can be
described in a small space and learned
quickly
a compiler for c can be simple and
compact compilers are also easily
written using current technology one can
expect to prepare a compiler for a new
machine in a couple of months and to
find that eighty percent of the code of
a new compiler is common with existing
ones
this provides a high degree of language
mobility because the data types and
control structures provided by c are
supported directly by most existing
computers the runtime library required
to implement self-contained programs is
tiny on the pdp-11 for example it
contains only the routines to do 32-bit
multiplication and division and to
perform subroutine entry and exit
sequences
of course each implementation provides a
comprehensible compatible library of
functions to carry out input output
string handling and storage allocation
operations but since they are only
called explicitly they can be avoided if
required and they can also be written
portably in c itself
again because the language reflects the
capabilities of current computers c
programs tend to be efficient enough
that there is no compulsion to write
assembly language instead the most
obvious example of this is the unix
operating system itself which is written
almost entirely in c
of 13 000 lines of system code only
about 800 lines at the very lowest level
are an assembler
in addition essentially all of the unix
application software is written in c
the vast majority of unix users
including one of the authors of this
book do not even know the pdp-11
assembly language
i would note that in this preface the
authors are carefully explaining the
fact that many of the well-established
programming languages of the 1960s and
1970s like fortran cobalt pascal algol
and pl1 were solving many of the use
cases that were needed by us programmers
by adding syntax to the languages the
creators of c and unix were advocating
for a more minimal set of programming
language constructs and more reliance on
calling function in provided runtime
libraries to meet programmer use cases
it may have seemed a strange approach
for experienced programmers in the 1980s
but over time it has allowed c to expand
to meet a very wide range of programmer
needs without requiring major revisions
to the core language or
compiler back to chapter 0.
although c matches the capabilities of
many computers it is independent of any
particular machine architecture and so
with a little care it is easy to write
portable programs that is programs which
can be run without change on a variety
of hardware
it is now routine in our environment
that software developed on unix is
transported to local honeywell ibm and
inner data systems in fact the c
compilers and runtime support on these
four machines are much more compatible
than the supposedly ansi standard
versions of fortran the unix operating
system itself now runs on both the
pdp-11 and the interdata 832
outside of programs which are
necessarily somewhat machine dependent
like the compiler assembler and debugger
software written in c is identical on
both machines
within the operating system itself the 7
000 lines of code outside of the
assembly language support and the i o
device handlers is about 95 percent
identical
as a note before unix and c if you are
running the vendor operating system and
writing in the best language for systems
like the pdp 11 and inner data 732 the
user experience was completely different
today we take for granted that we expect
to be able to download the same
application for windows mac os or a
linux system even in the 1970s those
that were using unix and c could write
code once and move it between two
hardware platforms and expect that it
would work with no or relatively few
changes
back to chapter zero
for programmers familiar with other
languages it may prove helpful to
mention a few historical technical and
philosophical aspects of c for contrast
and comparison
many of the most important ideas of c
stem from the considerably older but
still quite vital language bcpl
developed by martin richards the
influence of bcpl on c proceeded
indirectly through the language b which
was written by ken thompson in 1970 for
the first unix system on the pdp-7
although it shares several
characteristic features with bcpl c is
in no sense a dialect of it
bcpl and b are typeless language
the only data type is the machine word
and access to other kinds of objects is
by special operators or function calls
in c the fundamental data objects are
characters integers of several sizes and
floating point numbers in addition there
is a hierarchy of derived data types
created with pointers arrays structures
unions and functions
c provides the fundamental control
constructions required for
well-structured programs
statement grouping decision making with
if
looping with termination test at the top
using for and while or at the bottom
using do and selecting one of a set of
possible cases switch
all of these were provided in bcpl as
well
though with somewhat different syntax
that language anticipated the vogue for
structured programming by several years
c provides pointers in the ability to do
address arithmetic the arguments to
functions are passed by copying the
value of an argument and is impossible
for the called function to change the
actual argument in the caller
when it is desired to achieve call by
reference a pointer may be passed
explicitly and the function may change
the object to which the pointer points
array names are passed as the location
of the array origin so array arguments
are effectively call by reference
any function can be called recursively
and its local variables are typically
automatic or created anew with each
invocation
function definitions may not be nested
but variables may be be declared in a
block structured fashion
the functions of a c program may be
compiled separately
variables may be internal to a function
external but known only within a single
source file or completely global
internal variables may be automatic or
static
automatic variables may be placed in
registers for increased efficiency but
the register declaration is only a hint
to the compiler and does not refer to
specific machine registers
c is not a strongly typed language in
the sense of pascal or algol 68 it is
relatively permissive about data
conversion although it will not
automatically convert data types with
the wild abandon of pl1
existing compilers provide no run time
checking of array subscripts or argument
types
etc for those situations where strong
type checking is desirable a separate
version of the compiler is used this
program is called lint
apparently because it picks up bits of
fluff from one's program lint does not
generate code but instead
applies a very strict check as to many
aspects of the program as can be
verified at compile and load time it
detects
type mismatches inconsistent argument
use
unused or apparently uninitialized
variables potential portability
difficulties and the like programs which
pass unscathed through lint enjoy with
few exceptions freedom from type errors
about as complete as do for example
alcohol 68 programs we will mention
other lint capabilities as the
occasion arises
i would note that separately checking
for things that might be wrong into the
lint program keeps the c compiler simple
and easy to port to a new computer
the lint program was naturally a very
portable text processing application
while there's some overlap between a
lint program and a compiler
over time there's quite distinct
research and expertise in how to lint
versus how to compile
modern lint programs look at programs in
far more detail than most compilers
separating concerns of lint and the c
compiler also allowed lint programs to
use more memory and take more time to
execute than compilers
since the typical developer might use
the compiler many times per day and run
lint less often it was nice for the
compiler to run quickly and make light
use of computer resources
we call this idea of building two
smaller complementary programs that each
specialize in one task
separation of concerns and it is an
important principle in computer science
by keeping each component simple in
focus we can more easily build test and
verify each component
unix and c showed the benefits of taking
many small components approach to solve
an overall set of problems
back to chapter zero
finally
c like any other language has its
blemishes some of the operators have the
wrong precedence
some of the syntax could be better there
are several versions of the language
extent differing in minor ways
nonetheless c has proven to be an
extremely effective and expressive
language for a wide variety of
programming applications
the rest of this book is organized as
follows chapter 1 is a tutorial
introduction to the central part of c
the purpose is to get the reader started
as quickly as possible since we believe
strongly that the only way to learn a
new language is to write programs in it
this tutorial does assume a working
knowledge of the basic elements of
programming there is no explanation of
computers of compilation nor the meaning
of an expression like n equals n plus
one
although we have tried where possible to
show useful programming techniques the
book is not intended to be a reference
work on data structures and algorithms
when forced to make a choice we have
concentrated on the language
chapters two through six discuss the
various aspects of c in more detail and
rather more formally than does chapter 1
although the emphasis is still on
working examples of complete useful
programs rather than isolated fragments
chapter 2 deals with basic data types
operators and expressions and chapter 3
treats control flow if else while 4 etc
chapter 4 covers functions and program
structure external variables scope rules
and so on
chapter 5 discusses pointers and address
arithmetic and chapter 6 contains the
details of structures and unions
chapter 7 describes the standard cio
library which provides a common
interface to the operating system this
io library is supported on all machines
that support c so programs which use it
for input output and other system
functions can be moved from one system
to another
essentially without change
chapter eight describes the interface
between c programs
and the unix operating system
concentrating on input output the file
system and portability
although some of this chapter is unix
specific programmers who are not using
unix systems should still find useful
material here
including some insight on how one
version of the standard library is
implemented and suggestions on achieving
portable code
appendix a contains the c reference
manual this is the official statement of
the syntax and semantics of c and except
for one owns compiler the final arbiter
of any ambiguities and omissions from
earlier chapters
since c is an evolving language that
exists on a variety of systems some of
the material in this book may not
correspond to the current state of
developments for a particular system
we have tried to steer clear of such
problems and warn of potential
difficulties when in doubt however we
have chosen generally to describe the
pdp-11 unix system
since that is the environment of the
majority of c programmers appendix a
also describes implementation
differences on the major c systems
chapter 1 a tutorial introduction
let us begin with a quick introduction
to c our aim is to show the essential
elements of the language in real
programs but without getting bogged down
in details formal rules and exceptions
at this point we are not trying to be
complete or even precise
we want you to get as quickly as
possible to the point where you can
write useful programs
and to do that we have to concentrate on
the basics
variables and constants arithmetic
control flow functions and the rudiments
of input and output
we are quite intentionally leaving out
of this chapter features of c which are
of vital importance for writing bigger
programs these include pointers
structures and most of c's rich set of
operators
several control flow statements and a
myriad of details
this approach has its drawbacks of
course
most notable is that the complete story
on any particular language feature is
not found in a single place
the tutorial by being brief may also
mislead
and because they cannot use the full
power of c the examples are not as
concise and elegant as they might be
we have tried to minimize these effects
but be warned
another drawback is that later chapters
will necessarily repeat some of this
chapter
in any case experienced programmers
should be able to extrapolate from the
material in this chapter to their own
programming needs
beginners should supplement it by
writing small similar programs of their
own
both groups can use it as a framework on
which to hang the more detailed
descriptions that begin in chapter 2.
1.1 getting started
the only way to learn a new programming
language is by writing programs in it
the first program to write is the same
for all languages print the words hello
world
this is the basic hurdle
to leap over it you have to be able to
create the program text somewhere
compile it successfully
load it
run it and find out where your output
went
with these mechanical details mastered
everything else is comparatively easy
in traditional c
the program to print hello world is
main open parenthesis closed parenthesis
open curly brace
printf parentheses double quote hello
comma space world backslash n double
quote
close parentheses semicolon close curly
brace
the modern minimal version of this
program needs a bit more syntax we add a
single line at the beginning
hashtag
include space
left angle brackets
stdio.h right angle bracket pound
include
stdio.h we have to add that line for the
modern program
back to the book
just how to run this program depends on
the system that you're using
as a specific example on the unix
operating system you must create the
source program in a file whose name ends
in dot c such as hello dot c
and then you compile it with the command
cc
space hello.c
if you haven't botched anything such as
omitting a character or misspelling
something the compilation will proceed
silently and make an executable file
called a dot out
running that by the command
a dot out will produce hello comma world
as its output
on other systems the rules will be
different check with a local expert on
modern systems we use the gcc compiler
with the dash ansi option to accept the
legacy syntax of c
so we use gcc space minus ansi
space hello.c
and to run the resulting a dot out file
you usually you need to prepend the
local directory because most shell
configurations do not include the
current path in the paths to search for
applications so you need to write
dot slash a dot out
now for some explanations about the
program itself
a c program whatever its size consists
of one or more functions which specify
the actual computing operations that are
to be done
c functions are similar to functions and
subroutines of a fortran program or the
procedures of pl1 pascal etc
in our example main is such a function
normally you are at liberty give
functions whatever names you like but
main is a special name
your program begins executing at the
beginning of main
this means every program must have a
main somewhere
main will usually invoke other functions
to perform its job
some coming from the same program and
others from libraries of previously
written functions
one method of communicating data between
functions is by arguments
the parentheses following the function
name surround the argument list here
main is a function of no arguments
indicated by open parentheses close
parentheses
the curly braces enclose the statements
that make up the function they're
analogous to the due end of pl1 or the
begin end of algol or pascal and so on
a function is invoked by naming it
followed by a parenthesized list of
arguments
there is no call statement as there is
in fortran or pl1 the parentheses must
be present even if there are no
arguments
in the above text the authors were
making connections to the popular
general purpose programming languages of
the time
when the book was written it was not all
assured that c and c like languages
would ever evolve past writing high
performance applications
like operating system kernels and device
drivers
by comparing c to these more general
purpose languages the authors are trying
to plant the seed that c could have
value as a general purpose language
back to the text
the line that says
printf parentheses double quote hello
comma space world backslash and double
quote close parentheses semicolon
is a function call
which calls a function named printf
with the argument
hello world
printf is a library function which
prints the output to the terminal unless
some other destination is specified
in this case it prints the string of
characters that make up its argument
any sequence of any number of characters
enclosed in double quotes is called a
character string or string constant
for the moment our only use of the
character strings will be as arguments
to printf and other functions
the sequence backslash n
in the string is c notation for the new
line character
which when printed advances the terminal
to the left margin on the next line
if you leave out the backslash n
a worthwhile experiment by the way you
will find that your output is not
terminated by a line feed the only way
to get a new line character into the
printf argument is with backslash n
if you try to break it into two lines
like printf quote hello world and then
just hit the return
double quote
close parentheses
semicolon on a new line the c compiler
will print out unfriendly diagnostics
about missing quotes
printf never supplies a new line
automatically so multiple calls can be
used to build up an output line in
stages
our first program could have just as
well been written as
main open parenthesis closed parenthesis
open curly brace
printf quote hello quote
semicolon
printf quote world quote semicolon print
f backslash n semicolon and then on a
sixth line closed curly brace and it
would have produced the identical output
note that backslash n represents only a
single character an escape sequence like
backslash n provides a general and
extensible mechanism for representing
hard to get or invisible characters
among the others that c provides are
backslash t for tab
backslash b for backspace
backslash double quote for double quote
and backslash backslash for the
backslash itself
1.2
page 8
variables and arithmetic
the next program prints the following
table of fahrenheit temperatures in
their centigrade or celsius equivalents
using the formula c equals parenthesis 5
divided by 9
closed parenthesis parenthesis f minus
32.
the table contains fahrenheit of 0
celsius of negative 17.8 fahrenheit at
20 celsius of negative 6.7 fahrenheit of
40 celsius of 4.4 and so forth here is
the program itself
for reference this program is on page 29
of the textbook
so it starts with pound include stdio.h
to include the standard library then it
has a comment that says print the
fahrenheit celsius table for f equals
zero comma twenty comma dot dot dot
comma three hundred
close comment
main open parenthesis close parenthesis
open curly brace
int
lower comma upper comma step semicolon
float
far
comma celsius
lower equals zero semicolon followed by
a comment
upper equals 300 semicolon followed by a
comment
step equals 20 semicolon followed by a
comment
far equals lower
and then
while open parenthesis far less than or
equal to upper closed parenthesis open
curly brace
celsius equals parenthesis 5.0 slash 9.0
closed parenthesis
asterisk
open parenthesis far minus 32.0
close parentheses semicolon
then a printf statement printf open
parentheses double quote percent 4.0 f
space percent 6.1 f
backslash n close quote comma far
comma celsius
close parentheses semicolon
far equals far plus step
and then a closing curly brace to finish
the while statement and then a closing
curly brace to finish the main statement
the first two lines
slash star print fahrenheit to celsius
table for f equals zero comma twenty dot
dot dot three hundred
star slash are a comment
which in this case explains briefly what
the program does any characters between
star and star slash are ignored by the
compiler they may be used to freely make
the program easier to understand
comments may appear anywhere a blank or
new line can
in c all variables must be declared
before use
usually at the beginning of a function
before any executable statements
if you forget a declaration you will get
a diagnostic from the compiler a
declaration considered consists of a
type and a list of variables that have
that type as in
int
lower comma upper comma step semicolon
float far celsius semicolon
the type int
implies that the variables listed are
integers
float stands for floating point i.e
numbers which may have a fractional part
the precision of both int and float
depends on the particular machine that
you are using
on the pdp-11 for instance an int is a
16-bit signed number
that is one that lies between negative
32
eight
and positive thirty two thousand seven
sixty seven
a float number is a thirty two bit
quantity which amounts to about seven
significant digits with a magnitude of
about ten to the minus thirty eight
and
10 plus 38.
chapter 2 lists the sizes
for other machines
i would note that the 1970s was a time
of transition in the amount of memory
installed in computers
the c language int type was 16 bits in
the older but more generally available
computers like the pdp-11
c could be used to write programs like
the unix operating system that made
efficient use of available memory in
particular the 1978 version of c did not
require that computers support 32-bit
integers
but
32768 is a pretty small number the size
of an integer affected the maximum size
of arrays and strings
a lot of early c programs use the long
type to get at least a 32-bit integer
capable of representing numbers up to
about 2 billion
in modern modern computers and databases
we tend to choose between 32-bit and
64-bit integers
back to the text
c provides several other basic data
types besides int and float
char
is a character a single byte short is a
short integer
long is a long integer and double is a
double precision floating point
size of these objects are also machine
dependent and details are in chapter 2.
there are also arrays structures and
unions of these basic types and pointers
to them and functions that return them
all of which we will meet in due course
the actual computation in our
temperature conversion program begins
with the assignments lower equals zero
upper equals 300 step equals 20
far equals lower all ending with
semicolon
these set the variables to their
starting vari values
individual statements are terminated by
semicolons
each line of the table is computed in
the same way so we use a loop which
repeats once per line this is the
purpose of the while statement
while parentheses far less than or equal
upper close parentheses open curly brace
then the body of the loop and then close
curly brace
the condition in the parentheses is
tested if it is true i.e far is less
than or equal to upper the body of the
loop
all of the statements included between
the open curly brace and the closed
curly brace are executed
and the condition is retested if true
the body is executed again
when the test becomes false i.e
far exceeds upper the loop ends and
execution continues at the statement
that follows the loop
there are no further statements in the
program so it terminates
the body of a while loop can be one or
more statements enclosed in braces as
the temperature converter
or a single statement without braces as
in
while open parentheses i less than j
closed parenthesis i equals two times i
semicolon
in either case the statements controlled
by the while are indented by one tab
stop so you can see at a glance what
statements are inside the loop
the indentation emphasizes the logical
structure of the program
although c is quite permissive about
statement positioning proper indentation
and the use of white space are critical
in making programs easy for people to
read
we recommend writing only one statement
per line and usually leaving blanks
around operators the position of the
braces is less important we have chosen
one of the several popular styles pick a
style that suits you and then use it
consistently
i would add that with these words the
authors triggered a great debate about
how to best indent code and use curly
braces that continues to this day
the intention style used in this book is
often referred to as the k and r style
it tends to put open braces at the end
of statements like if and while to keep
code more compact in terms of the number
of lines of code
the best advice is not to debate at all
when you modify someone else's code just
imitate the style that they used when
they wrote their code
back to the text
most of the work gets done in the body
of the loop
the celsius temperature is computed and
assigned to the celsius variable by the
statement celsius equals open
parenthesis 5.0 slash 9.0 close
parenthesis
asterisk open parenthesis far
minus
32.0 close parentheses semicolon
the reason for using 5.0
9.0 instead of the simpler looking five
slash nine is that in c as in many other
languages
integer division truncates so that any
fractional part is discarded thus
five slash nine
is zero
and of course so would then all the
temperatures be zero
a decimal point in a constant indicates
that it is floating point so that 5.0
over 9.0 is
0.555 repeating which is what we want
we also wrote 32.0 instead of 32
even though since far is a float 32
would automatically be converted to flow
before the subtraction
but as a matter of style it's wise to
write floating point constants with
explicit decimal points even when they
have integral values it emphasizes their
floating point nature for human readers
and ensures the compiler will see things
the way you do as well
i would note that for those of you
familiar with python
before python 3
integer division truncated and returned
an integer just like c
in python 3 one of the major
improvements was that the division of
two integers performed the division
operation in floating point and returns
a floating point result
c and python 2 made the choice because
of efficiency
integer division with truncation
especially for 16-bit numbers was quite
fast in the 1970s computers compared to
floating point division that kept the
fractional part intact
early pdp-11 computers did integer
division in hardware
while all floating point was done with
loops and functions so it was far slower
if you wanted to write fast code in the
1970s you avoided floating point numbers
except for special situations
modern computers usually do 64-bit
floating-point operations almost at the
same speed as integer division so we
don't need to allow programmers to avoid
using floating point computations in
their code
the detailed rules for when integers are
converted to floating point are in
chapter 2.
for now notice that the assignment far
equals lower semicolon
and the test while far less than or
equals upper
both work as expected the int is
converted to a float before the
operation is done
this example also shows a bit more of
how printf works printf is actually a
general purpose format conversion
function
which we will describe completely in
chapter 7.
its first argument is a string of
characters to be printed with each
percent sign indicating where one of the
other second third etc arguments is to
be substituted and what form it is to be
printed in
for instance in the statement
printf
parentheses double quote percent 4.0 f
space percent 6.1 f
backslash n double quote comma far comma
celsius
the conversion specification percent 4.0
f says that a floating point number is
to be printed in a space at least four
characters wide with no digits after the
decimal point percent 6.1 f describes
another number to occupy at least six
spaces with one digit after the decimal
point
analogous to the f 6.1 of fortran
or the f parentheses six comma one of
pl1
parts of a specification may be omitted
percent six f says that the number is to
be at least six characters wide
percent.2f requests two places after the
decimal point but the width is not
constrained
and merely
percent f says to print the number
itself as floating point
printf also recognizes percent d for
decimal integers percent o for octal
percent x for hexadecimal and percent c
for characters and percent s for a
character string and percent percent for
the percent itself
each percent construction in the first
argument of printf is paired with its
corresponding second third etc
argument
they must line up properly by number and
type or else you'll get meaningless
answers
by the way
printf is not part of the c language
there is no input or output defined in c
itself
there is nothing magic about printf it's
just a useful function which is part of
the standard library of routines that
are normally accessible to c programs
in order to concentrate on c itself we
might we won't talk much about io
until chapter seven
in particular we'll defer formatted
input until then
if you have to input numbers read the
discussion of the function scanf in
chapter 7 section 7.4
scanf is much like printf except that it
reads input instead of writing output
the balance between building a feature
into the language itself and providing
it as a function in a library is
something that computer language
designers struggle with many years later
for example in python 2
print was a language element
in python 3 one of the non-upwards
compatible and somewhat unpopular
changes was changing print to be a
function
many programmers feel that a print
statement is a more elegant way to
express printing but from a compiler and
language design perspective a function
call with a variable number of
parameters is seen as technically more
elegant and flexible
with kernighan and richie focused on
keeping everything small and portable
they opted to keep all input output
functionality in libraries the syntax is
a little more complex
but given how computing has changed in
the past 30 years it is the right choice
section 1.3 the for statement
as you might expect there are plenty of
different ways to write a program let's
try a variation on the temperature
converter
this is sample code is on page 11 of the
textbook
pound sign include less than stdio.h
greater than
main open parentheses closed parenthesis
open curly brace
int
bar that is f a h r semicolon
four open parenthesis far equals zero
semicolon
far less than or equal to three hundred
semicolon
far equals far plus 20 close parenthesis
printf
open parentheses
double quote percent 4d space percent
6.1 f backslash n close print a close
quote
comma far
comma open parenthesis 5.0 slash 9.0
close parentheses
asterisk open parenthesis far minus 32
close parentheses close parenthesis
semicolon
this code produces the same answers as
the one before but it certainly looks
different one major change is the
elimination of most of the variables
only far fahr remains as an int to show
the percent d conversion in printf
the lower and upper limits of the step
size appear only as constants in the for
statement itself
the 4 is a new construction and the
expression that computes the celsius
temperature now appears as the third
argument of printf
instead of in a separate assignment
statement
this last change is an instance of a
quite general rule in c in any context
where it is permission permissible to
use the value of a variable of some type
you can use an expression of that type
since the third argument of printf has
to be a floating point value to match
the percent 6.1 f
any floating point expression can occur
there
the 4 itself is a loop a generalization
of while
if you compare it to the earlier while
its operation should be clear
it contains three parts separated by
semicolons the first part far equals
zero is done once
before the loop proper is entered the
second part is the test or condition
that controls the loop
far less than or equal to 300.
this condition is evaluated if it is
true the body of a loop in this case a
single printf is executed then the
reinitialization step
far equals far plus 20 is done and the
condition is reevaluated
the loop terminates when the condition
becomes false
as with the while the body of the loop
can be a single statement or a group of
statements enclosed in braces
the initialization and re-initialization
parts can be any single expression
the choice between while and four is
arbitrary and should be based on what
seems clearer
the four is usually appropriate for
loops in which the initialization and
reinitialization
are single statements and logically
related since it is more compact than
while and keeps the loop control
statements together in one place
i would note that the syntax of the for
and while loop is a feature of c and
derived c like languages
in modern languages we tend to have two
kinds of loop structures
determinant and indeterminate
the four and the while loop structures
in c are both indeterminate because you
must read them closely to make sure they
are properly constructed and for example
are not unintentionally infinite loops
an example of a determinant loop is the
for each loop in php or the for loop in
python the semantics of both of these
loops is to iterate all the elements in
a collection
but since collections are never infinite
you can be assured that these
determinant loops will not run forever
section 1.4 symbolic constants
a final observation before we leave
temperature conversion
it's a bad practice to bury magic
numbers or magic constants like 320
or
320 in a program they convey little
information to someone who might read
the program later and they're hard to
change in a systematic way
fortunately
c provides a way to avoid such magic
numbers
with the pound sign defined construction
at the beginning of a program we can
define a symbolic name or symbolic
constant to be a particular string of
characters thereafter the compiler will
replace all unquoted occurrences of the
name by the corresponding string
the replacement for the name can
actually be any text at all it's not
related to numbers
so this is a sample code on page 13 of
the text
pound sign include
less than stdio.h greater than
next line pound define space lower space
zero
next line pound define space upper space
300
pound define space step space 20.
for these pound sign statements i would
note
that they have to start in the first
column
the rest of this sample code is the code
itself
main open parenthesis closed parenthesis
open curly brace
int
far fahr
for
open parentheses far equals uppercase
lower
semicolon far less than or equal to
uppercase upper
semicolon far equals far plus uppercase
step then the same print statement
printf
open parentheses double quote percent 4d
space percent 6.1 f backslash n quote
comma
far
comma
percent 5.0 9.0
close parentheses asterisk open
parenthesis
far minus 32 close parenthesis close
parenthesis semicolon and then to end
the program close curly brace the
quantities uppercase lower uppercase
upper and uppercase step are constants
so they do not appear in declarations
symbolic names are commonly written in
uppercase so they can be readily
distinguished from lowercase variable
names
notice that there is no semicolon at the
end of a pound defined statement
since the whole line after the defined
name is substituted there would be too
many semicolons in the four
section 1.5 a collection of useful
programs
we are now going to consider a family of
related programs for doing simple
operations on character data
you will find that many programs are
just expanded versions of the prototypes
we discuss here
character input and output
the standard library provides functions
for reading and writing a character at a
time getchar
fetches the next input character each
time it is called and returns the
character as its value that is
after c equals get char open parentheses
close parenthesis the variable c
contains the next character of input
these characters normally come from the
terminal or keyboard but that need not
concern us until chapter 7.
the function put char open parentheses c
close parenthesis is the complement of
getchar
put chair open parenthesis c close
parenthesis
prints the content of the variable c on
some output medium again usually the
terminal or screen
calls to put char in printf may be
interleaved the output may be a p will
appear in the order in which the calls
are made as with printf there is nothing
special about gachar and putchar they
are not part of the c language but they
are universally available
once again i would note that the authors
are making the case that the syntax of
the language should not include syntax
for input output operations but instead
call library functions
keeping the compiler small and easy to
port new systems was important to the
creators of c
and even if something like put char was
part of the language syntax it would be
translated at runtime to call a function
programming languages from the 1960s
tended to have a small set of use cases
read some input run some calculation and
then write some output
so it seemed like a few language
elements would be sufficient to describe
all programs
but as programs started to make network
connections draw buttons on a screen or
respond to api calls over the network
it would have been difficult to keep
expanding the core language syntax for
each new use case
but it was extremely natural to add new
libraries to languages like c with
functions to call to accomplish these
new use cases
file copying given getchar input char
you can write a surprising amount of
useful code without knowing anything
more about input output the simplest
example is a program which copies its
input to its output one character at a
time in outline here's what we do
get a character
while the character is not the end of
file signal
i'll put the character we just read and
then get a new character
converting this into c gives us the
sample code on page 14 of the textbook
pound includes stdio.h
main open parentheses closed parentheses
open curly brace
int
c
semicolon c equals get char open
parenthesis close parenthesis semicolon
while c
not equal eof uppercase eof close
parenthesis open curly brace put char c
c equals get char semicolon close
parentheses close curly brace
the relational
operator exclamation equals means not
equal to
the main problem is detecting the end of
the input by convention getchar returns
the value which is a not a valid
character when it encounters the end of
input
in this way programs can detect when
they did not get a character and they've
actually simply run out of input
the only complication which is a serious
nuisance is that there are two
conventions in common use about what
that endophile value really is
we have deferred this issue by using the
symbolic name eof capital eof for the
value whatever it might be
in practice eof will be either negative
one or zero so the program must be pro
seated by the appropriate pound define
eof -1 or pound-defying eof0 to work
properly by using the symbolic constant
eof to represent the value that getcha
returns when the end of file occurs we
are assured that only one thing in the
program defines on the specific depends
on the specific value
numeric value of eof
i would
note most of that is incorrect modern c
compilers actually define eof in the
stdio.h include file so you never define
eof in your code
in modern c the value of eof is minus
one
you should just include stdio.h and use
predefined eof constant to check for end
to file
the nuisance of different values for eof
was resolved shortly after 1978.
continuing with the text
we also declare c to be an int not a
chair char so that it can hold the value
which get char returns as we'll see in
chapter two the value is actually an int
because it must be capable of
representing and defile in addition to
all possible characters
so the program for copying could
actually be written more concisely by
experienced c programmers in c
any assignment such as c equals get char
open parentheses close parenthesis can
be used in an expression
its value is simply the residual value
being assigned to the left hand side
if the assignment of a character to the
variable c is put inside the test part
of a while statement the file copy
program can be written as shown in the
example code on page 15 of the textbook
pound include stdio.h
main open parenthesis close parenthesis
open curly brace
int space c semicolon
while open parenthesis open parenthesis
c equals get char open parenthesis close
parenthesis close parenthesis not equal
eof close parenthesis put char c
parentheses c close parenthesis
semicolon close curly brace
the program gets a character assigns it
to c and then tests whether the
character was the end of file signal
if it was not the body of the wireless
executed printing the character
the while then repeats when the input is
end of input is finally reached the wild
terminal terminates and so does main
this virtual version centralizes the
input there is now only one call to get
char and shrinks the program
nesting an assignment is a test of one
of the places where c
permits a valuable conciseness it is
possible to get carried away and create
impenetrable code
though a tendency that we will try
though that is a tendency we will try to
curb
it's important to recognize that the
parentheses around the assignment within
the conditional are really necessary the
precedence of exclamation equal not
equals is higher than that of equals the
assignment operator which means that in
absence of parentheses the relational
test exclamation equals would be done
before the assignment
equals
so the statement
c equals get char parentheses open
parentheses close parenthesis not equal
eof is equivalent to
c equals get char open no sorry
is equivalent to
c equals open parenthesis get char open
press the close parenthesis not equal
eof
close parenthesis
this has the undefined desired effect of
setting
[Music]
it is important to recognize that the
parentheses around the assignment within
the conditional are really necessary the
precedence of exclamation equals is
higher than that of
equals which means that in the absence
of parentheses the relational test not
equals would be done before the
assignment so the statement c equals get
char not equal eof is equivalent to
c equals open parenthesis getchar not
equal eof close parenthesis
this has the undesired effect of setting
c to zero or one depending on whether or
not the call of getchar encountered the
end of file
more on this in chapter 2.
the next program counts characters it is
a small elaboration of the copy program
this sample code is on page 16 of the
textbook
pound include stdio.h
main open parenthesis close parenthesis
open curly brace
long
nc semicolon
and c equals 0 semicolon
while
open parenthesis get char open
parentheses close parenthesis
exclamation equal eof
plus plus nc semicolon
printf
double quote percent ld backslash n
double quote comma nc parentheses
semicolon close curly brace
the statement plus plus nc semicolon
shows a new operator plus plus
which means increment by one
you could write nc equals nc plus one
but plus plus nc is more concise and
often more efficient there is a
corresponding operator minus minus to
decrement by one
the operators plus plus
and minus minus can either be prefix
operators
plus plus c and c or postfix
and c plus plus
these two forms have different values
and expressions as will be shown in
chapter two but plus plus nc and nc plus
plus
both increment and c for the moment
we'll stick to the prefix form
the character counting program
accumulates its count in a long variable
instead of an int
on a pdp 11 the maximum value of an int
is 32
767 and it would take relatively little
input to overflow that counter if it
were declared as an int in honeywell and
ibm c
long and int are synonymous and much
larger the conversion specification
percent ld signals to printf that the
corresponding argument is a long integer
we again as a note we again see another
reference to the fact that the number of
bits of the int type is in transition in
1978.
the older pdp-11 used a 16-bit integer
to save limited memory on a small
almost obsolete computer while later
computers from ibm and honeywell have
already switched to their int type to be
32 bits this allowed code originally for
written for the pdp-11 like unix or even
the c compiler to be recompiled on the
ibm or honeywell with very few changes
to cope with bigger numbers you can use
a double which is a double length float
we will also use a for statement instead
of a while to illustrate an alternate
way to write a while loop
this code is the second sample code on
page 16 of the textbook
pound include stdio.h
main open parentheses closed parentheses
open curly brace
double
nc semicolon four open parenthesis nc
equals zero semicolon
get our open parenthesis close
parenthesis not equal eof semicolon plus
plus nc
close parenthesis
and then a semicolon the semicolon in
this case is an empty statement because
there's nothing in the body of the of
the for loop and at the end we say
printf double quote
percent dot zero f backslash n
double quote comma nc close parentheses
semicolon
close curly bracket
printf uses percent f for both float and
double
percent.0f
suppresses printing of the non-existent
fraction part
the body of the for loop here is empty
because all the work is done in the test
and reinitialization parts of the for
loop
but the grammatical rules of c require
that a for statement have a body the
isolated simply semicolon technically a
null statement is there to satisfy that
syntax requirement we put it on a
separate line to make it more visible
before we leave the character counting
program observe that if the input
contains no characters the while or for
test fails on the very first call to get
char so that the loop program produces
zero the right answer
this is an important observation
one of the nice things about while and
four is they are tested at the top of
the loop proceed before proceeding with
the body
if there is nothing to do
nothing is done
even if that means never going through
the loop body
programs should act intelligently
when hand handed input like no
characters
the while and the four statements help
ensure that they do reasonable things
with boundary conditions
line counting the next program counts
lines in its input input lines are
assumed to be terminated by the newline
character backslash n that has been
carefully appended to every line written
out
this is sample code on line 17 of the
textbook
pound includes
stdio.h
main open parenthesis close parenthesis
open curly brace
int
c comma nl semicolon
nl equals zero semicolon
while
open parenthesis open parenthesis c
equals get char open parentheses close
parenthesis close parenthesis not equal
eof close parenthesis
if open parenthesis c
double equals single quote backslash n
single quote close parentheses
plus plus nl semicolon
printf
double quote percent d backslash n
double quote comma nl
close parentheses semicolon close curly
brace
the body of the while loop now consists
of an if
which in turn controls the increment
plus plus nl
the if statement tests its parenthesized
condition and if true does the statement
or group of statements inside braces
that follow
we have again indented to show what is
controlled by what
the double equal sign in is the c
notation for is equal to like fortrans
dot eq dot
this symbol is used to distinguish the
equality test
the question being asked from the single
equal sign used for assignment
since assignment is about twice as
frequently used as equality testing in
typical c programs
it's appropriate that the operator be
half as long
a single character can be written
between single quotes to produce a value
equal to the numerical value of the
character in the machine's character set
this is called a character constant
so for example single quote a single
quote is a character constant in the
ascii character set its value is 65 the
internal representation of the character
a
of course
double single quote a single quote is to
be preferred over 65 its meaning is
obvious and it is independent of a
particular character set
these escape sequences that are used in
character strings are also legal in
character constants so in tests and
arithmetic expression expressions
single quote backslash n single quote
stands for the value of a new line
character
you should note carefully that single
quote backslash n is a single quer
character
and an expressions is equivalent to a
single integer on the other hand double
quote backslash n double quote is a
character string which happens to
contain only one character the topics of
strings versus characters is discussed
further in chapter two
the numeric values that are shown for
characters are using the ascii character
set
the character sets in the 1970s were
quite intricate most were eight bits
long to conserve computer memory and
only support a hundred or so latin-like
characters
this is why early programming languages
use special characters like asterisk and
curly brace in their syntax very
carefully they needed to choose
characters
that were commonly available on computer
keyboards from different manufacturers
modern programming languages like python
3 and ruby store internal string values
using the unicode character set so they
are all able to represent all the
characters in all languages around the
world
modern languages tend to represent 8-bit
values in the range from 0 to 256 using
a byte or similar type
python 2 strings were stored as 8 bit
bytes and python 3 strings are stored as
32-bit unicode characters
moving to unicode was a major effort in
the python 2 to python 3 transition
word counting
the fourth in our series of useful
programs counts lines words and
characters
with a loose definition that a word is
any sequence of characters that does not
contain a blank a tab or a new line
this is a very very bare bones version
of the unix utility wc
this example is on
page 18 in the textbook
pound include stdio.h pound define yes
1 pound to find no
0.
main
open parenthesis close parenthesis open
curly brace
int
c comma nl comma nw comma nc come in
word
inward equals no
l equals nw equals nc equals zero
while
open parenthesis open parenthesis c
equals get char
not equal to eof
open curly brace plus plus nc
if
parentheses c double equals
quote backslash n quote parenthesis plus
plus nl
if
open parenthesis c
double equals
single quote space single quote
double vertical bar
c
double equals
single quote backslash n
single quote
double vertical bar
c
equals equals
single quote backslash t
single quote close parenthesis
inward equals no
else if open parenthesis inward
equal equal no
close parenthesis open curly brace
inward equals yes semicolon plus plus nw
semicolon
close curly brace close curly brace
printf
open parenthesis
double quote percent d space percent d
space percent d backslash n double quote
comma
nl
comma nw comma nc close
curly brace
every time the program encounters the
first character of a word it counts it
the variable inward records whether the
program is currently in a word or not
initially it is not in a word which
which is assigned the value no
we prefer the symbolic constants yes and
no to the literal values one and zero
because they make the program more
readable
of course in a program as tiny as this
it makes little difference but in larger
programs the increase of clarity is well
worth the modest
effort to write it this way to make it
more readable
you will also find that it's easier to
make changes to programs where numbers
appear only as symbolic constants
the line
nl
equals nw equals nc equals zero
sets all three variables to zero this is
not a special case
but a consequence of the fact that an
assignment has a value and assignments
associate right to left
it's really as if we had written nc
equals open parenthesis nl equals open
parenthesis nw equals zero close
parentheses close parenthesis semicolon
the operator double vertical bar
vertical bar vertical bar means or so
the line
if open parenthesis
c double equals
single quote space single quote vertical
bar vertical bar c double equals single
quote backslash n single quote double
vertical bar c double equals quote
backslash t
quote parenthesis says
if c is a blank or c is a new line or c
is a tab
the escape sequence backslash t is a
visible representation of the tab
character
there is a corresponding operator which
is double ampersand for and
expressions connected by
double ampersand or double vertical bar
are evaluated left to right and it is
guaranteed that the evaluation will stop
as true as true soon as the truth or
falsehood for the overall expression is
known
thus if c contains a blank there is no
need to test whether contends contains a
new line or tab so these tests are not
made this isn't particularly important
here but is very significant in more
complicated situations as we will soon
see
i would note that the double vertical
bar and double ampersand are the norm
for boolean operators in c like
languages when a new language was being
designed it was really easy to just
adopt the c convention for logical
operators because while they may seem
cryptic
millions of software developers were
already familiar with the operators in
this way the relationship between c and
c like languages is like the
relationship between latin and romance
languages including english
back to the text
the example also shows the c else
statement which specifies an alternative
action to be done if the condition part
of an if statement is false the general
form is
if
open parenthesis expression close
parenthesis statement one
else statement two
one and only one of the two statements
associated with an if then else is done
if the expression is true statement one
is executed if not statement two is
executed
each statement can actually be in fact
quite complicated in the word count
problem the one after the else is an if
that controls two statements in braces
section 1.6 arrays
understanding the capabilities and
limitations of c arrays is one of the
most important topics
in our historical look at the c
programming language
most importantly the number of elements
in an array declaration must be a
constant at compile time and the size of
an array cannot be adjusted using an
array declaration while the program's
running
this inability to automatically resize c
arrays as data is added leads to a class
of security laws that are generally
referred to as buffer overflow where a
program reads more data in that can fit
into an array and is tricked to
overriding other data or code in
compromising an application
later in this book we will create
dynamic array-like structures in c using
pointers and the standard library cialoc
function
python has support for a non-dynamic
arrays buffers python buffers are
generally not used except for
programmers writing library code
that talks to low-level code written in
a language other than python or talking
to operating system things like linux
the more commonly used python list and
dictionary structures can change their
sizes automatically
as elements are added and deleted at
runtime
java has support for non-dynamic arrays
like c which are
given a length at the moment they are
created and the array length cannot be
increased nor decreased without making a
new array and copying all the elements
from the first to the second array
java does provide list and map
structures that automatically adjust
their length as data is added or removed
java has a class called arraylist which
can be dynamically extended but provides
array-like linear access
it is a list internally but it can be
used like an array externally
the underlying technique that is used to
implement language structures like
python's list
is dynamic memory allocation in a linked
list structure
linked lists are one of the most
important data structures in all of
computer science
we will cover dynamic allocation and
implementing data structures in c
in chapter 6.
for now we will merely examine the
syntax of c arrays but keep in mind that
allocating an array in c is very
different than creating a list
in python
back to the text
let us write a program to count the
number of occurrences of each digit of
white space characters blank tab and new
line and all other characters
this is an artificial problem to solve
but it permits us to illustrate several
aspects of c
in one program
there are 12 categories of input so it
is convenient
to use an array to hold the number of
occurrences of each digit rather than 10
individual variables
actually 12 individual variables
here is one version of the program on
page 21
in the textbook
and i would note that
as these programs get larger and larger
it is harder and harder for you to just
listen to me read them and you have to
go look at them in the textbook
so i recommend that you go check out the
textbook in page 20 and find this
actual code
found include
io dot h
main open parenthesis closed parenthesis
open curly brace
int
c
comma i comma n white comma n other
semicolon int
n digit
open square bracket 10 close square
bracket semicolon
and white equals n other equals 0
semicolon
4 open parenthesis i equals 0 semicolon
i less than 10 semicolon plus plus i
open let me close parenthesis
end digit open square bracket
i close square bracket equals zero
semicolon
now we're going to have a loop to read
all of our input
while double open parentheses c equals
get char open parenthesis close
parentheses and another closed
parenthesis not equal eof close
parenthesis
if open parentheses c greater than or
equal to
single quote 0 single quote
double ampersand
c less than or equal single quote 9
single quote close parenthesis
plus plus
in digit
open square bracket c minus single quote
0 single quote close square bracket
semicolon
else if
open parenthesis c double equals space
quote space quote
or double vertical bar c double equals
single quote backslash n single quote
double vertical bar c double equals
single quote backslash t single quote
close parenthesis
plus plus
and white
semicolon
else plus plus in other
that if statement was a sort of three
branches if checking to see if we were
doing a digit
a white space character or some other
character
at the end of the while loop or not the
end of the while loop and so we say
printf
parentheses double quote digits equals
double quote close parenthesis semicolon
now we'll note in this that there is no
new line so we can have these print defs
kind of concatenate outward without
going to a separate line
four parenthesis i equals zero semicolon
i less than 10 semicolon plus plus i
close parenthesis
printf
double quote space percent d double
quote
comma n digit
open square bracket i close square
bracket close parenthesis semicolon
printf open parenthesis
double quote backslash n white space
equals percent d
comma other equals percent d backslash n
double quote comma
and white comma n other closed
parentheses semicolon close curly brace
let's go through the code
the declaration int in digit open square
bracket 10 closed square bracket
semicolon declares n digit to be an
array of 10 integers
array of subscripts always start and 0
in c rather than 1 as in fortran or pl1
so the elements are end digit sub zero
and digit sub one dot dot dot end digit
sub nine
square brackets are the sub
this is reflected in the for loops which
initialize and print the array
a subscript can be integer any integer
expression which of course includes
integer variables like i and integer
constants
this particular program
relies heavily on the properties of
character representation of the digits
for example
if c greater than or equal to single
quote 0 single quote double ampersand c
less than or equal to single quote 9
single quote close parenthesis
determines whether it's a digit
that is if the numeric value of the
digit
and the numeric value of the digit is
c minus double quote 0 double quote this
only works if double quote 0 double
quote 1
etc are positive and increasing order
and there's nothing but digits between 0
and 9.
fortunately this is true for all
conventional character sets
by definition
arithmetic involving chars and ends
converts everything to int before
proceeding so char variables and
constants are identically
essentially identical to instant
arithmetic contexts
this is quite natural and convenient for
example c minus single quote 0 single
quote is an integer expression that
gives us a value between 0 and 9 an
integer value between 0 and 9
corresponding to the character quote 0
quote to quote 9 quote stored in c and
is thus a valid subscript for the ten
element array and digit
the decision as to whether the character
is a digit a white space or something
else is made by the sequence if open
parenthesis c greater than or equal to
quote zero quote double ampersand c less
than or equal
quote zero quote i quote nine quote
close parentheses
plus plus end digit open square bracket
c minus quote zero quote close bracket
semicolon else if
c double equals single quote or
c double equals single quote backslash n
or c double equals single quote
backslash t
plus plus n white else
plus plus and other
the pattern
if
in parentheses condition statement else
if parentheses conditions statement
else statement occurs frequently in
programs as a way to express a multi-way
decision the code is simply read from
the top of the bot to until the bottom
until some condition is satisfied at
that point the corresponding statement
part is executed and the entire
construction is finished
of course
statement can be several statements in
closed embraces
if none of the conditions are satisfied
the statement after the final else is
executed if present
if the final else and statement are
omitted as in the word count program no
action takes place
there can be an arbitrary number of else
if
condition
statements groups between the initial if
and the final else
as a matter of style it is advisable to
format this construction as we have
shown with proper indentation so that
long decisions do not march off the
right side of the page
the switch statement to be discussed in
chapter 3 provides another way to write
multi-way branching that is particularly
suitable when the condition being tested
is simply whether some integer or
character expression
matches one of a set of constants
for contrast we will present a switch
version of this program in chapter three
functions in c a function is equivalent
to a subroutine or function in fortran
or a procedure in pl1 pascal etc
a function provides a convenient way to
encapsulate some computation in a black
box which can then be used without
worrying about its innards
functions are really the only way to
cope with the potential complexity of
large programs
with properly designed functions it is
possible to ignore how a job gets done
knowing what is done is sufficient
c is designed to make the use of
functions easy convenient and efficient
you will often see a function only a few
lines long called only once just because
it clarifies some piece of code
so far we have used functions like
printf
getchar and put char
that have been provided for us
now it's time to write a few of our own
since c has no exponentiation operator
like the double asterisk of fortran or
pl1
let us illustrate the mechanics of
function definition by writing a
function
power open parenthesis m comma n close
parenthesis to raise an integer
into a positive power n
that is the value of power parentheses 2
comma 5 is 32.
this function certainly doesn't do the
whole job of
exponentiation since it only handles
positive powers of small integers
but it is best to confuse only one issue
at a time
here is the function power and a main
program to exercise it so you can see
the whole structure at once
this sample code is on page 23 of the
textbook
pound include stdio.h
main open curly brace
int i semicolon
for for parenthesis i equals 0 semicolon
i less than 10 semicolon plus plus i
close parentheses
printf
double quote percent d space percent d
space percent d backslash n double quote
comma
i comma power open parenthesis two comma
i close parenthesis comma
power
open parenthesis negative three comma i
close parenthesis close parenthesis
semicolon close curly brace the end of
the main now we begin the function
power open parenthesis x comma n close
parenthesis
int
x comma n semicolon open curly brace
int i comma p
p equals one
four
open parenthesis i equals 1 semicolon i
less than or equal to n semicolon plus
plus i
p equals p times x semicolon return open
parenthesis p close parenthesis
semicolon close curly brace
each function has the same form
function name open parenthesis argument
list if any
followed by argument declarations
if any
followed by the body of the function
which includes declarations and
statements
the functions can appear in either order
and in one source file or two
if of course the source file appears in
two files you will have to say more to
compile and load it when it fall appears
in one but that's an operating system
matter not a language attribute
for the moment we'll just assume that
both function functions are in the same
file so whatever you learned about c
programs running them will not change
the function power is called twice in
the line printf open parenthesis double
quote percent d space percent d space
percent d backslash n double quote comma
i comma power open parenthesis two comma
i close parenthesis comma power open
parenthesis negative three comma i close
parenthesis close parenthesis
each call passes two arguments to the
power function which each time returns
an integer to be formatted and printed
in the expression power open parenthesis
two comma i
is just an integer
as two and i are
not all functions produce an integer
value and we'll take this up in more
detail in chapter four
in power
the arguments have to be cleared
appropriately so their types are known
before the beginning of the body of the
function
this is done by the line int x comma n
semicolon
that follows the function name
the argument declarations go between the
argument list and the opening left brace
each declaration is terminated by a
semicolon the names used for power and
for its arguments are purely local to
power and not accessible to any other
functions
other routines can use the same names
for their variables without conflict
this is also true of the variables i and
p within the function the i in power is
unrelated to the i in main
the value that power
computes is returned to main by the
return statement
which is just as in pl1 any expression
must occur within the parentheses
a function need not return a value a
return statement with no expression
causes control but no useful value to be
returned to the call caller as does
falling off the end of a function by
reaching the terminating right curly
brace
section 1.8 arguments call by value
one aspect of c function which may be
unfamiliar to programmers who are used
to other languages particularly fortran
and pl1
in c all function arguments are passed
by value
this means that the called function is
given the values of its arguments in
temporary variables actually on a stack
rather than their addresses
this leads to some different properties
than are seen with call by reference
languages like fortran and pl1
in which the called routine has handled
the address of the argument not its
value
it may seem strange
that the authors are calling so much
attention to the fact that function
arguments are passed call by value in
the very first chapter
most modern programming languages like
python php or java pass single value
arguments by value by default
and to pass in an argument by reference
you need to do something special like
adding the ampersand in the function
declaration in php
passing by reference was the norm before
c and passing by value was the norm
after c
since modern languages were deeply
influenced by and often written in c
passing by value is the norm for modern
languages
it's nice because it isolates the data
in the calling code from the called code
so the called code can't easily mess
with its arguments either intentionally
or by mistake and create an unexpected
side effect and possibly a bug or
security flaw in the calling code
it was a bit of work to make pass by
value work and see c implements a call
stack
where a bit of memory is automatically
allocated at each function call and c
makes a copy of the values in the
calling code to pass them into the call
code in a way that the calling code can
see the values and change their local
copies without affecting the values in
the calling code
the same call stack that made it
possible
for c function arguments to be passed by
value
also made it possible for a function to
call itself
recursively fortran functions could not
be called recursively until the 1990
version of fortran
if you know your python you know that
simple variables like integers and
strings are passed by value while
structured data like dictionaries and
lists are passed by reference i.e the
called function can modify its arguments
we will later see this in c as well
talking about call stacks recursive
functions and the fact that arrays and
structures are called by reference is
jumping ahead somewhat
so for now
let's just remember the author's point
that normal valuable
values like integers and floats
are passed by value in c back to the
text
the main distinction is that in c the
called function cannot alter a variable
in the calling function it can only
alter its private temporary copy
call by value is an asset however not a
liability
it usually leads to more compact
programs with fewer extraneous variables
because arguments can be treated as
conveniently initialized local variables
in the called routine
for example here is a version of power
which makes use of this fact
this code is on page 24 of the text
power
open parenthesis x comma n close
parenthesis
and
x comma n semicolon open curly brace int
i comma p semicolon
for
open parenthesis p equals one semicolon
n greater than zero semicolon minus
minus n close parentheses
p
equals p times x
semicolon
return open parenthesis p close
parenthesis semicolon
close curly brace the argument n is used
as a temporary variable and is counted
down until it becomes zero
there is no longer a need for the
variable i as in the previous example
whatever is done to end inside the power
function has no effect on the argument
that power was originally called with
when necessary it is possible to arrange
for a function to modify the variable in
the calling routine
the caller must provide the address of
their variable to be set technically a
pointer to the variable
and the called function must declare the
argument to be a pointer and reference
the actual variable indirectly through
it
we will cover this in detail in chapter
5.
when the name of an array is used as an
argument the value passed to the
function is actually the location
or address of the beginning of the array
there is no copying of the elements in
the array
by subscripting this value the function
can access and alter
any element of the array in the calling
code
this is the topic of the next section
now i would recommend that you're
careful looking at the code samples in
the rest of this chapter recall
that in c array sizes do not grow and
shrink dynamically at all after they're
allocated the authors statically
allocate character arrays capable of
handling up to 1 000 characters long
their code works but it is somewhat
brittle so look at the next two sections
as examples of c syntax with many
important concepts about character
strings stored as arrays and calling
patterns when passing arrays to
functions as parameters that but not
exactly the best practice when handling
dynamically sized data
back to the text
probably the most common type of array
in c is an array of characters to
illustrate the use of character arrays
and functions to manipulate them let's
write a program that reads a set of
lines and prints the longest the basic
outline is simple enough
while there's another line
if it's longer than the previous longest
save it and its length and at the very
end print the longest line
the outline makes it clear that the
program divides naturally into pieces
one piece gets a new line another checks
it another saves it and then the rest
controls the process
since things divide so nicely it'd be
it would be well to write them that way
too
accordingly let's write first a separate
function called getline to fetch the
next line of input this is a
generalization of getchar
to make the function useful in other
contexts we'll try to make it as
flexible as possible
at the minimum
getline has to return a signal but
possible end of file
a more generally useful design would be
to return the length of the lan
line or zero if the end of file is
encountered
zero is never a valid line length since
every line has at least one character
even a line containing only a new line
has length one
i would note that here in chapter one we
have changed the book's original use of
the function name getline to get
underscore line in the code examples
because it conflicts with stead the
stdio.h
that defines getline as a library
function
in this chapter the authors are
providing examples around function
naming and linking in later chapters
code samples will simply use the
built-in git line without an underscore
to read an input
when we find a line that is longer than
the previous longest it must be saved
somewhere this suggests a second
function copy to copy the new line to a
safe place
finally we need a main program to
control getline and copy
here is the result
the sample code for this is on page 26.
and it's a bit long so you might want to
show take a look at the sample code in a
browser
pound include stdio.h
pound define max line 1000
main
open for an enclosed paren
open curly brace
int len
semicolon which is the current line
length
int max semicolon which is the maximum
length we've seen so far
char
line open square bracket
max line close square bracket semicolon
a character array that's the current
input line
and then char
save
open square bracket max line close
square bracket semicolon
which is a character array that has the
longest line where we're going to save
it
onto the code
max equals zero
while
open parenthesis open parenthesis len
equals get line open parenthesis line
comma max line close parenthesis close
parenthesis greater than zero
if
len is greater than max
open curly brace max equals len to save
it and then copy line comma save
close curly brace
if open parenthesis max greater than
zero
i.e there was a line
print f open parenthesis
double quote percent s
double quote comma save
close curly brace to end the main
program
now we're in the first function
get line open parenthesis s comma limb
close parenthesis
char
s open bracket close bracket semicolon
since it's being passed in as an
argument
we don't need to know the length of it
and the
next argument is int
lim semicolon so getline takes
a character array
of unknown length and a limit that tells
us the length of the character array
open curly brace
int
c comma i semicolon
four
open parenthesis i equals zero semicolon
i less than lim minus one
double ampersand
parenthesis
c equals get char open parentheses close
parenthesis close parenthesis not equal
e o f
and
double ampersand c not equal
single quote backslash n back
single quote semicolon plus plus i
and in the body of the loop it's s
open square bracket i closed square
bracket equals c
from now on i'll read that s sub i
equals c
at the end of the loop we say if open
parenthesis c double equals single quote
backslash n single quote close
parenthesis open curly brace
s sub i equals c
plus plus i close curly brace
s sub i equals quote backslash zero
quote semicolon
return open parenthesis i close
parenthesis semicolon
close curly brace and that's the end of
the get line function
and now we're on to the copy function
copy open parenthesis s1
s2 close parenthesis the purpose of this
function is copy s1 to s2 assume that s2
is big enough
the declaration is char s1
open square bracket close square bracket
comma s2 open square bracket close
square bracket
a note these arrays have a size we just
don't know what they are and we hope
that they're large enough
the body of the copy function starts
with open curly brace
int i
semicolon
i equals zero
while
open parenthesis open parenthesis s two
sub i equals s one sub i close
parenthesis not equal
single quote backslash zero single quote
plus plus i
close curly brace to end the copy
function
main and getline communicate both
through a pair of arguments and a
returned value in getline the arguments
are declared by the lines char
s
open square bracket close square bracket
semicolon int
lim semicolon
which specify that the first argument is
an array
of unknown length and the second is an
integer
the length of the array s is not
specified in getline since it's
determined in main
getline
uses return to send a value back to the
caller just as the function power did
some functions return a useful value
others like copy are only used for their
effect and return no value
getline puts the character backslash 0
the null character whose integer value
is zero at the end of the array it's
creating to mark the end of the string
of characters
this convention is also used by the c
compiler
with a when a string constant like
double quote
h-e-l-l-o backslash n double quote is
written in a c program the compiler
creates an array of characters
containing the characters of the string
and adds a backslash zero
at the end to terminate it so that
functions such as printf can detect the
end
so
that would lead to an array that has
h e
l
l o backslash n backslash zero so it's a
five character array
with a new line which is a sixth
character and then backslash zero which
is an actual character again
we don't know the arrays don't know
their length and so you use the
backslash 0
as the indicator of the end of a string
the percent s format specification in
printf expects a string represented in
exactly this form if you examine copy
you will discover that it too relies on
the fact that its input argument s1 is
terminated by backslash zero
and it copies this character backslash
zero
into the argument
output argument s2
all of this implies that backslash 0
is not part of normal text it's merely a
marker
it is worth mentioning in passing
that even a program as small as this one
presents some sticky design problems
for example
what should maine do if it encounters a
line which is bigger than its limit
getline
works properly and then it stops
collecting when the array is full
even if no new line has been seen
by testing the length in the last
character returned main can determine
whether the line was too long then cope
with it as it wishes
in interest of brevity we have ignored
this issue
there is also no way for a user of
getline function to know in advance how
long an input line might be
so getline checks for overflow on the
other hand a user of the copy function
already knows or should be able to find
out how big the strings are so we have
have chosen not to add error checking to
it
section
section 1.10 scope
external variables
the variables in main
line save etc are private or local to
main
because they are declared within main no
other function can have direct access to
them
the same is true of the variables in the
other functions for example the variable
i in getline is unrelated to the i in
copy
each local variable in a routine comes
into existence only when a function is
called and disappears when the function
is exited
it is for this reason that such
variables are usually known as automatic
variables following terminology in other
languages
we'll use the term automatic henceforth
to refer to these dynamic local
variables
chapter 4 discusses the static storage
class in which local variables do retain
their values between function
invocations
because automatic variables come and go
with function in invocation
they do not retain their values from one
call to the next and must be explicitly
set upon each entry
if they are not set they will contain
garbage
as an alternative to automatic variables
it is possible to define variables which
are external to all functions that is
global variables which can be accessed
by name by any function that cares to
this function is rather like fortran
common or pl1 external
because external variables are globally
accessible they can be used instead of
arguments to communicate data between
functions furthermore because external
variables remain in existence
permanently rather than appearing and
disappearing as functions are called and
exited they retain their values even
after the functions that set them are
done
an external variable has to be defined
outside of any function this allocates
actual storage for it the function also
must be declared and each function that
wants to access it
this may be done either by an explicit
extern declaration or implicitly by
context
to make the discussion concrete let's
rewrite the longest line program with
line save and max
as external variables this requires
changing the calls declarations and
bodies of all three functions
this sample code is on page 29 of the
textbook and it's pretty long but i'll
read it for you pound include stdio.h
pound define max line 1000.
and we're still outside of main char
line
open bracket max line close bracket
semicolon
char save open bracket max line
semicolon
int max semicolon those are our three
global variables
starting the main
main open friend close paren
open curly brace
intlen
extern int max so we're saying that this
is an integer but it's also not to be
allocated inside of main
extern char save
open
square bracket close square bracket
the line length the length of the save
array is defined above so we don't need
to define it here
max equals zero semicolon
while
double parenthesis land double left
parenthesis len equals get line
parenthesis greater than zero
parenthesis
if parenthesis len greater than max
open curly brace
max equals len
copy open parenthesis no parenthesis
semicolon no parameters to copy
because it's going to simply talk to the
global variables
close curly brace
after the loop finishes we say if open
parenthesis max greater than zero
then printf
open parentheses double quote percent s
double quote comma save
close parenthesis semicolon
close close curly brace and that is the
end of the main
so now we have the getline function
which is specialized to deal with
external variables
okay
so
we start get line open parentheses close
parenthesis no parameters open curly
brace int comma c comma int c comma i
semicolon these are local variables
extern char line open curly brace closed
curly brace semicolon
this is the our reference inside of
getline to the global variable line
four open parenthesis i equals 0
semicolon i less than max line minus 1
max line minus 1 max line is a
predefined constant at compile time
for i less than max line -1 double
ampersand parenthesis c equals get char
open parenthesis close parenthesis close
parenthesis not equal eof
double ampersand
i.e and
c not equal single quote backslash n
single quote semicolon plus plus i
lines sub i equals c
that's the for loop that in effect reads
characters one at a time and puts them
in line
after the for loop
we say if open parenthesis c double
equals
single quote backslash n single quote
close parentheses open curly brace
line sub i equals c plus plus i
close curly brace this ensures that we
append the new line to the function
line sub i
equals
single quote backslash zero backslash
that's semicolon the
that's the string termination character
return i
return open parenthesis i close
parentheses this is the length that
getline is returning and then close
curly brace to end the getline function
and then we have the copy function and
it's again it takes no parameters copy
open parentheses close parenthesis curly
brace and i
extern
char
line
open bracket close bracket
comma save open bracket close bracket
semicolon
i equals 0
while
parentheses open parenthesis open
parenthesis save sub i
equals line sub i
close parenthesis is not equal
quote backslash zero quote
plus plus i
close curly brace for copy
so the external variables in main
getline and copy are defined by the very
first lines in the example above outside
of main which state their type and cause
storage to be allocated for them
syntactically
external definitions are just like the
declarations we used previously but
because they occur outside of any
function including outside the main
function the variables are external
before a function can use or access an
external variable the name of the
variable must be made known to the
function one way to do this is to write
an extern declaration in the function
the declaration is the same as before
except for the added keyword
extern
in certain circumstances the extern
declaration can be admitted omitted
if the external definition of the
variable occurs in the same source file
before it's used in a particular
function then there's no need for an
extern declaration in the function
the extern declarations in main and
getline and copy are thus redundant in
fact common practice is to place all
definition of all external variables at
the beginning of the source file and
then omit all extern declarations
if the program is in several source
files and a variable is defined in say
file 1 and used in file 2 then an extern
declaration is needed in file 2 to
connect the two occurrences of the
variables
this topic is discussed at length in
chapter 4.
you should note that we are using the
words declaration and definition very
carefully when we refer to external
variables in this section
definition refers to the place where the
variable is actually created or assigned
storage declaration
refers to places where the nature of the
variable is stated but no storage is
allocated
by the way there is a tendency to make
everything inside an extern variable
because it appears to simplify things
argument lists are short and variables
are always there when you want them but
external variables are always there
also when you don't want them the style
of coding is fraught with peril since it
leads to programs whose data connections
are not at all obvious
variables can be changed in unexpected
and even inadvertent ways and the
program is hard to modify when it
becomes necessary the second version of
the longest line program is inferior to
the first partly because of these
reasons and partly because it destroys
the general at generality of two quite
useful functions by hardwiring them into
the names of the variables they will
manipulate
section 1.11
summary
at this point we have covered what might
be called the conventional core of c
with this handful of building blocks
it's possible to write useful programs
of considerable size
it probably a good idea if you paused
long enough to do so the exercises that
follow are intended to give you
suggestions for programs of somewhat
greater complexity than the ones
presented in this chapter
after you have this much sea under
control it will be well worth your
effort to read on for the features
covered in the next few chapters are
where the power and expressiveness of
the language begin to become
apparent this work
is based on the 1978 c programming book
written by brian w kernighan and dennis
m ritchie
their book is copyright all rights
reserved by att
but is used in this work under fair use
because of the book's historical and
scholarly significance
its lack of availability and the lack of
an accessible version of the book
the book is augmented in places to help
understand its rightful place in a
historical context amidst the major
changes of the 1970s and 1980s as
computer science evolved from a
hardware-first vendor-centered approach
to a software-centered approach where
portable operating systems and
applications written in c could run on
any hardware
this is not the ideal book to learn c
programming because the 1978 edition
does not reflect the modern c language
using an obsolete book gives us an
opportunity to take students back in
time and understand how the c language
was evolving as it laid the groundwork
for a future with portable applications
chapter 2 types operators and
expressions
variables and constants are the basic
data objects manipulated in a program
declarations list the variables to be
used and state what type they have and
perhaps what their initial values are
operators specify what is to be done to
them expressions combine variables and
constants to produce new values these
are the topics of this chapter
section 2.1 variable names
although we didn't come out and say so
there are some restrictions on variable
and symbolic constant names
names are made up of letters and digits
the first character must be a letter
the underscore counts as a letter it is
useful for improving the readability of
long variable names
upper and lower case are different
traditional c practice is to use
lowercase for variable names in all
uppercase for symbolic constants
only the first eight characters of an
internal name are significant although
more may be used for external names such
as function names and external variables
the number must be less than 8 because
external names are used by various
assemblers and loaders
appendix a lists the details furthermore
keywords like if else int float etc are
reserved you can't use them as variable
names and they must be in lower case
i would note that in modern c languages
the limitation of the first eight
characters of a variable name being
unique has been extended in most c
variants
at least 30 characters of a variable are
treated as unique the it character
limitation was to reflect the typical
limitation of identifier length in
assembly language programming and
runtime linkers of the time
naturally it's wise to choose variable
names that mean something that are
related to the purpose of the variable
and are unlikely to get mixed up
typographically
section 2.2 data types and sizes
there are only a few basic data types in
c
char which is a single byte
capable of holding one character in the
local character set
and
an integer typically reflecting the
natural size of integers on the host
machine
float a single precision floating point
and double is a double precision
floating point
in addition there are a number of
qualifiers which can be applied to end
short
long and unsigned
short and long refer to different sizes
of integers
unsigned numbers
obey the arithmetic of modulo 2 to the n
where n is the number of bits in an int
unsigned numbers are always positive
the declarations for qualifiers look
like
short int x semicolon
long int y semicolon
unsigned and z semicolon
the word in can be omitted in such
situations and typically is the
precision of these objects depends on
the machine at hand the table below
shows some representative values
on a dec pdp 11 a char is 8 bits on into
16 a short is 16 a char is 32 a float is
32 a double is 64.
on a honeywell 6000
which uses ascii character set a char is
9 bits an int is 36 bits as short as 36
bits a char is 36 bits and a float is 36
bits and a double is 32 bits
on the ibm 370 which is ebcdic
in its character set a char is 8 bits
and int is 32 bits as short is 16 bits a
char is 32 bits a float is 32 bits and a
double is 64 bits
and so on the intent is that short and
long should provide different lengths of
integers where practical
int will normally reflect the most
natural size of a particular machine
as you can see each compiler is free to
interpret short and long as appropriate
for their own hardware
about all you should count on is that
short is no longer than long
in this table we see that in the
mid-1970s
c was designed to support a range of
computer generations the pdp-11 was a
common previous generation computer that
had less memory so variable sizes were
kept small
the more modern computers in the chart
had a bit more memory and could afford
to have slightly larger larger sizes
the idea of a natural size is the size
that could be loaded computed and stored
in usually of single machine language
instruction
you knew as a programmer that when used
int the machine code you would generate
would not need to include an extra
instructions for a simple line of code
like x equals x plus one semicolon
modern int values in c are 32 bits long
and long values are 64 bits long
even though modern computers can do
64-bit computations in a single
instruction using the shorter int type
when appropriate can save on memory
storage and memory bandwidth using int
values
interestingly the length of a 32-bit int
leads to a unix and c problem with dates
that is called the year 2038 problem a
common way to represent time in unix c
programs was as a 32-bit integer of the
number of seconds since
january first 1970. it was quick and
easy to compare or add or subtract
these second counter dates in code and
even in databases but the number of
seconds since january 1st 1970 will
overflow a 30-bit number on the 19th of
january in 2038.
by now in order to avoid systems in
order to avoid problems most systems
have converted to storing these number
of second values in long or 64-bit
values
which gives us almost 300 billion years
until we need to worry about overflowing
second timer counters again
back when c was developed we had two
different character sets and two
different character variable lengths the
world generally standardized on the
ascii character set for the core western
characters and the unicode utf-8 to
represent all characters in all
languages worldwide
but that is a story for another time for
now just think of the char type as also
a byte type it is 8 bits in length and
can store ascii
modern languages like python or java
have excellent support for wide
character sets in our historical look at
c we will not cover wide or multi-byte
characters
also if you look at the float and double
types you will see different bit sizes
even worse
each of these computers in the 1970s did
floating point computation using
slightly different hardware
implementations and the same code run on
different computers would give slightly
different results and have unpredictable
behavior on overflow underflow and other
extraordinary floating point operations
this was solved by the introduction of
the ieee 754
standard in 1985 which standardized
floating point format
this standardized both the length of the
float and the double but also ensured
that the same set of floating point
calculations would produce the exact
same result
on different processors
2.3 constants int and float constants
have already been disposed of except to
note that the usual
123.456 e minus 7 or
0.12
e3 scientific notation for floats is
also legal
every floating point constant is taken
to be double so the e notation
serves for both float and double
long constants are written in the style
1 2 3 capital l
an ordinary integer constant that is too
long to fit into an int is also assumed
to be a long
there is a notation for octal and
hexadecimal constants
a leading zero on an int constant
implies octal
and a leading zero x or zero x upper
case indicates hexadecimal
for example the decimal 31 can be
written as 037 in octal and 0x1 f
or 0x1 f where f is capitalized in hex
hexadecimal and octal constants may also
be followed by the letter l to make them
long
a character constant is a single
character written in single quotes as in
quote x quote the value of the character
constant is the numeric value of the
character in the machine's character set
for example the ascii character set
0
or quote 0 quote is 48 and an ebcdic
quote 0 quote is 240. both quite
different from the numeric value zero
writing quote zero quote instead of a
numeric value like 48 or 240 makes the
program independent of the particular
value
character constants participate in
numeric operations just like any other
numbers
although they are most often used in
comparisons with other characters
a later section treats conversion rules
certain non-graphic characters can be
represented in character constants by
escape sequence like backslash n for
newline backslash t for tab backslash
zero for null backslash backslash for
backslash itself and backslash quote for
single quote etc these look like two
characters but they're actually only one
in addition an arbitrary byte space bit
pattern can be generated by writing
single quote backslash and then three
digits single quote where the three
digits is one to three octal digits as
in
pound define space form feed single
quote backslash zero one four
single quote which is ascii for a form
feed
we mentioned
form feed here because in the 1970s we
sent much of our output to printers
physical printers a form feed was the
character we would send to the printer
to
advance to the top of a new page
the character constant quote backslash
zero quote
represents the character with the value
zero
quote backslash zero quote is often
written instead of zero to emphasize the
character nature of some expression
a constant expression is an expression
that only involves constants
such expressions are evaluated at
compile time rather than run time and
accordingly may be used in
any place a constant maybe as in
pound define
max line 1000
char
line open bracket max line plus 1 close
bracket
semicolon
or
seconds equals 60 times 60 times hours
a string constant is a sequence of zero
or more characters surrounded by double
quotes as in double quote i
space am space a space string double
quote
or
double quote double quote which is a way
to show an empty string
the quotes are not part of the string
but only serve to delimit it the same
escape sequences used for character
constants apply in strings
backslash double quote represents the
double quote character
technically a string is an array whose
elements are single characters
the compiler automatically places the
null character backslash zero at the end
of each such string so programs can
conveniently find the end this
representation means that there is no
real limit on how long a string can be
but programs have to scan one to
completely determine its length
the physical storage required is one
more location than the number of
characters written between the quotes
the following function sterlin
taking the parameter s returns the
length of the character string s
excluding the terminal backslash zero
sterling open parentheses s close
parenthesis
char
s
open bracket close bracket semicolon
open curly brace
int space i semicolon
i equals zero semicolon
while parentheses s
sub i
exclamation equals
quote backslash zero quote close
parentheses
plus plus i semicolon
return parentheses i parentheses
semicolon close curly brace
be careful to distinguish between the
character constant and a string that
contains a single character single quote
x single quote is not the same as double
quote x double quote the former is a
single character used to produce the
numerical value of the letter x of the
machine's character set the latter is a
character string that contains one
character the letter x and a backslash
zero
section 2.4
all variables must be declared before
use although certain declarations can be
made implicitly by context
a declaration specifies a type and is
followed by a list of one or more
variables of that type as in
int
lower comma upper comma step semicolon
char
c comma line
open bracket 1000 close bracket
semicolon
variables can be distributed among
declaration in any fashion the list
above could we could be equally well
written as
int lower semicolon in upper semicolon
in step semicolon char c semicolon char
line open bracket 1000 close bracket
semicolon the latter form takes more
room but it is convenient for adding a
comment to each declaration or for
subsequent modifications
variables may also be initialized in
their declaration although there are
some restrictions
if the name is followed by an equal sign
in a constant that serves as an
initializer as in char
backslash equals
single quote backslash backslash single
quote semicolon
int
i equals 0 semicolon
float eps equals 1.0 e minus 5 semicolon
if the variable in question is external
or static the initialization is done
once only conceptually before the
program starts executing
explicitly initialized automatic
variables are initialized each time the
function they are in is called
automatic variables for which there is
no explicit initializer have undefined
that is garbage values
external and static variables are
initialized to zero by default but it is
a good style to state the initialization
anyway
we will discuss initialization further
as new data types are introduced
section
2.5 arithmetic operators
the binary operators
are
plus
minus
asterisk and slash
and the modulus operator percent
there is a unary minus but no unary plus
integer division truncates any
fractional fractional part the
expression x percent y
produces the remainder when x is divided
by y and is thus zero when y divides x
exactly
for example a year is a leap year if it
is divisible by 4 but not by 100
except that years divisible by 4 are
leap years therefore
if parentheses year percent for equal
equal zero
and and
year percent
100 not equal zero
or
year percent 400 equal equal zero it's a
leap year
else it's not
the percent operator cannot be applied
to float or double
the plus and minus operators have the
same precedence
which is lower than the identical
precedence of asterisk slash and percent
which are in turn lower than unary minus
arithmetic operators group from left to
right a table at the end of this chapter
summarizes precedence and associativity
for all operators
the order of evaluation is not specified
for associative and commutative
operators like asterisk and plus
the compiler may rearrange a
parenthesized computation involving
these thus
a plus open parenthesis b plus c closed
parenthesis can be evaluated as
open parenthesis a plus b close
parentheses plus c
this rarely makes any difference but if
a particular order is required explicit
temporary variables might be used
the action on overflow or underflow
depends on the machine at hand
i would note that the above
paragraph allows the compiler
i would note that the above paragraph
allowing the compiler to reorder
computations even in the parentheses
presence of parentheses is known as the
knr c arrangement license
as the authors state it almost never
makes a difference unless an expression
contains a value computed in a function
call or is there a pointered lookup to
find a value for the computation that
might fail
the rule was subtly adjusted in the iso
version of c but iso c still does not
strictly force the order of otherwise
commutative operations even in the pr
presence of parentheses
the good news is that as long as you
keep your expression simple you don't
have to worry about this rule sometimes
the real value of parentheses is to
communicate your intentions to the human
readers of your code
if you are writing code that depends on
the order of overflow
function calls and pointer dereferences
in a single mathematical expression
perhaps you should break your expression
into multiple
statements section 2.6 relational and
logical operators the relational
operators are greater than greater than
or equal
less than less than or equal
they all have the same precedence
just below them in precedence are the
equality operators double equals and
exclamation equals which have the same
precedence
relationals have lower precedence than
arithmetic operators so expressions like
i less than limb minus 1 are taken as i
less than open parenthesis limb minus 1
close parenthesis as would be expected
more interesting are the logical
connectives double ampersand and double
vertical bar and an or
expressions connected by double
ampersand or double vertical bar are
evaluated left to right and the
evaluation stops as soon as the truth or
falsehood of the result is known
these properties are critical in writing
programs that work
for example
here is a loop from the input function
get line which we wrote in chapter one
for parenthesis i equals zero semicolon
i less than lim minus one double
ampersand
parenthesis
c equals get char open parenthesis close
parenthesis close parenthesis not equal
single quote backslash n single quote
double ampersand
c exclamation equal e o f semicolon plus
plus i
close parenthesis
s sub i equals c
clearly before reading a new character
it is necessary to check that there's
room to store the array so the test i
less than lim minus 1 must be made first
not only but if this test fails
we must not go on and read another
character
similarly it would be unfortunate if c
were tested against eof before getchar
was called
the call must occur before the character
c is checked against dof
the precedence of double ampersand and
is greater than that of double vertical
bar or and both are lower than the
relational inequality operators so
expressions like i
less than limb minus one double
ampersand parenthesis c equals char open
print close paren close paren not equal
single quote backslash n single quote
double ampersand c not equal eof needs
no extra parenthesis but since the
parentheses of
not equals is higher than assignment
parentheses do need to be added in
open print c equals get char open print
close paren close print not equal
backslash n
to achieve the desired result
let's take a brief digression
one of the great debates of the 1970s
was how to use structured programming
to avoid any use of go-to statements
that lead to completely unreadable
spaghetti code
structured code was easier to read debug
and validate structured code advocated
for if then else else if while do loops
and do while loops where the loop exit
test was at the top or the bottom of the
loops respectively
there was a move from flowcharts with
lines boxes and arrows to to structure
programming techniques
like nashi schneiderman diagrams that
you did used nested boxes to emphasize
the structured nature of the code
the proponents of each approach tended
to approach the problem based on the
language they used
algol and pascal programmers were strong
advocates of structured programming and
those languages had syntax that
encouraged the approach
fortran programs
had decades of flowchart use and style
flowchart style thinking intended to
avoid full adoption of structured
programming
kurdian and ritchie chose a middle path
and made it so that c could support both
approaches to avoid angering either side
of the structure programming debate
one area where the structured code
movement kept hitting a snag
was implementing a loop that reads a
file and processes data until it reaches
the end file
the loop must be able to handle an empty
file or no data at all
there are three ways to construct a read
and process until eof loop and none of
the approaches are ideal
the loop constructions that you can do
are a top tested loop with prime a
priming read before the loop
a bottom tested loop with a read as the
first statement in the loop and then if
then else is the rest of the body of the
loop
a top tested infinite loop with a
priming read and a middle test and exit
and a top tested loop with a side effect
read in the test of the loop
which is the way that kernighan and
ritchie chose to document
in this chapter
all of this
serves to explain the syntax
while
open parenthesis open parenthesis c
equals get char open paren close print
close parenthesis not equal eof close
parenthesis open curly brace body of the
loop close curly brace this construct is
a topped tested loop which most
programmers prefer
and it folds the priming read and puts
its value inside the variable c
but since the getchar might also return
eof we need to check if we actually
receive no data at all and need to avoid
executing the body of the loop
or exit the loop
if eof were defined as zero instead of
minus 1. the loop could have been
written
while open parenthesis c equals get char
open paren close paren close parenthesis
open curly brace body of the loop close
curly brace
now
the get jar function returns a character
or zero and the test itself is looking
at the side effect or residual value of
the assignment statement to decide to
start and or continue the loop body
the problem with using zero is end of
file if you are reading a binary file
like jpeg data a zero character might
make perfect sense and we would not want
to incorrectly end the loop because of a
zero character in input data that does
not end a file
so we get the double parentheses syntax
the side effect call to getchar and test
the return value
within the while test
i'm quite confident that this is far
more detail that you wanted here in
chapter two but as it is as good a time
as any to understand how much thought
goes into a programming language how it
is designed and documented
by the time we finish chapter 3 and look
at the break and continue statements
which are in languages like python and
java you will see that this 50 year old
structured programming debate
debate is still unresolved in the minds
of many software developers
back to the book
the unary negation operator logical
negation operator converts a non-zero or
true operand into zero in a zero or
false operand into one
a common use of exclamation which we
often call bang is in constructions like
if open parenthesis exclamation point in
word close parenthesis
rather than if open parenthesis inward
equal equals zero
it is hard to generalize about which of
these two forms is better construction
like exclamation inward read quite
nicely as if not in word
but more complicated ones can be hard to
understand
section 2.7 type conversions
when operands of different types appear
in expressions they are converted to a
common type according to a small number
of rules
in general the only conversions that
happen automatically are those that make
sense such as converting an integer to a
floating point in an expression like f
plus i expressions that don't make sense
like using a float in a subscript are
disallowed
first
chars and inst may be freely intermixed
in arithmetic expressions
every chart in an expression is
automatically converted to an end
this permits considerable flexibility in
certain kinds of character
transformations
one is exemplified by the function a to
i which converts a string of digits into
its numeric equivalent
a to y open parenthesis s close
parenthesis
char s open bracket close bracket
semicolon
open curly brace int i comma n semicolon
n equals zero
four parenthesis i equals zero semicolon
s sub i greater than or equal to quote
zero quote double ampersand
s sub i less than or equal to double
quote nine quote semicolon plus plus i
close parentheses
n equals 10
asterisk n plus
s sub i minus single quote 0 single
quote semicolon
return open parenthesis and close
parentheses semicolon close curly brace
to end the function
as we discussed in chapter 1 the
expression s sub i minus quote 0 quote
gives the numeric value of the character
stored in sub i because the values 0
1 etc form a continuously increasing
positive sequence positive sequence
another example
of the card chart in conversion is the
function lower which match a single
character to lower case for the ascii
character set only
if the character is not an upper case
letter lower is returned unchanged
here's a function
lower open parentheses c closed
parenthesis
int c semicolon open curly brace
if open parenthesis c greater than or
equal to quote capital a quote
double ampersand c
less than or equal to quote z quote
uppercase z
parenthesis return
open parenthesis c plus
quote lowercase a quote minus quote
uppercase a quote close parentheses
semicolon else return c
this works for ascii because the
corresponding upper and lowercase
letters are a fixed distance apart as
numeric values and each alphabet is
contiguous
there is nothing but letters between a
and z
this latter observation is not true of
the ebcdic character set on ibm 360 370
architectures so this code fails on such
systems it converts more than letters
there is one subtle point about the
conversion of characters to integer
the language does not specify whether
character where the variables of type
char are signed or unsigned quantities
when char is converted to an int
can it ever produce a negative number
unfortunately this varies from machine
to machine reflecting differences in
architecture
on some machines
for instance a char whose left most bit
is one will be converted to negative
integer using sign extension
on others a char is promoted to an in by
adding zeros at the left end and is thus
always positive
the definition of c guarantees that any
character in the machine standard
character set will never appear to be
negative so these characters may be used
freely in expressions as positive
quantities but
arbitrary bit patterns stored in
character variables may appear to be
negative on some machines yet positive
on others
the most common occurrence of this
situation is when the value negative 1
is used for eof consider the code
char
c semicolon
c equals get char open print close paren
semicolon if open print c double equals
eof close paren dot dot dot
on a machine which does not do sign
extension c is always positive because
it returns a char
yet eof is negative as a result this
test always fails to avoid this we have
been careful to use int instead of char
for any variable which holds a value
returned by the function getchar
the real reason for using int instead of
char is not related to any questions of
possible sign extensions it is simply
that getchar must return all possible
characters so that it can be root used
to read arbitrary input and in addition
a distinct eof value
thus its value cannot be represented as
a care
char but must instead be stored as an
int
as an aside since the book was written
before the getchar function was
standardized the text is somewhat vague
in this section
shortly after the book was published
getchar was put into the stdio.h library
and declared to return an integer so as
to accommodate
all possible characters and the integer
-1 value to indicate the end file
the above code would be better written
with c declared as an integer
intc semicolon
c equals get char open paren close paren
semicolon
if
open print c double equal eof close
paren dot dot
while the conversion from char to int
may or may not have sign extension and
yes it still depends on the
implementation 50 years later the
conversion from into char is predictable
with the top bits being simply discarded
if you're using the library function get
s to read a file line by line we don't
need to worry about this conversion
since git s returns a pointer to a
character array i.e a string it
indicates that reach has reached end of
file by returning the null pointer i.e
there is no more data to give
back to the textbook
another useful form of automatic type
conversions is that relational
expressions like i greater than j and
logical expressions constructed by
double ampersand and double vertical bar
and and or respectively are defined to
have the value 1 if true and 0 if false
thus the assignment
is digit equals c greater than or equal
to quote 0 quote double ampersand c less
than or equal to quote 9 quote sets the
variable is digit to 1 if c is a digit
and 0 if it's not
in the if test of a
in a test part of an if while or four
true just means non-zero
implicit arithmetic conversions would
work much as expected
in general if an operator likes c or
asterisk for multiplication which takes
two operators i.e a binary operator if
it has operated operands of different
types the lower type is promoted to the
higher type before the operation
proceeds and the result is the higher
type
more precisely for each arithmetic
operator the following sequence of
conversion rules
is applied
char and short are converted to int and
float is converted to double
then if either operand is double the
other is converted to double and the
result is double
otherwise if either operand is long and
the other is converted to long the
result is long
otherwise if either operand is
operand is unsigned the other is
converted to unsigned and the result is
unsigned otherwise
the operands must be int and the result
isn't
note that all float values in an
expression are converted to double all
floating point arithmetic in c is done
in double precision
conversions take place across
assignments
the value of the right side is converted
to the type of the left
which is the type of the result a
character is converted to an integer
either by sign extension or not as
described above the reverse operation
into char is well behaved excess high
order bits are simply discarded thus in
int i semicolon char c semicolon i
equals c
c equals i the value of c is unchanged
and this is true whether or not sign
extension is involved
if x is float and i is int then x equals
i and i equals x both cause conversions
float to end causes truncation of any
fractional part
double is converted to float by rounding
longer ins are converted
to shorter ones by or to charge by
dropping excess high order bits
since a function argument is an
expression type conversions also take
place when arguments are passed to
functions
in particular char and short become int
and float becomes double and that is why
we have declared function arguments to
be int and double even when the function
is called with char and float
finally
explicit type conversions can be forced
also we call it coerced in any
expression with a construct called the
cast
in the construction open parenthesis
type name close parentheses expression
the expression is converted to the named
type by the conversion rules above
the precise meaning of cast is in fact
as if the expression were assigned to a
variable of the specified type which is
then used in place of the whole
construction
for example the library square root sqrt
expects a double argument and will
produce nonsense if inadvertently handed
something else so if n is an integer
sqrt open parenthesis open parenthesis
double close parenthesis n close
parenthesis converts n to double before
passing it to sqrt
note that the cast produces the value of
n in the proper type the actual content
of n is not altered the cast operator
has the same
precedence as other unary operations as
is summarized in the table at the end of
this chapter
section 2.8 increment and decrement
operators
c provides two unusual operators for
incrementing and decrementing variables
the increment operator plus plus adds
one to its operand the decrement
operator minus minus subtracts one
we have frequently used plus plus
increment variables as in if open
parentheses c equals equals single quote
backslash n single quote closed
parenthesis
plus plus nl semicolon
the unusual aspect is that plus plus and
minus minus may be used either as prefix
operators ie before the variable as in
plus plus n or postfix after the
variable n plus plus
in both cases the effect is to increment
n
but the expression the residual value of
the expression plus plus n
increments n before using its value
while n plus plus increments and after
its value has been used
this means that in a context
where the value is used
not just the effect
plus plus n and n plus plus are
different if n is 5
then x equals n plus plus semicolon sets
x to 5 the old value
but x equals plus plus n semicolon sets
x to 6
the new value
in both cases n becomes 6.
the increment and decrement operators
can only be applied to variables
an expression like x equals open
parenthesis i plus j close parenthesis
parenthesis plus plus is illegal
in a context where no value is wanted
just incrementing effect as in if open
parentheses c double equals single quote
backslash n
single quote close parenthesis and l
plus plus semicolon
choose prefix or postfix according to
taste
but there are situations where one or
the other is specifically called for for
example consider the function squeeze s
comma c which removes all occurrences of
the character c from the string s
squeeze open parenthesis s comma c close
parenthesis
char
s
open
bracket close bracket semicolon int c
semicolon open curly brace int i comma j
semicolon
for parenthesis i equals j equals zero
semicolon
s sub i
not equal to
single quote backslash zero single quote
semicolon i plus plus close parentheses
if
open parenthesis s sub i
not equal to c close parenthesis
s sub j plus plus
close parenthesis equals s sub i
and outside the for loop totally s sub j
equals
backslash quote
s sub j
equals quote backslash zero quote
semicolon close curly brace
each time a non-c a character other than
what's in the variable c occurs is
copied into the current j position and
only then is j incremented to be ready
for the next character this is exactly
equivalent to
if open parenthesis s sub i not equal to
c close parenthesis open curly brace
s sub j equals s sub i
semicolon j plus plus semicolon close
curly brace
another example of a similar
construction comes from the getline
function we wrote in chapter one where
we can replace if open parenthesis c
double equals quote backslash n quote
close parenthesis open curly brace s sub
i equals c
semicolon plus plus i semicolon close
parenthesis by the far more compact
if parentheses c double equals quote
backslash end quote close parentheses s
sub i plus plus equals c semicolon
in a third example the function stir cat
concatenates the string t to the end of
the string s
stir cat does assume that there's enough
space in s to hold the combination
here's the code
stir cat open parentheses s comma t
close parenthesis
char
s open bracket close bracket comma t
open bracket close bracket semicolon
open curly brace int i comma j semicolon
i equals j equals 0 semicolon
while open paren
s sub i not equal
single quote backslash zero single quote
close paren i plus plus
in this we'd find the end of s
while open parenthesis open parenthesis
s sub i plus plus equals
t sub j plus plus close parenthesis not
equal backslash zero
close parentheses semicolon
that code copies the rest of t
into s
close curly brace
as each character is copied from t to s
the postfix plus plus is applied to both
i and j to make sure they are in
position for the next pass
through the loop
section 2.9 bitwise logical operators
c provides a number of operators for bit
manipulation
these may not be applied to float or
double
ampersand is bitwise and vertical bar is
bitwise inclusive or
carrot is bitwise exclusive or
less than less than is left shift and
greater than greater than is right shift
and tild is one complements and it's a
unary operator
the bitwise and operator
ampersand is often used to mask off some
set of bits for example
c equals n ampersand 0 1 7 7 sets to 0
all but the lower 7 bits of n the
bitwise or operator is used to turn bits
on
x equals x vertical bar mask
sets to 1 the x bits that are set to one
in mask
you should carefully distinguish the
bitwise operator ampersand and vertical
bar from the logical connectives double
ampersand and double vertical bar which
imply left to right evaluation of a
truth value
for example if x is 1 and y is 2 then x
single ampersand y is 0
while x double ampersand y is 1.
think about that for a moment
the shift operators less than less than
and greater than greater than
perform left and right shifts
respectively of their left operand by
the number of bit positions given by the
right operand
thus
x less than less than 2 shifts x left by
two positions filling the vacated bits
with zero
this is the equivalent to multiplication
by four
right shifting an unsigned quantity
fills the vacated bits with zero
right shifting a sine quantity will fill
the sine bits
arithmetic shift on some machines such
as pdp 11 and with and with zero bits
logical shift on other
the unary operator tilled
yields the ones complement of an integer
that is
it converts each one bit into a zero bit
and vice versa
this operator typically finds use in
expressions like
x
ampersand tilled
077
which masks the last six
bits of x to zero
note that x ampersand tilde 0 7 7 is
independent of word length
and is thus preferable to for example
x
ampersand 0 1 7 7 7 0 0 which assumes
that x is a 16 bit quantity
the portable form involves no extra
cause since killed zero seven seven is a
constant expression and thus evaluated
at compile time
to illustrate the use of sum of the bit
operators consider the function get bets
open parenthesis x comma p comma n which
returns the right adjusted n bit field
of x that visit begins at position p
we assume that position
0 is at the right end and that n and p
are sensible positive values for example
get bits
open print x comma 4 comma 3
close print returns the three bits in
bit positions 4 3 and 2 write adjusted
here we go with the code
get bits open print x comma p comma n
unsigned x comma p comma n semicolon
open curly brace
return
open parenthesis open parenthesis x
greater than greater than open
parenthesis p plus 1 minus n close
parenthesis close parenthesis
and ampersand
tild open parenthesis till 0
less than less than in closed
parenthesis close parenthesis semicolon
close curly brace
x greater than greater than parenthesis
p plus one minus n
close parenthesis moves the desired
field to the right end of the word
declaring the argument to be x
declaring the argument x to be unsigned
ensures that when it is right shifted
vacated bits will be filled with zeros
not sign bits regardless of the machine
the program is run on
tilde zero is all one bits shifting it
left n bit positions with tilde 0 left
shift
tilde 0 less than less than n creates a
mask with the zeros in the right most n
bits and ones everywhere else
complementing that with tilled makes a
mask with ones in the right most bits
bitwise operators may seem unnecessary
for modern computers
but if you look at the internal
structure of tcpip packets the values
are packed very tightly into the headers
in order to save space
c made it possible to write portable
tcpi implementations on a wide range of
hardware architectures
bitwise operators also play an important
role in encryption decryption and
checksum calculations
modern languages like java and python
support bitwise operators following the
same patterns that we established in c
so that things like tcpip and encryption
algorithms can also be implemented in
these languages
by defining these operators it kept
software developers from needing to
write non-portable assembly language to
implement these low-level features in
operating systems and libraries
section 2.10 assignment operators and
expressions
expressions such as i equals i plus 2 in
which the left-hand side is repeated on
the right can be written in the
compressed form i plus equals 2 using an
assignment operator like plus equals
most binary operators operators like
plus that have a left and right operand
have a corresponding
assignment operator op equals where op
is one of plus
minus
asterisk for multiplication slash for
division percent for modulo
less than less than
left shift
greater than greater than right shift
ampersand bitwise and
carrot exclusive or
vertical bar bitwise or
if e1 and e2 are expressions then e1
operand equals e2 is equivalent to e1
equals e1 operand e2
except that e1 is only computed once
note the parentheses around e2
x
star equals y plus 1 is actually
x equals x times parenthesis y plus 1
close parenthesis rather than
x times y plus 1.
as an example function bit count counts
the number of one bits in its integer
argument
here's the code
bit count open parentheses in close
parenthesis unsigned and semicolon
open curly brace into b
four open parenthesis b equals 0
semicolon
and exclamation equals 0 semicolon
n
greater than greater than equal 1
close parenthesis
if open parenthesis in ampersand
0 1
close parenthesis
b plus plus semicolon
return
open print b close print semicolon curly
brace
quite apart from its conciseness
assignment operators have the advantage
and that they correspond better to way
the way people think we said we say add
2 to i or increment i by 2 not take i
add 2 and put the result back in i
thus
i plus equal to
in addition for a complicated expression
like
yy val
open
bracket yypv open bracket p3 plus p4
close bracket plus yypv
open bracket p1 plus 2 p2 close bracket
close bracket plus equals 2
the assignment operator makes it code
easier to understand since the reader
doesn't have to check painstakingly that
too long expressions are indeed the same
or wonder why they're not
an assignment operator may even help the
compiler to produce more efficient code
we have already used the fact that the
assignments statement has a side effect
value and can occur in expressions the
most common example is while open
parentheses open parenthesis c equals
get char open parenthesis close
parenthesis close parenthesis
exclamation equal eof close parentheses
and then the rest of the loop
assignments using other assignment
operators plus equal minus sql can also
occur in expressions although it's a
less frequent occurrence
the type of an assignment expression is
the type of its left operand
section 2.11 conditional expressions
the statements
if parentheses a greater than b
close parentheses c equals a semicolon
else z equals b semicolon of course
compute z in the maximum of a and b
the conditional expression written with
a ternary operator which is question
mark and colon provides an alternate way
to write this and similar constructions
in the expression e1 question mark e2
colon e3
the expression e1 is evaluated first
if it is non-zero true then the
expression e2 is evaluated and that is
the value of the conditional expression
otherwise e3 is evaluated and that is
the value only one of e 2 and e 3 are
evaluated thus to set the z to set z to
the maximum of a and b we say
z equals parentheses a greater than b
close parentheses question mark a
colon b
and this implements z equals max of a
and b
it should be noted that the conditional
expression is indeed an expression and
can be used just as any other expression
if e1 and if e2 and e3 are different
types their type of the result is
determined by the conversion rules
described earlier in this chapter for
example if f is a float and n is an end
then the expression
parentheses n greater than zero closed
parenthesis
question mark f colon n
is of type double regardless of whether
n is positive or not
parentheses are not necessary around the
first expression of a conventional
expression since the precedence of
question mark colon is very low just
above assignment they are advisable
anyway however since they make the
condition part of the expression easier
to see
the conditional expression often leads
to succinct code for example
this loop print prints n elements of an
array 10 per line with each column
separated by one blank and with each
line including the last terminated by
exactly one new line
here's the code four parentheses i
equals zero semicolon i less than n
semicolon i plus plus close parentheses
printf open parentheses double quote
percent 6d percent c
double quote comma
a sub i
comma
open parenthesis
i percent 10
double equal 9
or double vertical bar i double equal n
minus 1 close parenthesis question mark
single quote backslash n single quote
colon single quote space single quote
close parenthesis semicolon
a new line is printed after every tenth
element
and after the nth and all elements are
followed by one blank although this
might look tricky it's instructive to
try to write it without the conditional
expression section 2.12 precedence in
order of evaluation
the table below summarizes the rules for
precedence and associativity of all
operators including those which we have
not yet discussed
operators on the same line have the same
precedence
rows are in order of decreasing
precedence so for example
asterisk slash and percent all have the
same precedence which is higher than
that of plus and minus
parentheses
square brackets
the arrow operator and the dot operator
are first with the right left to right
associativity
next precedence is exclamation
tilled
plus plus
minus minus
single minus
the cast
multiplication
bitwise and size of with left with right
to left
associativity
then
multiplication division and modulo with
left right associativity
then plus and minus with left to right
associativity
then
left shift which is less than less than
and right shift which is right
greater than greater than with left to
right associativity
then logical operators less than less
than or equal to greater than or greater
than or equal to with left to right
associativity
then comparison double equals
not equal exclamation equal left to
right
then we have some bitwise operators the
bitwise and with left to right
associativity
then the bitwise exclusive or with left
right associativity which is a carrot
then the single vertical bar which is
bitwise or with left to right
associativity
then we have amber sand ampersand which
is and the logical and left to right
associativity then double vertical bar
which is the logical or with left to
right associativity then the ternary
operator which is question mark and
colon with right to left associativity
then the assignments
equals plus equals minus sets equals etc
with right to left associativity and
then the comma which we'll cover in the
next chapter with left to right
associativity the operators
dash
greater than and dot are used to access
members of structures they'll be covered
in chapter six along with size of
in chat
and then in chapter five we'll discuss
asterisk indirection and ampersand
address of
note that the precedence of the bitwise
logical operators ampersand carrot and
vertical bar falls below
double equals and exclamation equals
that this implies that bis bit testing
expressions like if
parentheses parentheses x ampersand mass
close parenthesis
equal equals zero close parenthesis must
be fully parenthesized to get proper
results
as mentioned before expressions
involving one or more of the associative
and commutative operators like multiply
plus
bit y z end bit lies orbit li and
bitwise exclusive or can be rearranged
even when parenthesized in most cases
this makes no difference whatsoever in
situations where it might explicit
temporary variables can use
to force a particular order of
evaluation
c like most languages does not specify
in what order operands of an operator
are evaluated for example
in a statement like x equals f open
parentheses close parentheses plus g
open parentheses close parenthesis
semicolon f may be evaluated before v g
or vice versa
thus if f or g
alters an external variable that the
other depends on
x can depend on the order value of
evaluation again
intermediate results can be stored in
temporary variables to ensure a
particular sequence
similarly the order which function
arguments are evaluated is not specified
so
the statement
printf open parentheses double quote
percent d space percent d backslash n
double quote comma
plus plus n comma power open parenthesis
two comma n close parentheses close
parentheses
is wrong
it can and often does produce different
results on different machines depending
on whether or not n is incremented
before power is called the solution of
course is to write
plus plus n semicolon
printf open parentheses double quote
percent d space percent d backslash n
double quote comma
n comma power open parenthesis two comma
n close parentheses close parenthesis
function calls nested assignment
statements and increment and decrement
operators cause side effects
some variables change as a byproduct of
the evaluation of an expression
in any expression involving side effects
there can be subtle dependencies on the
order in which variables taking part in
the expression are stored
one unhappy situation is typified by the
statement
a sub i equals i plus plus
the question is whether or not the
subscript
is the old value of i or the new value
the compiler can do this in different
ways and generate different answers
depending on its interpretation
when side effects i.e assignment to
actual variables takes place is left to
the discretion of the compiler since the
best order strongly depends on machine
architecture
the moral of this discussion is writing
code which depends on the order of
evaluation is a bad programming practice
in any language
naturally it is necessary to know what
things to avoid
but if you don't know how they are done
on various machines that innocence may
help to protect you
the c verifier lint
will detect most dependencies on order
of evaluation
i would add that the real moral of the
story is to use side effect operators
very carefully
they are generally only used in
idiomatic situations and then use it
written using simple code
the authors are happy to tell you
everything that you can do and see in
great detail
and they are also suggesting that just
because you can do something does not
mean that you should do something
remember that a key aspect of writing
programs is to communicate with future
human readers of your code
including you reading your own code in
the future
with modern day compilers and optimizers
you gain little performance by writing
dense or obtuse code
write the code describe what you want
done and let the compiler find the best
way to do it
one of the reasons that a common senior
project in many computer science degrees
was to write a compiler is to make sure
that all computer scientists
understand that they can trust the
compiler to generate great code
this work
is based on the 1978 c programming book
written by brian w kernighan and dennis
m ritchie
their book is copyright all rights
reserved by at t
but is used in this work under fair use
because of the book's historical and
scholarly significance
its lack of availability and the lack of
an accessible version of the book
the book is augmented in places to help
understand its rightful place in a
historical context amidst the major
changes of the 1970s and 1980s as
computer science evolved from a hardware
first vendor-centered approach to a
software-centered approach where
portable operating systems and
applications written in c could run on
any hardware
this is not the ideal book to learn c
programming because the 1978 edition
does not reflect the modern c language
using an obsolete book gives us an
opportunity to take students back in
time and understand how the c language
was evolving as it laid the groundwork
for a future with portable applications
chapter 3 control flow
the control flow statements of a
language specify the order in which the
computations are done
we have already met the most common
control flow constructions of c in
earlier examples
here we will complete the set and be
more precise about the ones discussed
above
3.1 statements and blocks an expression
such as x equals zero or i plus plus or
printf open paren
dot dot dot close paren becomes a
statement when it is followed by a
semicolon as in
x equals zero semicolon
i plus plus semicolon
printf open parentheses something closed
parentheses semicolon
in c the semicolon is a statement
terminator rather than a separator as it
is in algol like languages
the braces the curly braces open curly
brace and closed curly brace are used to
group declarations and statements
together into a compound statement or
block so that they are syntactically
equivalent to a single statement
the braces that actually surround the
statements of a function are one obvious
example
braces around multiple statements after
an if
else while or four are another
variables can actually be declared
inside any block we will talk about this
in chapter four
there is never a semicolon after the
right curly brace that ends the block
ah see how do i love thee let me count
the ways
quote by dr chuck with homage to
elizabeth barrett browning
the humble semicolon is why spacing and
line ends do not matter in c and c like
languages it means that we as
programmers can focus all of our white
space and line ends on communicating our
intent to humans
this freedom is not an excuse to write
obtuse code or dense code
for example see the obfusicated pearl
contest but instead
freedom to describe what we mean or use
spacing to help us understand or
maintain our code
we can take a quick look at how a few
other c like languages that came after c
treat the semicolon java is just like c
in that the semicolon terminates
statements
python treats the semicolon as a
separator like alcohol allowing more
than one statement on a single line but
since
python treats the end of a line as a
statement separator you generally never
use semicolon in python
but for people like me who automatically
add a semicolon when typing code too
fast at least python ignores the few
semicolons i mistakenly add to my code
out of habit
javascript treats the semicolon as a
separator but since javascript ignores
the end of the line it's treated as
white space semicolons are required when
a block of code consists of more than
one statement
when i write javascript i meticulously
include semicolons at the end of all
statements because any good programmer
can write c in any language
back to the text 3.2
if else
the ifl statement is used to make
decisions
formally the syntax is
if parentheses expression parentheses
statement 1
else statement 2 where the else part is
optional
the expression in parentheses is
evaluated if it evaluates to true that
is the expression has a non-zero value
statement one is done if it is false the
expression is zero
and there's an else part statement two
is executed instead
since an if simply tests the numeric
value of the expression certain coding
shortcuts are possible the most obvious
is writing if open parentheses
expression
instead of if open parenthesis
expression not equal zero close
parenthesis
sometimes this is natural and clear
other times it's cryptic
because the else part of an if else is
optional there is an ambiguity
when an else is omitted from a nested if
sequence
this is resolved the usual way the else
is a cl associated with the closest
closest previous else list if
for example
if
open parenthesis n greater than zero
closed parenthesis
if
open parenthesis a greater than b close
parentheses
z equals a semicolon
else z equals b
the else with the z equals b goes with
the inner if as we have shown by the
indentation in the above example
if that's not what you want braces must
be used to force the proper association
if n greater than zero open curly brace
if a greater than b
z equals a semicolon closed curly brace
else z equals b
this ambiguity is especially pernicious
in situations like
if open parenthesis n greater than zero
for open parenthesis i equals 0
semicolon i less than n semicolon i plus
plus closed parenthesis
if open parenthesis
s sub i greater than 0 close parentheses
open curly brace printf
string dot
parenthesis semicolon return open
parenthesis i close parenthesis
semicolon close curly brace
else and this is where it's wrong
printf
open parenthesis error and is zero
closed parenthesis semicolon
the indentation in the above example
shows unequivocally what you want but
the compiler does not get the message
and associates the else with the inner
if
this bug can be very hard to find
by the way
notice that there is a semicolon after z
equals a in
if open parenthesis a greater than b
close parenthesis z equals a semicolon
else z equals b semicolon
that is because grammatically a
statement follows the if and an
expression like z equals a is always
terminated by a semicolon
section 3.3
else if
the construction if open parenthesis
expression close parentheses statement
else blank if open parentheses
expression close parentheses statement
else if
open parenthesis
expression close parentheses statement
else statement occurs so often that it's
worth a brief separate discussion the
sequence of ifs is the most general way
of writing a multi-way decision the
expressions are evaluated in order
if any expression is true the statement
associated with it is executed and this
terminates the whole chain the code for
each statement
is either a single statement or a group
of statements in phrases
the last else
handles the none of the above or default
case where none of the other conditions
was satisfied
sometimes there is no explicit action
for the default in that case the
trailing else statement can be omitted
or it may be used for error checking to
catch an impossible condition
to illustrate three-way decision
here is a binary search function that
decides if a particular value x occurs
in the sorted array v
the elements of v must be in increasing
order the function returns the position
a number between 0 and n minus 1 if x
occurs in v n minus 1 if not
this sample code is on page 54. it is
the first example on page 54 in the book
binary open parenthesis x comma v comma
n close parenthesis
int x
comma v
open square bracket close square bracket
comma n semicolon open curly brace
int
low comma high comma mid semicolon
low equals zero semicolon high equals n
minus one semicolon
while open parenthesis low less than or
equal to high close parenthesis
open curly brace
mid
equals open parenthesis low plus high
close parenthesis
slash 2 semicolon
if
open parenthesis x less than
v submid close parenthesis
high equals mid minus 1 semicolon
else if open parenthesis x greater than
v sub mid close parenthesis low equals
mid plus one
else
return open parenthesis mid close
parenthesis semicolon close curly brace
closing the while
and then return open parenthesis -1
close parentheses semicolon close curly
brace to end the function
the fundamental decision in this code is
whether x is less than greater than or
equal to the middle element v submit at
each step
this is a natural for elsa
i would note that in the above examples
the else and the if in c are two
language constructs that are just being
used idiomatically to construct a
multi-way branch or else if pattern with
indentation that captures the idiom
if we are pedantic about the indentation
above the of the above sequence we would
be separating the else and if and
indenting each succeeding block further
as follows with brackets or added for
clarity
if
open parenthesis expression close
parentheo parentheses open curly brace
statement close curly brace else
open curly brace if open parenthesis
expression close parenthesis open curly
brace statement close curly brace else
open curly brace and now we're quite
indented at this point if open
parenthesis expression close parentheses
open curly brace statement closed curly
brace
else open curly brace statement close
curly brace close curly brace glows
curly brace
java and javascript keep the else and if
as separate language elements and
document their idiomatic usage and
indentation just like c
but in python
life is a single keyword in a new
language construct that achieves the
same idiom as shown below
if open parenthesis expression close
parentheses colon block
lf
open parenthesis expression close
parenthesis
colon block
alif
if lf parentheses expression parentheses
colon block else colon block
the c
java javascript and python idioms
thankfully look the same when the
idiomatic indentation is used
even fortran 77 supports elf the else if
construct to implement multi-way logic
section 3.4 switch
the switch statement is a special
multi-way decision maker that tests
whether an expression matches
one of a number of constant values and
branches accordingly
in chapter one we wrote a program to
count the occurrences of each digit
white space and all other characters
using a sequence of if else if else
here's the same program with a switch
this is the first example program on
page 55.
pound include
less than stdio.h
main open parentheses closed parenthesis
open curly brace
int c comma i
come n white comma n other comma n digit
open square bracket 10 close square
bracket
a 10 element array
and white equals and other equals 0
for i equals 0
i less than 10 i plus plus and digit sub
i equals 0.
while parentheses parenthesis c equals
get char open paren close paren close
paren not equal e o f
close paren
switch
open parentheses c close parenthesis
open curly brace
case quote zero quote colon case quote
one quote colon
case
quote two qu quote colon case quote
three quote colon case quote four quote
colon case quote five quote colon case
quote six quote colon case quote seven
quote colon case quote eight quote colon
case quote nine quote colon
end digit sub c minus quote zero quote
close bracket plus plus
break
now that that bit of code right there
was to take all the of zero through nine
and
guide it to the line of code that
incremented the particular element of
the end digit array by one
continuing after the break semicolon
case quote space
quote colon
case quote backslash end quote colon
case quote backslash t quote colon
and white
plus plus semicolon break
default colon and other plus plus colon
break semicolon
close curly brace
print f
open parenthesis double quote digits
equals double quote close parenthesis
semicolon
4 open print i equals 0
i less than 10
i
semicolon i plus plus close parenthesis
printf
open parenthesis percent space percent d
close double quote comma end digit sub i
close parenthesis semicolon
printf
quote backslash n white space equals
percent d comma other equals percent d
backslash n double quote comma and white
comma n other closed parenthesis
semicolon close curly brace
the switch statement evaluates the
integer expression in parentheses in
this case the character c and compares
its value
simultaneously to all the cases each
case must be labeled by an integer or
character constant or constant
expression
if a case matches the expression value
execution starts at that case the case
labeled default is executed if none of
the other cases is satisfied
default is optional if there isn't if it
isn't there and none of the cases
matches no action at all takes place
cases in default can occur in any order
cases must all be different
the break statement causes an immediate
exit from the switch
because the cases serve as labels
after the code for one case is done
execution falls through to the next
unless you take explicit action to
escape
break and return are the most common
ways to leave a switch
a break statement can be used to force
an immediate exit from a while four and
do loops as well as will be discussed
later in this chapter
falling through the cases is a mixed
blessing
on the positive side
it allows multiple cases for a single
action as with blank tab or new line in
this example but it also implies that
normally each case what must end with a
break to prevent falling through to the
next
falling through from one case to another
is not robust being prone to
disintegration when the program is
modified
with the exception of multiple labels
for a single computation fall throughs
should be used sparingly
as a matter of good form put a break
after the last case in this case default
although it's logically unnecessary
someday when another case gets added at
the end this bit of defensive
programming will save you
uh the switch statement what is there to
say i think that the switch statement
was added to c c to compete with the
earlier fortran computed go to statement
or just to keep low level assembly
language programmers from switching into
assembly language to implement the
concept of a branch table
the authors spend most of the previous
section apologizing for the switch
statement so you should perhaps take
this as a hint and never use it
there are very few situations where a
branch table outperforms a series of
this if then else checks and those are
likely deep in a library or operating
system code
programmers should only use switch if
they understand what a branch table is
and why a branch table is more efficient
for the particular bit of a program
they're writing
otherwise
just use elsif and do the readers of
your code a favor
3.5 loops while and four
we have already excounted the while and
for loops in while open parenthesis
expression close parentheses statement
the expression is evaluated if it is
nonzero the statement is executed and
the expression is reevaluated this cycle
continues until the expression becomes a
zero at which point execution return
resumes after the statement
the for statement four open parenthesis
expression one semicolon expression two
semicolon expression three closed
parentheses statement is equivalent to
expression one semicolon while open
parenthesis expression two closed
parenthesis open curly brace
statement
expression three semicolon close curly
brace
grammatically the three components of
the four are expressions
most commonly expression one and
expression three are assignments or
function calls and expression two is a
relational expression
any of the three parts can be omitted
although the semicolons must remain
expression if expression one or
expression three is left out
it is simply dropped from the expansion
if the test expression two is not
present it is taken as permanently true
so the code
for open parenthesis semicolon semicolon
closed parenthesis open curly brace dot
dot close curly brace is an infinite
loop
presumably to be broken by some other
means such as a break or a return
whether to use while or for is largely a
matter of taste
for example
in the code
while open parentheses open parenthesis
c equals get char open paren close paren
close parenthesis equal equal
quote space quote
or
c equal equal quote backslash end quote
or
c equal equal quote backslash t quote
close parentheses semicolon
skipping white characters
there is no initialization or
re-initialization so a while seems more
natural
the four is clearly superior when there
is simple initialization and
reinitialization
since it keeps the loop control
statements close together and visible at
the top of the loop this is the most
obvious in
4
open paren i equals 0 semicolon i less
than n semicolon i plus plus close paren
which is the c idiom for processing the
first n elements of an array
the analog of a fortran or pl1 do loop
the analogy is not perfect however since
the limits of a for loop can be altered
within the loop and the controlling
variable i retains its value when the
loop terminates for any reason
because the components of the four are
arbitrary expressions for loops are not
restricted to arithmetic progressions
nonetheless is bad style to force
unrelated computations into a four it is
best reserved for loot control
operations
as a larger example here is another
version of the a to i function for
converting a string to its numeric
equivalent
this one is more general it
copes with optional leading white space
and an optional plus or minus sign
chapter 4
shows a to f which does the same
conversion for floating point numbers
the basic structure of the program
reflects the form of the input
skip white space if any get the sign if
any get the integer part and convert it
each step does its part and leaves a
clean slate for the next the whole
process terminates on the first
character that would not be part of a
number
this is the first example
on page 58 of the textbook
a to i open paren s close paren which is
going to convert s to an integer
char
s open square bracket close square
bracket semicolon
open curly brace int
i comma n comma sine semicolon
4
i equals 0
s sub i equal equal
quote space quote or s sub i equals
equals quote backslash end quote or
s sub i equals equals backslash quote
backslash t quote semicolon
i plus plus
semicolon
skip white space this is a for loop with
an empty loop body
sine equals one semicolon
if s sub i equal equal plus or
s sub i equal equal quote minus quote
close parenthesis
sine
equals
and here we use a
ternary operator
open parentheses s sub i plus plus equal
equal quote plus quote close parenthesis
question mark 1 colon minus 1 semicolon
for open parentheses n equals 0
semicolon s sub i greater than or equal
to quote 0 quote and s sub i less than
or equal to quote 9 quote i plus plus
close parenthesis
n equals 10 times
n plus s sub i minus quote 0 quote
semicolon
return open parenthesis sine times n
close parenthesis semicolon close curly
brace to end the function
the advantages of keeping loop control
centralized are even more obvious when
there are separate several nested loops
the following function is a shell sort
for sorting an array of integers the
basic idea
of the shell
sort is that in early stages far apart
elements are compared rather than
adjacent ones as in simple interchange
sorts this tends to eliminate large
amounts of disorder quickly so later
stages have less work to do the interval
between the compared elements is
gradually decreased to 1 at which point
the sort becomes an effectively an
adjacent interchange method
this sample code is the second example
in page 58 of the textbook
shell open parentheses v comma and close
parenthesis int v open square bracket
close square bracket comma n semicolon
open curly brace
int
gap comma i comma j comma temp
four open paren gap equals n divided by
two semicolon gap
greater than zero semicolon
gap
slash equals to close parenthesis
4 open parenthesis i equals gap
semicolon i less than n
i plus
close parenthesis
4
and now we're 3d nested in the for loops
4 open parenthesis j equals i minus gap
semicolon j greater than or equal to 0
and
v sub j
greater than v sub j plus gap semicolon
j minus equals gap close parenthesis
open curly brace
temp equals v sub j
v sub j equals v sub j plus gap
semicolon v sub j plus gap equals temp
semicolon just a swap of v and v b sub j
plus gap p sub j and v sub j plus cap
close curly brace and that close the
inner innermost for loop and
and then the next closed curly brace
closes the function
there are three nested loops
the outermost loop controls the gap
between the compared elements shrinking
it from n over two by a factor of two
each pass until it becomes zero the
middle loop compares each pair of
elements that is separated by cap
the innermost loop reverses any elements
that are out of order
since gap is eventually reduced to one
all elements are eventually ordered
correctly
note that the generality of the 4 makes
the outer loop fit the same form as the
others
even though it is not an arithmetic
progression
one final c operator is the comma
which most often finds use in the for
statement
a pair of expressions separated by a
comma is evaluated left to right and the
type and value of the result are the
type and value of the right operand thus
in a for statement it is possible to
place multiple expressions in the
various parts
for example to process two parallel
indices
this is illustrated in the function
reverse which reverses the function
string in place
this code is from page 59 of the
textbook and it is the first example on
page 59.
pound include less than string.h greater
than
reverse open paren s close paren
char
s open square bracket close square
bracket semicolon
open curly brace int c comma i comma j
for open parenthesis i equals zero comma
j equals stirling sub s minus one
semicolon
i less than j semicolon i plus plus
comma j minus minus close parenthesis
open curly brace
c equals s sub i s sub i equals s sub j
semicolon s sub j equals c semicolon
close curly brace
close curly brace to end the function
the commas that separate the function
arguments variables declarations etc are
not comma operators and do not guarantee
left to right evaluation
section 3.6 loops do while
the while and for loops share the
desirable attribute of testing the
termination condition at the top rather
than at the bottom as we discussed in
chapter one
the third loop in c the do while tests
at the bottom after making each pass
through the loop body the body is always
executed at least once
the syntax is as follows
do
statement while open parenthesis
expression close parenthesis semicolon
the statement is executed then the
expression is evaluated if it is true
statement is evaluated again and so on
if the expression becomes false the loop
terminates
as might be expected do while is much
less used than while in four accounting
perhaps five percent of all loops
nonetheless it is from time to time
valuable as the following as in the
following function i to a which converts
a number to a character string the
inverse of a to i the job is slightly
more complicated than it might be
thought at first
because the easy methods of generating
the digits generate them in the wrong
order
we've chosen to generate the string
backwards and then reverse it
this is the first sample code on page 61
page 60 of the textbook
i to a open parenthesis n comma s close
parenthesis char
s open square bracket close square
bracket semicolon
int n semicolon
open curly brace
int i comma sine semicolon
if
open parenthesis open parenthesis sine
equals n
close parenthesis less than zero
close parenthesis
n equals minus n semicolon that's a bit
of a complex if i would say there
it has an assignment statement that both
copies n into sine
and then evaluates as to whether or not
it's less than zero the n or sign is
less than zero because it's a side
effect assignment statement for the
residual value
but the net result is sign contains n
and then it's negated um
then n is made positive
so continuing
i equals 0 semicolon
do
open curly brace
s sub i plus plus
equals n
modulo 10
plus
quote 0 quote
semicolon
close curly brace while
parenthesis parenthesis n slash equals
10
close parenthesis
greater than zero close parenthesis
semicolon
if open parenthesis sine less than zero
close parenthesis
s sub i plus plus
equals quote dash quote
or minus sign semicolon
s sub i
equals quote
0 quote semicolon in a sense to
terminate the string and then we call
the function reverse reverse open
parenthesis s close parenthesis
semicolon close curly brace
the do while is necessary or at least
convenient since at least one character
must be installed in the array s
regardless of the value of n
we have also used braces around the
single statement that makes up the body
of the do while even though they are
unnecessary so the hasty reader will not
mistaken mistake the while part for the
beginning of a while loop
i would note that it's important for any
language to provide top tested loops and
bottom tested loops but don't feel bad
if you write code for years and never
feel like a bottom tested loop is the
right way to solve a problem you're
facing it is usually rare to write a
loop that you insist will run once
regardless of its input data
section 3.7 break
it is sometimes convenient to be able to
control loop exits other than by testing
at the top or the bottom
the break statement provides an early
exit from a for while or do just as it
does from the switch statement
a break statement causes the innermost
enclosing loop or switch to be executed
immediately
the following program removes trailing
blanks and tabs from the end of each
line of input using a break to exit from
a loop
when the rightmost character is
non-blank non-tab is found
this example code is on page 61 of the
textbook and it is the first example on
that page
pound include less than stdio.h
pound define max line 1000
main open parenthesis close parenthesis
open curly brace
int
n
semicolon char
line open bracket
max line close bracket
semicolon
while open paren open paren n equals get
line open paren line comma max line
close paren close brand greater than
zero close brand open curly brace
while open cur open parenthesis
minus minus n greater than or equal to
zero close parenthesis
if open parenthesis line sub n not
equals a quote space quote and
line sub n not equal quote backslash t
quote and
line sub n not equal quote backslash end
quote
close parenthesis break
line
sub n plus one equals quote backslash
zero quote semicolon
printf
double quote percent s backslash n
double quote comma line close
parenthesis semicolon
close curly brace to end the while and
then close curly brace to end the main
getline returns the length of the line
the inner while loop starts at the last
character of line
recall that minus minus n decrements end
before using the value and scans
backwards looking for the first
character that is not a blank tab or new
line the loop is broken when one is
found or when n becomes negative that is
when the entire line has been scanned
you should verify that this is the
correct behavior even when the line
contains only white space characters
an alternative to break is to put the
testing in the loop itself
while open parenthesis open parenthesis
n equals get line open parenthesis line
comma max line close parenthesis close
parenthesis greater than zero close
parenthesis open curly brace
while open paren minus minus n greater
than
equal to zero and open for n line sub n
equal equal
quote space quote or line sub n equals
quote backslash t quote or line sub n
equals
quote backslash n quote close paren
close paren semicolon
dot dot
close curly brace this is inferior to
the previous version because the test is
harder to understand
tests which require a mixture of and or
not
and parentheses should generally be
avoided 3.8 continue
the continue statement is related to
break but less often used it causes the
next iteration of the enclosing loop for
a while or do to begin
in the while and do this means that the
test part is executed immediately
in the four control passes to the
re-initialization step
control by the way continue applies only
to loops not to switch a continue inside
a switch statement inside of a loop
causes the next loop iteration
as an example
this fragment processes only positive
elements in the array a negative values
are skipped
4 open paren i equals 0 semicolon i less
than n semicolon i plus plus close paren
open curly brace
if open paren a sub i less than 0 close
paren
continue
this line skips the negative elements
and then the rest of the body of the
loop taut is
will run only for the positive elements
of the loop and the loop finishes with a
close curly brace
the continue statement is often used
when part of the loop that follows is
complicated so that reversing a test and
indenting another level would nest the
program too deeply
it's time for a bit of an aside
now that we have seen the break and
continue language structures in c that
also have made it into c like languages
and learned about middle tested loops it
is time to revisit the structured
programming debate
and the need for priming operations when
a program must process all data until it
finishes and still handle the there is
no data at all situation
in the previous chapter the author
somewhat skirted the issue by using a
top tested while loop and a side effect
statement with residual value that was
compared to eof to decide when to exit
the loop
int c colon while open parenthesis open
parenthesis c equals get char open paren
close paren close parenthesis not equal
eof close parenthesis open curly brace
process your data
close curly brace
and just for fun now that we do know
about the for loop let's rewrite this
loop as a for loop to make sure we
really understand how for loops work
in c semicolon for
friend c equals get char open print
close print semicolon
c not equal eof semicolon c equals get
char open print close paren close paren
curly brace process your data close
curly brace for the for loop
now you will almost never see a read all
characters until eof written this way
because because it is not the way knr
told us
knr told us to reuse a while loop for
this
but the for loop formulation is probably
clearer to many
than the while formulation especially to
a reader who's not familiar with the
assignment side effect idiom commonly
used in c
in particular the four formulation does
not require
that the assignment statement has a
residual value of the value that was
assigned
the first part of the four is a priming
read the second part of the four is a
top text tested exit criteria that works
both for no data and after all data has
been read and processed and the third
part of the four is done at the bottom
of the loop to advance to the next
character
or encounter eof before going back to
the top and doing the loop test the call
to get char is
done twice in the for formulation of the
read all available data loop and while
we don't like to repeat ourselves in
code it is a if it is a small and
obvious bit of code perhaps this code
is more clear with a bit of repetition
so with all this is background
you can take this page of the document
and sit down with a friend at a coffee
shop and debate as long as you like
about which is the better formulation
for the read all available
data but if at that coffee shop you
asked dr chuck's opinion neither of
these is ideal because in the real world
we build data oriented loops that
usually do a lot more than get one
character from standard input
my formulation of a data loop will upset
the structured programming purists and
probably upset kernighan enrichy as well
but i write code in the real world so
here is my version
int
c semicolon
while open paren one close print open
curly brace
c equals get char
if open friends c double equals eof
close paren break
process your data and then close curly
brace to end the loop and if i wanted to
skip blanks and new lines i could use
both break and continue further angered
angering the structured programming
purists
int c semicolon while open parenthesis
one closed parenthesis open curly brace
c equals get char open
parenthesis close parenthesis semicolon
if
open parenthesis c equal equal eof close
parenthesis break
if open parenthesis c equal equal quote
space quote or
c equal equal quote backslash end quote
close parenthesis continue
then process your data
close parenthesis
i use this middle tested approach
because usually the data i am processing
is coming from a more complex source
than the keyboard and i don't want a
function with two to three parameters
stuck inside of a sine side effect
statement in a while test
and also sometimes you want to exit loop
not just based on the return value from
the function
but instead based on the complex
structure that came back from the
function itself
as these data processing loops get more
complex the middle tested loop is a
tried and true pattern
even kernighan and ritchie point out its
benefits above
and with that i have now triggered
endless coffee shop conversations about
the best way to write a data handling
loop
section 3.9 go to's and labels
c provides the infinitely abusable go-to
statement and labels to branch to
formally the go-to is never necessary
and in practice
it is almost always easy to write code
without it we have not used go to in
this book
nevertheless we will suggest a few
situations where go-to's might find a
place the most common
use is to abandon processing in some
deeply nested structure such as breaking
out of two loops at once
the break statement cannot be used
directly since it leaves the only the
most inter innermost loop thus
four open parentheses.close parenthesis
four open parenthesis.close parenthesis
open curly brace do some stuff if open
parenthesis disaster close parenthesis
go to error semicolon
close curly brace dot dot dot dot dot
and then error colon
and then clean up the mess
this organization is handy if the
error handling code is non-trivial and
if errors can occur in several places a
label has the same form as a variable
name and is followed by a colon
it can be attached to any statement in
the same function as the go to
another example
consider the possibility of finding the
first negative element in a
two-dimensional array
multi-dimensional arrays are discussed
in chapter five
one possibility is four
open parenthesis i equals zero semicolon
i less than n
semicolon i plus plus close parentheses
four open parenthesis j equals zero
semicolon j less than m semicolon j plus
plus close parenthesis
if open parenthesis v sub i sub j less
than zero close parenthesis go to found
other one and then you handle and you
keep going and then found colon
include is where it comes to uh jumps to
code involving a go to can always be
written without want but though perhaps
at the price of somewhat repeated tests
or an extra variable for example the
array search becomes
found equals zero four open parenthesis
i equals zero semicolon i less than n
ampersand ampersand exclamation found
semicolon i plus plus
four open parenthesis j equals zero
semicolon j less than m ampersand
ampersand exclamation found
semicolon j plus plus
found equals v sub i sub j less than
zero
if found
continue else not found although we are
not dogmatic about the matter it does
seem that go to go to statements should
not should be used sparingly at if at
all
i would add before we leave control flow
i need to say that i agree with
structured programming experts as well
as kernighan and ritchie in that the
go-to is universally a bad idea
there are a lot of little details that
make them a real problem
things like how the stack works in
function calls and how code blocks
happen and patching the stack up
correctly when a go to happens in the
middle of a deeply nested mess
you might be tempted to use a go to when
you want to exit multiple nested loops
in a single statement break and continue
only exit the innermost loop the authors
use this example above
but are quite lukewarm when describing
it as the use of go to
usually if your problem is that complex
putting things in a function and using
return or adding a few if statements is
a better choice
the dr chuck middle tested loop data
processing solves this because the loop
is always the innermost loop
also as new languages were built the
concept of exceptions became part of
language design and was by a by far more
elegant solution
to a path of some deeply nested code
that just needs to get out
so most of the time you think the go-to
might be a good idea you should lean
towards a throw catch pattern to make
your intention clear
it is one of the reasons why we prefer
languages like java or python over c
when writing general purpose code
this work
is based on the 1978 c programming book
written by brian w kernighan and dennis
m ritchie
their book is copyright all rights
reserved by at t
but is used in this work under fair use
because of the book's historical and
scholarly significance
its lack of availability and the lack of
an accessible version of the book
the book is augmented in places to help
understand its rightful place in a
historical context amidst the major
changes of the 1970s and 1980s as
computer science evolved from a hardware
first vendor-centered approach to a
software-centered approach where
portable operating systems and
applications written in c could run on
any
hardware this is not the ideal book to
learn c programming because the 1978
edition does not reflect the modern c
language
using an obsolete book gives us an
opportunity to take students back in
time and understand how the c language
was evolving as it laid the groundwork
for a future with portable applications
chapter 4 functions in program structure
functions break large computing tasks
into smaller ones and enable people to
build on what others have done instead
of starting over from scratch
appropriate functions can often hide
details of operation from parts of the
program that don't need to know about
them thus clarifying the whole and
easing the pain of making changes
c has been designed to make functions
efficient and easy to use
c programs generally consist of numerous
small functions rather than a few big
ones
a program may reside on one or more
source files in any convenient way
the source files may be compiled
separately and loaded together along
with previously compiled functions from
libraries we will not go into that
process here since the details vary
according to the local system most
programmers are familiar with library
functions for input and output like get
char input chart and numerical
computations like sine cosine and square
root in this chapter we will show more
about writing new functions
4.1 basics
to begin let us design and write a
program to print each line of input that
contains a particular pattern or string
of characters
this is a special function of the unix
utility program grap
for example searching for the pattern
the in the set of lines now is the time
for all good men to come to the aid of
their party we'll produce the output now
is the time
men to come to the aid of their party
the basic structure of the task falls
neatly into three pieces
while there's another line
if that line contains a pattern print it
although it's certainly possible to put
the code for all of this in one main
routine
a better way is to use the natural
structure to advantage by making each
part a separate function
three small pieces are easier to deal
with than the one big one because
irrelevant details can be buried in the
functions and the chance of unwanted
interactions minimized and the pieces
might even be useful later in their own
right
while there is another line is getline a
function we wrote in chapter one and
printed is printf which someone has
already provided for us
this means that we need to only write a
routine which decides if the line
contains an occurrence of the pattern
we can solve that problem
by stealing a design from pl1 the
function index
s comma t returns the position or index
in the string s where the string t
begins
or -1 if s doesn't contain t
we use 0 rather than 1 as the starting
position in s because c arrays always
begin at position 0.
when we later need more sophisticated
pattern matching
we only have to replace index the rest
of the code can remain the same
recall that because the modern stdio.h
defines a getline function whenever the
book writes this function to teach a
feature of functions we rename it to get
underscore line
given this much design filling in the
details of the program is
straightforward here's the whole thing
so you can see how the pieces fit
together
for now the pattern to be searched for
is a literal string in the argument of
index which is not the most general of
mechanisms
we will return shortly to a discussion
of how to initialize character arrays
and in chapter 5 we will show how to
make the pattern
a parameter that is set when the program
is run
this is also a new version of getline
you might find it instructive to compare
it to the one in chapter one
pound include stdio.h
pound define max line 1000
main open parenthesis closed parenthesis
open curly brace
char
line open square bracket max line close
square bracket semicolon
while parentheses get line open
parenthesis line comma max line close
parenthesis greater than zero
close parenthesis
if
open parenthesis index open parenthesis
line comma double quote the double quote
close parenthesis greater than or equal
to zero
close parenthesis printf open
parenthesis double quote percent s
double quote comma line
close parenthesis semicolon
and a close curly brace to finish the
main function
next function is get line
get
line open parenthesis s comma limb close
parenthesis
char s
open square bracket close square bracket
semicolon
available
c equals get char open frame close paren
close paren not equal e o f
double ampersand
c not equal
double quote backslash n double quote
semicolon plus plus i close parentheses
s sub i equals c
that loop basically read until it found
a new line or end of file
if
open parenthesis c double equals
quote backslash end quote close
parenthesis open curly brace
s sub i equals c
plus plus i semicolon close curly brace
closing the f
s sub i equals quote backslash zero
quote
semicolon to terminate the string
properly return
open paren
i close paren
semicolon to return the length of the
line and then close curly brace to
finish the getline function
and now the new code
index open parenthesis s comma t close
parenthesis char
s
open square bracket close square bracket
comma t open square bracket close square
bracket semicolon i would note that
when we are declaring a character array
and we don't give the length of the
array that means that we're inside of a
function the length of the array exists
but it was from the callings calling
code
so
char
s
open square bracket close square bracket
t open square bracket close square
bracket semicolon means
parameters s and t are strings of some
length and we will use backslash 0 to
know when that length is done
beginning the code in index with an open
curly brace int
i comma j comma k
semicolon
and then we have two nested for loops
four open print i equals zero
s sub i not equal to quote backslash
zero quote semicolon i plus plus open
curly brace
four
j equals i comma k equals zero
semicolon
t s t sub k not equal to backslash zero
and double ampersand s sub j double
equals t sub k semicolon j plus plus k
plus plus
semicolon
if open print t sub k double equals
quote backslash zero quote close paren
return open paren i close paren
semicolon close curly brace
return
open paren minus one close paren
semicolon curly brace
each function has the form
name
argument list if any
in parentheses
argument declarations if any open curly
brace declarations and statements if any
close curly price as suggested various
parts may be absent a minimal function
is dummy open paren close paren open
curly brace closed curly brace which
does nothing a do nothing function is
sometimes useful as a placeholder during
program development the function name
may also be preceded by a type if the
vert function returns something other
than an integer value this is the topic
of the next section
a program is just a set of individual
function definitions communication
between the functions is in this case by
arguments and values returned by the
functions it can also be via external
variables the functions can occur in any
order in the source file and the source
program can be split into multiple files
so long as no function is split
the return statement is the mechanism
for returning a residual value from the
called function to its caller
any expression can follow return
return open parentheses expression close
parentheses
the calling function is free to ignore
the return value if it wishes
furthermore there need
there is no need to have an expression
after the return
in that case no value is returned to the
caller control also returns to the
caller with no value when execution
falls off the end of the function by
reaching the right closing brace it is
not illegal but probably a sign of
trouble if a function returns a value
from one place and no value from another
place
in any case
the residual value of a function which
does not return one is certain to be
garbage
the c verifier lint checks for such
errors
the mechanics of how to compile and load
a c program which resides on multiple
source files vary from one system to the
next on the unix system for example the
cc command mentioned in chapter one does
the job
suppose that three functions are in
three files called main.c
getline.c and index.c then the command
cc main.c getline.c index.c compiles the
three files and places the resulting
relocatable object code in files main.o
getline.o and index.o and loads them all
into an executable file named a dot out
if there is an error say in main.c that
file can be recompiled by itself and the
result loaded with the previous object
files with the command cc main.c
getline.o index.o
the cc command uses the dot c suffix
versus the dot o suffix naming
convention to distinguish source files
from object files
i would note that this cc example
exactly as the authors wrote it does not
quite work as described in modern c
compilers if you want to compile your
source code and leave the compiled
object code around after the compile you
add the minus c option to the compiler
column
modern c compilers generally do accept
multiple files with either dot c or dot
o suffixes and conv combine them into a
runnable application
section 4.2 functions returning
non-integers
so far none of our programs has
contained any declaration of the type of
a function
this is because by default a function is
implicitly declared by its appearance in
an expression or statement such as while
open paren get line open paren line
comma max line close paren greater than
zero close print
if a name which has not been previously
declared occurs in an expression and is
followed by a left parenthesis it is
declared by context to be a function
name
furthermore
by default the function is assumed to
return an int
since char promotes to int in
expressions there is no need to declare
functions that return char these
assumptions cover the majority of
classes including all of our examples so
far
i would add
that's not true quite true anymore in
modern c languages you are required to
provide a type for each function if you
leave off the type for a function
declaration at a minimum you will give
us get a stern warning message
but sometimes functions do not intend to
return anything at all and so the void
type was invented to indicate that a
function returns nothing
the rule of requiring a type on a modern
function definition in c
even if it's void allows the compiler to
check to make sure all of your return
values in a function
match the expected return type
back to the text
but what happens if a function must
return some other type
many numerical functions like square
roots sine and cosine return double
other specialized functions return other
types to illustrate how to deal with
this let us write and use the function a
to f
which converts its argument string s to
its double precision floating point
equivalent
a2f is an extension of a to i
which we wrote versions of in chapters
two and three
it handles an optional sign and decimal
point and the presence or absence of
either the integer or fractional part
we note that this is not a high quality
input conversion routine it takes doing
everything takes a bit more space than
we care to use here in this book
first
a to f must declare the type of the
value it returns since it's not int
because float is converted to double in
expressions there is no point in saying
that a to f returns float we might as
well make use of the extra precision and
thus declare it to return double
the type name precedes the function name
like this
double
a to f
open parenthesis s close parenthesis
char
s open square bracket close square
bracket open curly brace
double val comma power
int i comma sine semicolon
for
i equals zero semicolon s sub i double
equals quote space quote or
s sub i double equals quote backslash
end quote or
s sub i
eq double equals quote backslash t quote
semicolon i plus plus
semicolon
that skips the white space
sine equals one
if s sub i double equals quote plus
quote or
s sub i double equals quote minus quote
sine equals
and now we're going to use a ternary
operator here paren s sub i plus plus
close
bracket
double equals quote plus quote close
paren
question mark
1 colon minus one semicolon
and that basically tells us it it makes
sine be one or negative one based on the
presence or absence of a plus or minus
for val equals zero semicolon
s sub i greater than or equal to quote
zero quote double ampersand s sub i less
than or equal to double quote nine quote
i plus plus
close paren
val equals 10 times val
plus s sub i minus quote zero quote
semicolon
what this is doing is multiplying the
current value by 10 in effect shifting
it left and then adding in that new
lower empty spot
the digit that we're encountering which
is somewhere between the character 0 and
the character 9.
continuing
if parentheses s sub i double equals
quote dot quote close parentheses
i plus plus
four open parenthesis power equals one
semicolon s sub i greater than or equal
to quote zero quote double ampersand s
sub i less than or equal to quote nine
quote semicolon i plus plus
open curly brace
val equals 10 times val plus s sub i
minus quote zero quote
again shifting the number to the left as
its as we encounter characters
power star equals 10 semicolon
close curly brace
return
open parenthesis sine times val
over power close parenthesis
semicolon
close curly brace
second and just as important the calling
routine must state that a to f returns a
non-end value the declaration is shown
in the following primitive desk
calculator
barely adequate for checkbook balancing
which reads one number per line
optionally preceded by sign and adds
them all up printing the sum after each
input
this example is from page 70 of the
textbook
pound include
stdio.h pound define max line 100
main open parenthesis close parenthesis
open curly brace double sum comma a to f
open parenthesis close parenthesis
semicolon
char line open square bracket max line
close square bracket semicolon
sum equals zero
while open parenthesis get line open
parenthesis line comma max line close
parenthesis greater than zero
close parenthesis
printf
quote backslash t
percent.2f
backslash n comma sum plus equals a to f
open parenthesis line close parenthesis
close parenthesis
semicolon
close curly brace
that code used the plus a plus equals
side effect operator and merge the call
to a to f right into the parameter of
the second parameter of printf
the declaration double sum a to f open
parentheses close parentheses says that
sum is a double variable and that a to f
is a function that returns a double
value
as a mnemonic it suggests that sum and a
to f parenthesis dot dot are both double
precision floating point values unless a
to f is explicitly declared in both
places c assumes it returns an integer
and you will get nonsense answers
if a to f itself and the call to it in
main aren't typed inconsistently with
this with in the same source file it
will be detected by the compiler but if
as is more likely a to f were compiled
separately the mismatch would not be
detected and a to f would return a
double which maine would treat as an end
and meaningless answers would result
lind catches this error
given a to f we could in principle write
a to i to convert a string to an integer
in terms of it
int a to i open parentheses s close
parentheses char s open square bracket
close square bracket semicolon open
curly brace double
a to f open parenthesis close
parenthesis semicolon
return open parenthesis
a to f
close parentheses s close parentheses
close parentheses semicolon close curly
brace
note the structure of the declarations
in the return statement the value in the
expression in return expression is
always converted to the type of the
function before the return is taken
therefore the value of a to f
a double is converted automatically to
int when it appears
in a return since the function a to i
returns an end
the conversion of a floating point value
to in truncates
any fractional part as we discussed in
chapter two
more on function arguments
in chapter one we discuss the fact that
function arguments are passed by value
that is the called function receives a
private temporary copy of each argument
not its address
this means that the function cannot
affect the original argument in the
calling function
within a function each argument is in
effect a local variable initialized to
the value with which the function was
called
when an array name appears as an
argument to a function the location of
the beginning of the array is passed
elements are not copied the function can
alter elements of the array by
subscripting from this location
the effect is that arrays are always
passed by reference
in chapter 5 we will discuss the use of
pointers to permit functions to affect
non-arrays in calling functions
a bit of a digression
since including array as an argument
passes the location or memory address of
the array into the function the function
cannot can change the items in the array
using array subscripts
in particular the array contents are not
copied when an array is passed into a c
function
when we get destructs in a future
chapter we will find that the content of
structs
also are passed using the address of the
entire struct so structs are passed by
reference as well
when thinking about past by reference or
pass by value remember that a char
variable is a single item similar to int
and passed by value i.e is copied in c
strings are arrays of characters so they
are passed by reference
python follows this design for the same
efficiency reason as c
normal single variables like int or
float are copied before being passed
into a function and therefore passed by
value
collections like list or dict are passed
into functions by reference so the
contents can be changed within a
function
python strings are not technically
copied when being passed into a function
but the way assignments happen in python
make it seem like strings are passed by
value
since they can never be modified
you can learn more with a bit of web
research but the easy way is to imagine
in python that strings are passed by
value with a clever trick to avoid
requiring a copy for every function call
php follows the same pattern of passing
numbers and strings by value and passing
arrays as reference
php passes strings by value without
recover without requiring a copy again
using clever runtime code
because in java javascript and php
strings are objects of course which we
haven't discussed much yet
those languages can make sure that
strings act as if they were passed by
value and not passed by reference the
way they are always passed in c
c made decisions on its run time based
on getting the maximum performance out
of the hardware of the 1970s at the
expense of making it too easy to write
code that overwrites memory and leads to
corrupted programs that have dangerous
and undefined behavior
languages like php java and javascript
add a small amount of runtime overhead
to do things like store the length of an
array and make sure we programmers don't
over reference the array and overwrite
random bits of our program's code or
data
the creators of c placed more priority
on speed and efficient use of memory
than safety
it is like driving an autom automobile
in the rain without abs automatic
braking system it is fast but dangerous
and should be reserved by highly skilled
and very careful programmers
and drivers and those drivers should
probably be on a race course
by the way
back to the text
by the way there is no entirely
satisfactory way to write a portable
function that accepts a variable number
of arguments because there is no
portable way for the called function to
determine how many arguments were
actually passed in a given call
thus you can't write a truly portable
function that will compute the maximum
of an arbitrary number of arguments as
will the max functions that are built in
to fortran and pl1
it is generally safe to deal with a
variable number of arguments if the
called function doesn't use an argument
that was not actually supplied and if
the types are consistent printf the most
common c function with a variable number
of arguments uses information from the
first argument which is the formatting
string to determine how many other
arguments are present and what their
types are it fails badly if the caller
does not supply enough arguments or if
types are not what the first argument
says it is also
non-portable and therefore must be
modified for different programming
environments
alternatively if arguments are of known
types it is possible to mark the end of
the argument list in some agreed-upon
way such as a special argument value
often zero that stands for the end of
the arguments
interestingly modern languages like
python php and java go to great lengths
to make variable length argument lists
work predictably and portably the syntax
for variable length argument lists in
these language can be a bit obtuse at
times but at least it's allowed
documented reliable
and portable
section 4 external variables
a c program consists of a set of
external objects which are either
variables or functions the adjective
external
is used primarily in contrast to
internal which describes arguments and
automatic variables defined inside
functions
external variables are defined outside
any function and are thus potentially
available to many functions
functions themselves are always external
because c does not allow functions to be
defined inside other functions
by default external variables are also
global so that all references to such a
variable by the same name
even from functions that are compiled
separately are references to the same
thing
in as this sense external variables are
analogous to fortran common or pl1
external
we will later see how to define external
variables and functions that are not
globally available but instead only
visible within a single source file
because external variables are globally
accessible they provide an alternative
to function arguments and return values
for communicating data between function
any function may access an external
variable by referring it to by name
if the name has been declared somehow if
a large number of variables must be
shared among functions external
variables are a more convenient and
efficient than long argument lists
as pointed out in chapter 1 however this
reasoning should be applied with some
caution for it can have a bad effect on
program structure and lead to programs
with many data connections between
functions
a second
reason for using external variables
concerns initialization in particular
external arrays may be initialized but
automatic
ie internal arrays may not we will treat
initialization near the end of this
chapter
the third reason for using external
variables is their scope and lifetime
automatic variables are internal to a
function
they come into existence
when the routine is entered and
disappear when it's left
external variables on the other hand are
permanent they do not come and go so
they retain values from one function
invocation to the next
thus if two functions must share some
data yet neither calls the other it is
often most convenient if the shared data
is kept in external variables rather
than passed in and out via arguments
let's examine this issue further with a
larger example
the problem is to write another
calculator program better than the
previous one
this one permits plus minus asterisk and
slash
and equals
equals will print our answer
because it is somewhat easier to
implement the calculator will you use
reverse polish notation instead of in
fixed notation
reverse polish notation is the scheme
used by for example hewlett-packard
pocket calculators
in reverse polish notation each operator
follows its operators
operands
an infix expression like open
parenthesis 1 minus 2 close parentheses
c star open parenthesis 4 plus 5
close parenthesis equals is entered as
1
2
minus
4
5 plus star equals
parentheses are not needed in reverse
polish notation the implementation is
quite simple
each operand is pushed onto a stack
when an operator arrives the proper
number of operands two for binary
operators are popped
the operator applied to them and the
result is pushed back onto the stack
in the example above one and two are
pushed then replaced by their difference
negative one
next four and five are pushed then
replaced by their sum nine
and then the product of negative one and
nine which is negative nine replaces
them on the stack and then the equal
sign operator prints the top element
without removing it
so intermediate steps in a calculation
can be checked
the operations of pushing and popping a
stack are trivial but by the time error
detection and recovery are added they're
long enough so it's better to put each
in a separate function than to repeat
the code throughout the whole program
and there should be a separate function
for effects fetching the next input
operator or operand
thus the overall structure of the
program is
while
next operator or operand is not into
file if it's a number push it
else if it's an operator pop operands do
the opera operation and push the result
else error
the main design decision that has not
yet been discussed is where the stack is
that is what routines access it directly
one possibility is to keep it in main
and pass the stack and current stack
position to the retrains that push and
pop it
but maine doesn't need to know about the
variables that control the stack it
should only think about pushing and
popping so we
have decided to make the stack and its
associated information
external variables accessible to push
and pop but not to main
translating this outline to code is easy
enough the main program is primarily a
big switch
on the type of operator or operand this
is a more typical use of switch than the
one shown in chapter 3.
this sample code is from page 74 of the
textbook
pound include stdio.h
pound define maxop 20 pound defined
number quote zero quote
this is going to be a single we found a
number and pound to find two big quote
nine quote a signal that the string is
too big
main open parenthesis close parenthesis
open curly brace
int
type semicolon
char s open square bracket max op close
square bracket semicolon
double
opt 2
a to f open parenthesis close
parenthesis
comma pop open parenthesis close
parenthesis comma push open parenthesis
close parenthesis semicolon
while open parenthesis open parenthesis
type equals get up open parenthesis s
comma max op
close parenthesis close parenthesis not
equal e o f close parenthesis
switch open parenthesis type close
parenthesis open curly brace
case number colon
note that number is a predefined
constant above
push open parenthesis a to f open
parenthesis s close parenthesis close
parenthesis semicolon break
case quote plus quote
colon
push open parenthesis pop open paren
close paren plus pop open for n close
paren close paren
semicolon break semicolon
case
quote asterisk quote colon
push open paren pop open paren close
paren
asterisk pop open paren close paren
close paren semicolon break semicolon
that was the multiplication
case
quote minus quote colon
op 2 equals pop open for n close paren
push open paren pop minus op2
close print semicolon
break semicolon that was subtraction
case open print slash close paren
colon op 2 equals pop open paren
semicolon if up to
not equal 0.0 push open print
pop open paren close print slash opt2
close paren semicolon else
printf double quote zero divisor popped
backslash n double quote
close paren semicolon break
case quote equal
quote colon printf open paren double
quote backslash t percent f backslash n
double quote comma
push open paren pop open friend close
paren close paren close friend semicolon
so to print it we pop it and
push it and then print the residual
value of the push function
the next line is break semicolon
case
quote c quote colon
clear open paren close print
semicolon break semicolon
case too big
colon
print f
double quote percent dot 20 s
space dot dot dot is too long backslash
n double quote comma s close paren
semicolon break semicolon
default colon
print f
open paren double quote unknown command
percent c backslash n
double quote comma type open print close
print semicolon break semicolon close
paren close curly brace to finish the
switch statement and then close
curly brace to finish
the main
so now we're going to have a separate
file that has some of these functions
defined
this file is on page 75 of the textbook
this file will be compiled separately
but then later linked all together with
the main program but we're going to
define
push
pop and clear in this file
pound include
stdio.h pawn define maxval 100
maximum value that would be the maximum
value of our stack the maximum size of
our stack maximum depth of our stack
now we are declaring variables outside
of any function these are the external
variables
int sp equals zero
double val open square bracket max val
close square bracket semicolon
and so those variables are external
variables and they're outside of all of
the functions but we can use them in any
function and there's just one copy no
matter what function we're using it so
now we define our functions
double push open paren f close paren
double f semicolon open curly brace if
open paren sp
less than max val close paren return
open paren val open square bracket sp
plus plus close square bracket equals f
close paren semicolon
else
open curly brace
printf double quote air colon stack full
backslash n double quote closed paren
semicolon
clear open paren close print semicolon
return open print zero close paren
semicolon close curly brace
to finish the else and then close curly
brace to finish the double function the
push function
and now we define the pop
double pop open print close paren open
curly brace if open paren sp greater
than zero close paren return open paren
val open square bracket minus minus sp
close square bracket close curly brace
semicolon else open curly brace printf
open paren double quote error colon
stack empty backslash n close quote
close double quote
close paren semicolon clear open paren
close paren semicolon return open print
zero close paren semicolon close curly
brace to finish the else and then close
curly brace to finish the double
and the last function we're going to
define is the clear function
which is quite simple clear open paren
close paren open curly brace sp equals
zero semicolon
close paren
i would note that
just read this one carefully
they're very good at using side effect
operators and side effect assignments
and to keep this code very simple and
succinct
and you really have to understand a lot
of the other stuff that you've
covered in the book up to this point
back to the text
the command c clears the stack with the
function clear which can also be used by
push and pop in case of error we'll
return to get op in a moment
as discussed in chapter one a variable
is external if it is desi defined
outside the body of any function
thus the stack and stack pointer which
must be shared by push pop and clear are
defined outside the three functions but
if main itself does not refer to the
stack or stack pointer their
representation is carefully hidden
thus the code for the equal operator
must use
push
open print pop parentheses parentheses
close parenthesis close parenthesis
semicolon to examine the top of the
stack without disturbing it notice also
that because plus and multiplication are
commutative operators the order in which
the popped operands are combined is
irrelevant but for the minus and slash
operators the left and right operands
must be distinguished
this example code above shows why it's
important to remember the k and r c
arrange rearrangement license as it
applies to operators that are
associative and commutative
if the code for the minus operator were
written written push open paren pop open
print close print minus pop open print
close paren
close print semicolon there is no
guarantee that the left pop will run
before the right pop
and since these functions access global
variables and have side effects
it is important to force the compiler
not to rearrange the order of the
function calls to force the evaluation
order the code is broken into two
statements op2 equals pop open print
close print semicolon push open open
paren
pop open paren close paren minus op2
close paren semicolon now you might
think that the lesson here is that the k
rc arrangement license which was done to
allow optimization and performance is a
bad idea
but the more important lesson is that
writing low level utility functions like
push and pop that use global variables
and have side effects is a dangerous
pattern in any programming language
section 4.5
scope rules
the functions and external variables
that make up a c program need not all be
compiled at the same time the source
text of the program may be kept in
several files and previously compiled
routines may be loaded from libraries
the two questions of interest are
how are declarations written so that
variables are properly declared during
compilation and how our declarations set
up so that all the pieces will be
properly linked or connected when the
program is loaded
the scope of a name is the part of the
program over which the name is defined
for an automatic variable
declared at the beginning of a function
the scope is the function in which the
name is declared and variables of the
same name in different functions are
unrelated
the same is true of the arguments of the
function
the scope of an external variable lasts
from the point at which is it is
declared in a source file to the end of
that file
for example if val sp push pop and clear
are defined in one file in the order
shown above that is intsp equals zero
double val open square bracket maxval
close square bracket semicolon
double push open print f close paren
open curly brace dot dot close curly
brace double pop open print close paren
open curly brace dot dot dot close curly
brace clear open paren close paren open
curly brace dot dot dot close
curly brace then the variables val and s
p may be used in push pop and clear
simply by naming them and no further
declarations are needed
on the other hand
if an external variable is to be
referenced before it is defined or it is
defined in a different source file from
the one in which it's being used then an
extern declaration is mandatory
it is very important to distinguish
between the declaration of an external
variable and its definition
a declaration announces the property of
the variable its type its size etc
a definition also causes storage to be
allocated
if the lines int
sp semicolon
double val open square bracket maxval
close square bracket semicolon appear
outside any function they define the
external variables sp and val
and cause the storage to be allocated
and also serve as the declaration
for the rest of that source file
on the other hand the lines extern int
sp
extern double val open square bracket
close score bracket semicolon
declare for the rest of the source file
that sp is an int and val is a double
array whose size is determined and
allocated elsewhere
but they do not create variables or
allocate storage for them there must be
only one definition of an external
variable among all the files that make
up the source program
other files may contain extern
declarations to access it
there may also be an extern declaration
in the file containing the definition
any initialization of an external
variable goes only with the definition
array sizes must be specified with the
definition but are optional with the
extern declaration
although it is not a likely organization
for this program
val and sp could be defined and
initialized in one file and the
functions push pop and clear defined in
another
then these definitions and declarations
would be necessary to tie them together
in file 1 we would see int sp 0
semicolon double val open square bracket
max val close square bracket semicolon
and then in file 2
x turn in sp semicolon x turn double val
open square bracket close square bracket
semicolon
double push open print f close paren
open curly brace dot dot close curly
brace
double pop open frame close paren
open curly brace dot dot dot close curly
brace
clear open friend close paren open curly
brace dot dot dot close curly brace
because the x turned declarations in
file two lie ahead and outside the three
functions they apply to all
one set of declarations suffices for all
of file 2.
for larger programs the pound include
file inclusion facility discussed later
in this chapter allows one to keep only
a single copy of the extern declarations
for the program and have that inserted
in each source file it's as it's being
compiled
let us now turn to the implementation of
getup the function that
fetches the next operator or operand the
basic task is easy
skip blanks
tabs and new lines if the character is
not a digit or a decimal point return it
otherwise collect a string of digits
that might include a decimal point and
return number a single signal that a
number has been collected
the routine is substantially complicated
by an attempt to handle the situation
properly when the input number is too
long
get up reads digits perhaps with an
intervening decimal point until it
doesn't see anymore but only stores the
ones that fit
if there was no overflow it returns
number in the string of digits
if the number was too long however getup
discards the rest of the input line so
the user can simply retype the line from
the point of error it returns too big as
the overflow signal
this example code
is from page 78
of the textbook and you can view it at
www.cc4e.com
code
page 78
get up
open friend s comma lim close paren char
s open square bracket close square back
at semicolon
int lim semicolon open curly brace
int i comma c semicolon
while open paren open paren c equals get
ch open paren close paren close paren
double equals quote space quote or
c double equals quote backslash t quote
or c double equals quote backslash end
quote close paren semicolon
skip all the blanks
if c is not equal
quote dot quote and
open paren c less than quote zero quote
vertical bar vertical bar c greater than
quote nine quote close paren close paren
return s return open paren c close paren
s sub zero equals c
four paren i equals one semicolon open
paren c equals get chart open paren
close paren close print greater than or
equal to quote zero quote and c less
than or equal to quote nine quote
semicolon i plus plus
inside the for loop
if i less than limb
s sub i equals c
if open for n c double equals quote dot
quote
close paren open curly brace we begin to
collect the fraction
if
open print i
less than limb
close paren s sub i equals c
four open paren i plus plus
c equals get char open paren close paren
close paren greater than or equal to
quote zero quote
ampersand ampersand c less than or equal
to quote nine quote
semicolon i plus plus closed paren
if open prime i less than limb close
paren s sub i equals c
close curly brace to close the if
statement where we're collecting the
fraction
if open paren i less than limb close
paren open curly brace
this means the number is good
ungetch is ch open friends c close paren
semicolon
s sub i equals quote backslash zero
quote semicolon
return
open paren number close print and recall
that number is a predefined constant
close curly brace else open curly brace
if it's too big we're going to skip to
the end of the line
while open paren c not equal
quote backslash end quote and c not
equal eof open paren
c equals get char open for enclosed
paren semicolon
s sublim minus one equals quote
backslash zero quote semicolon
return too big semicolon close curly
brace to finish the if and then close
curly brace to finish the function
recall that too big is a
constant that indicates that we've read
too much
back to the text
what are get ch and unget ch well it is
often the case that a programming
reading input cannot determine that is
read enough until it is read too much
one instance is collecting characters
that make up a number
until the first non-digit is seen the
number is not complete but then the
program has read one character too far
and that is a character it is not
prepared for
the problem would be solved if it were
possible to unread the unwanted
character then every time the program
reads one character too many it could
push it back on the input so that the
rest of the code would behave as if it
never been read
fortunately it is easy to simulate
ungetting a character by writing a pair
of cooperating functions getch delivers
the next input character to be
considered
ungetch puts the character back on the
input so the next call to get ch will
return it again
how they work together is simple
unget ch puts puts the pushed back
characters into a shared buffer a
character array gets the ch reads from
the buffer is there's anything there and
then it calls get char if the buffer is
empty
there must be an index variable which
records the position of the current
character in the buffer
since the buffer and index are shared by
get ch and unget ch and must retain
their values between calls they must be
external to both routines
thus we can write getch and ungetch and
their shared variables as follows
this is on page 79 of the textbook you
can see the code at www.cc4e.com
code and go to page 79
pound include
stdio.h
found to find buff size 100
char buff open square bracket buff size
close square bracket semicolon
int buff p equals zero semicolon those
are the external variables outside any
function
here's the first function get ch open
friend close paren open curly brace
return open parenthesis open parenthesis
buff p greater than zero close
parenthesis question mark
buff
open square bracket minus minus buff p
close square bracket colon
get char open paren close paren close
paren semicolon close curly brace to
finish the get ch function
the unget ch function pushes a character
back on input
ch open paren c close paren into c
semicolon
open curly brace
if open paren buff p greater than buff
size printf
open prin double quote unget ch colon
too many characters backslash n double
quote
close paren semicolon else
buff
open square bracket buff p plus plus
close square bracket equals c semicolon
and then close curly brace to finish the
ungetch function
we have used an array for pushback
rather than a single character since the
generality may come in handy later
section 4.6 static variables static
variables are a third class of storage
in addition to the x turn and automatic
that we've already met
static variables may either be internal
or external
internal static variables are local to a
particular function just like automatic
variables are but unlike automatics they
remain in existence rather than coming
and going each time the function's
activated
this means that internal static
variables provide private permanent
storage in a function
character strings that appear within a
function such as the arguments of printf
are internal static
an external static
variable is known within the remainder
of the source file in which it's
declared but not in any other file
external static thus provides a way to
hide names like buff and buff p in the
get ch unget ch combination
which must be external so they can be
shared
yet which should not be visible to users
of get ch and unguess ch so there's no
possibility of conflict if the two
routines are compiled in one file as in
static char buff open square bracket
buff size close square bracket semicolon
static int buff p equals zero semicolon
get ch open frame close paren open curly
brace dot dot close curly brace unget ch
open paren c close paren open curly
brace dot dot dot close curly brace then
no other routine will be able to access
buff and buff p
in fact
they will not conflict with the same
names in other files of the same program
static storage whether internal or
external is specified by prefixing the
normal declaration with the word static
the variable is external if it's defined
outside of any function and internal if
defined inside a function
normally functions are external objects
their names are known globally
it is possible for a function however to
be declared static
this makes its name unknown outside the
file in which it's declared
in c
static
connotates
not only
permanence but also a degree of what
might be called
privacy internal static objects are
known only inside one function
external static objects variables or
function are are known only within the
source file in which they appear their
names do not interfere with variables or
functions
of the same name in other files
external static variables and functions
provide a way to conceal data objects
and any internal routines that
manipulate them so that other routines
and data cannot conflict even
inadvertently
for example getch and ungetch form a
module for character input and pushback
buff and buff p should be static so
they're inaccessible from the outside
in the same way push pop and clear form
a module for stack manipulations
val and sp should also be external
static
4.7
register variables
the fourth and final storage class is
called register
a registered declaration advises the
compiler that the variable in question
will be heavily used when possible
register variables are placed in machine
registers
which may result in smaller and faster
programs
the register declaration looks like
register int x
semicolon
register char c semicolon and so on the
in part may be omitted register can only
be applied to automatic variables and
the formal parameters of a function
in this latter case the function
declaration looks like
f open paren c comma n close paren
register int c comma n semicolon open
curly brace register int i semicolon and
then dot dot
close curly brace
in practice there are some restrictions
on register variables reflecting the
realities of the underlying hardware
only a few variables in each function
may be kept in registers and only
certain types are allowed
the word register is ignored for excess
or disallowed declarations
and it is not possible to take the
address of a register variable a topic
that will be covered in chapter 5. the
specific restrictions vary from machine
to machine
as an example on the pdp-11
only the first three registered
declarations in a function are
effective and the types must be int char
or pointer
as a quick aside the description of the
details of the implementation of the
register modder modifier on the pdp-11
is a delightful peek into how the c
compiler generated runtime code on that
particular system in the 1970s
as compilers have become more
sophisticated the compiler could decide
which variables to keep in registers far
better than the programmer could
and since
how variables would be allocated to
registers might be different on
different hardware architectures the
register indication is generally ignored
by modern c compilers so you should
probably never use it in your code
as a matter of fact
i wrote the following sample c program
and compiled it with the minus capital s
option so i could see the generated
assembly language with and without the
register declaration
with optimization there was no
difference between the code generated
with or without the registered
declaration
the reason the generated assembly code
was identical once you take a look at it
was regardless of the use the register
keyboard was that the c optimizer on my
arm based computer in 2022 realized the
best way to implement the code was to
keep both of the variables in registers
because the loop code was so simple and
the cpu in my computer has plenty of
registers and optimized any loading and
storing of the data for these variables
right out of the program
in 1978 the authors likely included the
register function as a feature to
convince the experienced assembly
language programmers that they should
write all but the lowest lowest level
code in c
so write a little tiny bit in c and then
i mean write a little tiny bit in
assembly language and write everything
else in c
so here's an example that's not in the
textbook it's on page 81 if it were in
the textbook you can see this code at
www.cc4ed
code page 81
and this is code that i wrote to play
with the register keyword to mostly
convince myself it was pointless to use
it but here we go
pound include stdio dot h
int
main open prime close print open curly
brace
int compute semicolon
register end enter
semicolon scanf open for n double quote
percent d
close quote comma ampersand compute
close parenthesis semicolon
printf open parenthesis double quote
compute space percent d backslash n
double quote comma compute close
parenthesis semicolon
four
open print iter equals zero semicolon
enter less than one thousand semicolon
iter plus plus close parenthesis open
curly brace compute equals open
parenthesis compute times 22 close
parenthesis times seven
if compute
greater than one thousand compute equals
compute modulo one thousand
close curly brace printf
open paren double quote compute space
percent d backslash n close quote comma
compute
semicolon close curly brace now some of
these i wrote this code in a way
that
tries to convince the
uh the the optimizer that i'm actually
going to use these values that's why i
read the value from input as compared to
a constant it would actually optim the
optimizer so so so smart that it would
just eliminate all the constant
calculations so
but that's my sample
playing with register
section 4.8 block structure
c is not a block structured language in
the sense of pl1 or algol in that
functions may not be defined within
other functions
on the other hand variables can be
defined in a block structured fashion
declarations of variables including
initializations may follow the left
brace that introduces any compound
statement
not just the one that begins a function
variables declared this this way
supersede any identically named
variables in outer blocks and remain in
existence until the matching right race
for example
if open parentheses n greater than zero
close parenthesis open curly brace int i
semicolon
declare a new i
four open parenthesis i equals 0
semicolon i less than n semicolon i plus
plus
close parenthesis and dot dot the rest
of the for loop and then a closed curly
brace for the if
the scope of the variable i
is in the true branch of the if this i
is unrelated to any other i in the
program
block structure also applies to external
variables given the declarations
int x semicolon f open parenthesis
closed parenthesis open curly brace
double x
semicolon dot dot dot close parenthesis
then within the function f occurrences
of x refer to the internal double
variable outside of f they refer to the
external integer this is
same is true of the names of formal
parameters
for example
in z semicolon outside of any function
f open parenthesis z close parenthesis
double z semicolon open curly brace dot
dot close curly brace within function f
z
refers to the formal parameter not the
external variable
section 4.9 initialization
initialization has been mentioned in
passing many times so far but always
peripherally to some other topic this
section summarized some of the rules now
that we have discussed the various
storage classes
in absence of explicit initialization
external and static variables are
guaranteed to be initialized to zero
automatic and register variables have
undefined or garbage values
simple variables not arrays or
structures may be initialized when they
are declared by following the name with
an equal sign and a constant expression
int x equals one semicolon jar s quote
equals single quote backslash single
quote single quote semicolon
a constant of a single character that is
a single quote itself
long day equals 60 times 24 semicolon
which is the minutes in a day
for external and static variables the
initialization is done once conceptually
at compile time for automatic and
register variables it is done each time
the function or block is entered
for automatic and register variables the
initializer is not restricted to being a
constant it may in fact be any valid
expression involving previously defined
values
even function calls
for example the initializations of the
binary search program that we wrote in
chapter 3 could be written as
binary open parenthesis x comma
v comma n close parenthesis int
x comma v open square bracket close
square bracket comma n semicolon
open curly brace
int low equals zero semicolon and high
equals n minus one semicolon and in mid
followed by the rest of the function and
then close curly brace
instead of
initializing these as the first
executable statements and we would do
this with binary open paren x comma v
comma n close paren int x comma v open
square bracket close square bracket
comma n semicolon
open curly brace
int low comma mid comma high
semicolon low equals 0 semicolon high
equals n minus 1 semicolon and so forth
in effect initializations of automatic
variables are just shorthand for
assignment statements
which form to prefer is largely a matter
of taste we have generally used explicit
assignments because initializers and
declarations are harder to see
automatic arrays may not be initialized
external and static arrays may be
initialized by following the declaration
with a list of initializers enclosed in
braces and separated by commas
for example the character counting
program of chapter 1 which originally
was
main open parentheses closed princely
open curly brace
int c comma i comma n white comma n
other
int n digit open square bracket 10 close
square bracket semicolon
n white equals n other equals zero
four open parenthesis i equals zero
semicolon i less than ten semicolon i
plus plus closed parenthesis
and digit sub i equals 0 and then the
rest of the code
followed by a closed curly brace
finishing main
this could be written instead using
initializers as follows int and white
equals 0 semicolon int and other equals
zero semicolon int n digit open square
bracket 10 close square bracket equals
open curly brace
zero com zero comma zero comma zero
comma zero comma zero comma zero comma
zero comma zero comma zero
close curly brace
ten zeros in a row and
separated by commas and in braces
and then the main code is simply main
open paren close paren open curly brace
in comma c comma i and then the rest of
the main code close curly brace the idea
is is that with the initializers and
with the external variables outside of
the main function you do not need to
initialize them even with a for loop in
the beginning of the main program
these initializations are actually all
unnecessary since they're all zero
anyways but it's a good form to make
them explicit anyway
if there are fewer initializers than the
specialized size the others will be zero
it is an error to have too many
initializers
regrettably there is no way to
specify the repetition of an initializer
nor to initialize an element in the
middle of the ray without supplying all
the intermeaning intervening values as
well
character arrays are a special case of
initialization
a string may be used instead of the
braces in commas notation
as in
char
pattern open square bracket close square
bracket equals double quote th e double
quote semicolon
this is a shorthand for the longer but
equivalent char pattern open square
bracket close square bracket equals open
curly brace single quote t single quote
comma single quote h single quote comma
single quote e single quote comma single
quote backslash zero single quote close
curly brace semicolon
when the size of an array of any type is
omitted the compiler will compute the
length of the array by counting the
initial
initializers in this specific case
the size of pattern is four
three actual characters plus the
terminating backslash zero
i would note that the primary difference
between c and c influence like languages
like java php and javascript this key is
that c
strings are character arrays while in
the other languages strings are objects
these string objects do have inside
themselves an array of bytes or
characters but they also keep track of
things like the length of the string and
provide functionality like extract a
substring in the methods in these
objects
in c
there is a set of library functions that
perform string operations like compare
two strings
while cut string comparison is built
into the string objects in each of the
other languages
strings as character arrays allow
programmers to build very fast low-level
code in libraries and operating systems
but to write the code well you need to
understand what is really going on at
the low level
section 4.10 recursion
c functions may be used recursively that
is a function may call itself either
directly or indirectly
one traditional example involves
printing of a number as a character
string as we mentioned before
the digits are generated in the wrong
order
low order digits are available before
four high order digits but they have to
be printed in the other way around
there are two solutions to this problem
one is to store the digits in an array
as they are generated and then print
them in reverse order as we did in
chapter 3 with eye to a
the first version of print d follows
this pattern
this is sample code on page 85 of the
textbook you can view the sample code at
com www.cc4e.com code page 85 example
one
pound include stdo dot h
print d open paren and close paren
in
open curly brace char
s open square bracket 10 close square
bracket semicolon and i semicolon
if parenthesis n less than 0 parenthesis
open curly brace put char
open prin single quote dash
single quote close paren semicolon
n equals minus n semicolon close curly
brace
i equals zero
semicolon
do open curly brace
s sub i plus plus
equals n modulo 10 plus quote zero quote
which gets the next character while
parentheses parenthesis
equal 10 close parenthesis greater than
zero
close parenthesis semicolon
then we reverse the string while open
print minus minus i greater than equal
to zero close paren put char open paren
s sub i
close paren semicolon close curly brace
to end the print d function
the alternative is a recursive solution
in which each call of print d first its
calls itself to cope with any leading
digits then prints the trailing digit
after that call returns
this is an example on page 85 of the
textbook in its example
pound include
stdio.h print d open paren n close paren
int n semicolon open curly brace
int i semicolon if open friend n less
than zero close paren open curly brace
put chair
open paren single quote dash single
quote close paren semicolon
n equals minus n semicolon close curly
brace to finish the if
if
open paren open print i equals n over 10
close print not equal 0
close print
print d
open print i closed paren semicolon
that's the recursive call
and after the recursive call comes back
we do put char open paren
n modulo 10 plus
single quote 0 single quote close paren
semicolon close curly brace to end the
print d function
when a function calls itself recursively
each invocation gets a fresh set of all
the automatic variables quite
independent of the previous set
thus in print d 123
the first print d has n equals 123.
it passes 12 to a second print e
then prints three when that one returns
in the same way the second print d
passes one to a third which prints it
and then prints 2.
recursion generally provides no saving
in storage since somewhere a stack of
values is being processed or has to be
maintained nor will it be faster but
recursive code is more compact and often
much easier to write and understand
recursion is especially convenient for
recursively defined data structures like
trees we will see a nice example in
chapter 6.
as an aside ah recursion recursion
recursion
recursion is a beloved concept in
computer science
it is often taught early in most
programming courses because it is just
so cool
most examples are sadly like computing
factorial or the example above
converting an integer to a string and
they're not good uses a recursion
actually
but when you do finally find yourself in
need of traversing a tree-based
structure like an xml document or
parsing a mathematical expression with
parentheses recursion is the ideal
solution so the problem in a sense is
not recursion but when it is taught and
what examples are used
interestingly kernighan and ritchie
include the correct warning about using
recursion when it is not
the best solution in the above text
and it bears another read
back to the book
recursion generally provides no saving
in storage since somewhere a stack of
values is being processed or has to be
maintained nor will it be faster
but recursive code is more compact and
often much easier to write and
understand
recursion is especially convenient for
recursively defined data structures
like trees we will see a nice example in
chapter 6.
i couldn't have said it better
section 4.11 the c
preprocessor
c provides certain language extensions
by means of a simple macro preprocessor
the pound defined capability which we
have used is the most common of these
extensions
another is the ability to include the
entire contents of other files during
compilation
file inclusion
to facilitate handling of pound defines
and declarations among other things c
provides a file inclusion feature
any line that looks like pound include
space double quote file name double
quote
is replaced by the contents of the file
name the quotes are indeed mandatory
often a line or two of this form appears
at the very beginning of each source
file to include common pound-defined
statements and extern declarations for
global variables pound includes may be
nested
pound include is the preferred way to
tie declarations together for a large
problem and in a large program
it guarantees that all the source files
will be supplied with the same
definitions and variable declarations
thus eliminating a particularly nasty
kind of bug
of course when an include file is
changed all the files that depend on it
must be recompiled
macro substitution
a definition of the form pound define
yes one calls for a macro substitution
of the simplest kind
repeat replacing a logical name by a
string of characters names in the pound
of fine have the same forms as the c
identifiers the replacement text is
arbitrarily normally the replacement
text is the rest of the line
a long definition may be continued by
pasting a backslash at the end of the
line to be continued the scope of the
name defined with pound define is from
from its point of definition to the end
of the source file
names may be redefined and a definition
may use previous definitions
substitutions do not place take place
within quoted strings so for example if
yes is a defined name there would be no
substitution in printf open paren double
quote yes double quote close paren
since implementation of pound define is
a macro pre-pass not part of the
compiler proper there are very few
grammatical restrictions on what can be
defined for example
alcohol fans can say
pound define
then and then nothing
pound define begin
open curly brace
pound define end
semicolon close curly brace and then
write
approximate algo
if
paren i greater than zero close paren
then begin
a equals one semicolon
b equals two
end
it is also possible to define macular
macros with arguments so the replacement
text depends on the way the macro is
called
as an example define a macro called max
like this
pound define max open paren a comma b
open paren open paren a close paren
greater than open paren b close print
question mark open parent a closed paren
colon open paren b close paren close
paren
now the line x equals max open paren p
plus q comma r plus s close paren
semicolon will be replaced in the
preprocessor by the line
x equals open paren open paren p plus q
close paren greater than open paren r
plus s close paren question mark open
paren p plus q close print colon open
paren r plus s close paren close print
semicolon
this provides a maximum function that
expands into inline code rather than a
function call
so long as the arguments are treated
consistently this macro will serve for
any data type there is no need for
different kinds of macs for different
data types as there would be with
functions
of course if you examine the expansion
of max above you will notice some
pitfalls the expressions are evaluated
twice it is bad if they involve side
effects like function calls increment
operators or perhaps push and pop like
we've used before
some care has to be taken with
parentheses to make sure the order order
of evaluation is preserved
consider the macro
pound defined square open paren x close
paren equals
x times x
when it is invoked as square open paren
z plus one
close paren
there are even some purely lexical
problems
there can be no space between the macro
name and left parenthesis that
introduces the argument list
nevertheless macros are quite valuable
one practical example is the standard io
library to be described in chapter 7 in
which git char and put char are defined
as macros obviously put chart needs an
argument thus avoiding the overhead of a
function call per character profit
process
other capabilities of the macro
processor are described in appendix a
as a bit of a long aside
in this section we are talking about the
preprocessor
it's probably a good time to talk a bit
about why we use this terminology
for those of you with a computer science
degree from back in the day many of you
wrote a compiler as a senior project
just like i did
building a compiler was a great project
because part of the goal of computer
science is to understand the
technologies that make programming
process possible from the language
syntax down to the hardware
the compiler that translates our source
code into machine code is an essential
part of the technology stack that we use
early compilers for languages like the
early fortran variants tended to be
translators they just translated code
one line at a time from a high-level
language to assembly language
you could think of early fortran
programs in the 1950s and the 1960s as
just more convenient ways to write
assembly language for programmers that
knew assembly language you always needed
to be aware of assembly language and the
translation
that it was going to write
fast fortran
programs were small and optimization was
done at the fortran level often leading
to some hard to understand code
by the mid-1970s programming languages
were based on parsing theory and we used
what is called a grammar to define the
language
kernighan and ritchie kept io statements
out of the c language to keep its formal
definition i.e its grammar as simple as
possible
as these new languages emerge they
allowed for more theoretical and
powerful approach to converting source
code to machine language
the theoretical advances in compiler and
language design meant that parts of the
compiler might be reusable across
multiple programming languages
each language could have its own syntax
and grammar rules and they could be
plugged into the compiler and poof you
would have a new programming language
it got to the point where unix system
unix systems had a tool called yak which
stood for yet another compiler compiler
you would give it a grammar for your new
language and it would make a compiler
for you
as a matter of fact the javascript
language that was created in 10 days
back in 1995 was possible because
brendan ike had a lot of experience with
compiler generators
he defined a grammar for javascript and
generated his first compiler
part of what made a compiler generate
generator possible is the idea of a
multi-step compiler or the tasks of a
compiler were broken down into a series
of simpler and more well-defined steps
here are the steps of a typical c
compiler in the 1970s
first a preprocessor step that takes c
code with syntax like pound define and
pout include as its input and produces
raw c code output with o's instructions
processed and or expanded the
preprocessor processor was a c to c
transformation
next
a parser step that took the raw c code
applied the grammar to the language and
created what is called a parse tree
think of the tree as a hierarchy of
statements grouped into blocks grouped
into functions etc of things like a loop
or just one node in a parse tree
after that a code generation would turn
the parse tree into some kind of
simplistic
portable internal code that expanded
things like loops and if-then-else
statements into code
after that a code optimization that
looked at the internal code and moved
things around
eliminating any redundant computations
say don't compute the same things twice
this step is why the authors make such a
big fuss about how there are times where
c might do things in a slightly
different order in an expression even in
the presence of parentheses remember the
knrc arrangement license back in chapter
2
that rule removes constraints on the
compiler's optimization step so it can
generate the most efficient code
i would note that all the steps up to
this point did not depend in any way on
the actual machine language of the
system that they were running on this
meant a preprocessor parser code
generator and code optimizer could
literally be written in c and used on
any architecture
the final step is a code generator
that takes the optimized intermediate
code and generates the actual assembly
and machine language for the processor
for fun you can add the minus capital s
parameter to your c compiler and see the
resulting assembly language output for
your system
if you look at the machine language
generated on intel or amd processor
and compare it to the machine language
on an arm processor it will look very
different
because all but the final compiler steps
did not depend on the computer where the
program is being run you could actually
create a c compiler on a new computer
architecture by writing a code generator
on the new computer then running all but
the last step of the compiler on one
computer then copying the internal code
generated by the compiler to the new
compiler and running the code generation
step on the new computer
then you actually have a working c
compiler
on the new computer and the first step
is usually to recompile the c compiler
itself from source code to produce a
fully native c compiler on the new
computer that can compile all the rest
of the c code you have including
possibly the mostly portable elements of
the unix operating system on the new
compiler
yes describing how to cross compile and
bootstrap a c compiler onto a new
computer hardware architecture can give
you a headache if you think about it too
much
but this notion of bootstrapping a c
compiler onto a new architecture was an
important technique to move c and then
unix to a wide range of very different
computer architectures
we see this in action as the unix-like
mac os operating system over the past 20
years was delivered initially on a
motorola 68 000 family processors then
on powerpc processors and then on intel
processors and most recently on
arm-based processors built by apple
using the software portability patterns
that come from c and unix and described
by kernighan and ritchie in this book
apple now makes their own hardware that
can be tuned and evolved over time as
their operating system and their
applications requirements
dictate
the use of a grammar by the way is to
define a programming language is one of
the reasons that syntax errors are so
obtuse
the compiler is not looking at your code
like a human it is following a very set
of simple rules to parse your code and
it's stuck with something
logical and gives you a message like
unexpect
unexpected statement block or constant
on line 17 and the error is nowhere near
line 17.
modern compilers are more sophisticated
of course than the steps above but these
steps give you a sense the compiler does
many things to make it so your code can
actually run
very efficiently
and given that kernighan and richie were
building a programming language c a more
mostly portable operating system written
in c unix and a mostly portable c
compiler written in c
some of their innovative work and
research into compiler design finds it
its way into this book so we have a
section in this chapter called the c
preprocessor
so here we are at the end of chapter
four
and it's a good time to talk about the
word address
up to this point in the book if you
count them the word address has been
used 10 times without a precise
definition beyond the notion that data
is stored in memory and the address of
the data is where the data is stored in
memory
in the next chapter this notion of the
address where the data is stored becomes
very real and tangible as we explore
pointers as well as the ampersand and
asterisk operators
up to now
an experienced javascript php or java
programmer can view c as just another
set of similar syntax rules with a few
quirky runtime bits
but in the next chapter
we will deeply explore the concept of
data allocation and location
it turns out that every programming
language pays a lot of attention to data
allocation and location but the runtime
environments of modern languages work
very hard not to expose you to those
details
just because modern languages hide the
difficult bits from us it does not mean
that those languages solve the problem
using magic
eventually the problem needs to be
solved
and that is why the compiler and
low-level runtime elements of language
like php
javascript and java are usually written
in c
so the builders of those languages can
solve the difficult data storage and
allocation problems
for you
this work
is based on the 1978 c programming book
written by brian w kernighan and dennis
m ritchie
their book is copyright all rights
reserved by at t
but is used in this work under fair use
because of the book's historical and
scholarly significance
its lack of availability and the lack of
an accessible version of the book
the book is augmented in places to help
understand its rightful place in a
historical context amidst the major
changes of the 1970s and 1980s as
computer science evolved from a hardware
first vendor-centered approach to a
software centered approach where
portable operating systems and
applications written in c could run on
any hardware
this is not the ideal book to learn c
programming because the 1978 edition
does not reflect the modern c language
using an obsolete book gives us an
opportunity to take students back in
time and understand how the c language
was evolving as it laid the groundwork
for a future with portable applications
chapter 5 pointers and arrays
before we start chapter 5 a quick note
from your narrator
from time to time i have been adding
some of my interpretation to this book
but i won't be adding anything to this
chapter
i think that sections 5.1 through 5.6
contain some of the most elegantly
written text in the book
the concepts are clearly stated and the
example code is short direct and easy to
understand
pointers are the essential difference
between c and any other modern
programming language
so pay close attention to this chapter
and make sure that you understand it
before continuing
this chapter is as strong now as it was
in 1978
and so without further ado we read and
listen as kernighan and ritchie teach us
about pointers and arrays
a pointer is a variable that contains
the address of another variable
pointers are very much used in c
partly because they are sometimes the
only way to express a computation
and partly because they usually lead to
more compact and efficient code than can
be obtained in other ways
pointers have been lumped with a go-to
statement as a marvelous way to create
impossible to understand programs
this is certainly true when they are
used carelessly and it is easy to create
pointers that point somewhere unexpected
with discipline however pointers can
also be used to achieve clarity and
simplicity
this
is the app aspect that we will try to
illustrate
section 5.1
pointers and addresses
since a pointer contains the address of
an object it is possible to access the
object indirectly through the pointer
suppose that x is a variable say int
and that px is a pointer created in
some as yet unspecified way
the unary operator ampersand gives the
address of an object so the statement
px equals ampersand x semicolon
assigns the address of x to the variable
px
px is now said to point to x
the ampersand operator can be applied
only to variables and array elements
construct like ampersand open paren x 1
close paren and ampersand 3 are illegal
it is also illegal to take the address
of a register variable
the unit the unary operator asterisk
treats its operand as the address of the
ultimate target
and accesses that address to fetch the
contents thus
if y is also an int
y equals star p x semicolon
assigns to y the contents of whatever px
points to
so the sequence
px equals ampersand x semicolon
y equals star px semicolon assigns the
same value to y as does y equals x
it is also necessary to declare the
variables that participate in all of
this
int x comma y semicolon int star px
semicolon the declaration of x and y is
what we have seen all along
the declaration of the pointer px is new
int star px semicolon
is intended as a mnemonic
it says that the combination star px is
an end
that is if px occurs in the context star
px it is equivalent to a variable of
type int
in effect the syntax of the declaration
for a variable
mimics the syntax of expressions in
which the variable might appear
this reasoning is useful in all cases
involving complicated declarations
for example double a to f open
parenthesis close parenthesis comma star
dp semicolon
says that in a particular expression a
to f open friend close friend and star
dp have values of type double
you should also note the implication in
the direction declaration
that a pointer is constrained to point
to a particular kind of objects
pointers can occur in expressions for
example
if px points to the integer x then star
px
can occur in any context where x could
y equal star px plus 1
sets y to 1 more than x
printf open parenthesis double quote
percent d backslash n double quote comma
star px close paren prints the current
value of x
and
d equals square root open paren open
paren double
close paren star p x close paren
produces in d the square root of x which
is coerced into a double before being
passed to square root
in expressions like y equals star px
plus 1 the unary operators
star and ampersand bind more tightly
than arithmetic operators so this
expression takes whatever px points at
adds one and assigns it to y
we will return shortly to what
y equals star open paren px plus one
close paren might mean
pointer references can also occur on the
left side of assignments
if px points to x
then
star px equals zero sets x to zero
and star px plus equals one
increments it as does open paren star px
close paren plus plus
the parentheses are necessary in this
last example without them
the ink expression would increment px
instead of what it points to because
unary operators like star
and plus plus are evaluated right to
left
finally since pointers are variables
they can be manipulated as other
variables can
if py is another pointer to int
then py equals px
copies the contents of px into py
thus making py point to whatever px
points to
section 5.2 pointers and function
arguments
since c passes arguments to functions
by call by value there is no direct way
for the called function
to alter the variable in the calling
function
what do you do if you really have to
change an ordinary argument
for example
a sorting routine might exchange two out
of order elements with a function called
swap
it's not enough to write swap open
parentheses a comma b close parentheses
semicolon where the swap function is
defined as and this is sample source
code on page 91 of the textbook and you
can see it at www.cc4e.com
code
this is a wrong swap by the way this
this is showing you the code that you're
not supposed to do
swap open paren x comma y close paren
int x comma y
semicolon open curly brace
int temp semicolon temp equals x x
equals y semicolon y equals temp
semicolon close curly brace
because of call by value swap can't
affect the arguments a and b in the
routine that called it
fortunately there is a way to obtain the
desired effect
the calling point program passes
pointers to the values to be changed
the call is swap open parentheses
ampersand a comma ampersand b close
parentheses semicolon
since the operator ampersand gives the
address of a variable
ampersand a is a pointer to a
in swap itself the arguments are
declared to be pointers and the actual
operands are accessed through them
so the correct code is on page 92
swap open paren px comma py close paren
int star px comma star py semicolon
open curly brace
int temp semicolon
temp equals star px semicolon
star px equals star py semicolon
star py equals temp semicolon and closed
curly brace
one common use of pointer arguments is
in functions that must return more than
a single value
you might say that swap actually returns
two values the new values of its
arguments
as an example consider a function getint
which performs a free format input
conversion by breaking a stream of
characters into integer values one
integer per call
getint
has to return the value that it found or
an end to file signal when there is no
more input
these values have to be returned as
separate objects for no matter what
value is used for eof that could also
be a value of the integer
one solution which is based on the input
function scanf that we will describe in
chapter seven
is to have get in to return eof as its
function value it finds end of file and
other any other return value singles a
normal integer
the numeric
value of the integer it found is
returned through an argument which then
must be a pointer to an integer
this organization
separates the end of file status from
the returned numeric value
the following loop fills an array with
integers by calls to getint
int
n comma array open print size close
paren semicolon
for n equals zero
n
less than size
double ampersand
get int open paren ampersand v close
print not equal eof semicolon and plus
plus close parentheses
array sub n equals v
each call sets v to the next integer
found in the input
notice that is essential to write
ampersand v instead of v as the argument
to get int
using plane v is likely to cause an
addressing error since getint believes
that it's been handed a valid pointer
getint is an obvious modification to a
to i which we wrote earlier
the sample code is on page 93 of the
textbook and you can see this sample
code at
dot www.cc4e.com slash code
pound include stdio.h
getint open paren pn
close print
int star pn
semicolon
open for open curly brace
int c comma sign
while open print open print c equals get
ch open praying close paren close print
double equals quote space quote
or
c double equals quote backslash n quote
or
c double equals backslash t
quote
close paren semicolon this loop we've
done before and it skips the white space
sine equals one semicolon if open paren
c double equals quote plus quote or
c double equals quote minus quote close
paren open curly brace
equals open parenthesis double equals
quote plus quote close paren question
mark 1 colon -1 semicolon
c equals gut ch
to advance the character
semicolon
and then close curly brace that those
four lines record the sign
now
four
star pn equals zero
c greater than or equal to quote zero
quote and c less than or equal to quote
9 quote
colon
semicolon c equals get ch open paren
close paren close curly brace
star pn equals 10 times star pn plus
c minus quote zero quote
star pn star equals sine
if open paren c not equal to eof close
print on get ch open paren c close paren
semicolon
return c
throughout get int star pn is used as an
ordinary int variable
we have also used getch and ungetch as
described in chapter four
so the one extra character that must be
read can be pushed backed on to the
input section 5.3 pointers and arrays
and see there is a strong relationship
between pointers and arrays
strong enough that pointers and arrays
should really be treated simultaneously
any operation which can be achieved by
array subscripting can also be done with
pointers
the pointer version will in general be
faster
but at least to the uninitiated somewhat
harder to grasp immediately
the declaration int a sub 10
defines an array a of size 10 that is a
block of 10 consecutive objects named a
sub 0
a sub 1
dot dot a sub 9. the notation a sub i
means the element of the array i
positions from the beginning
if
p a
is
a pointer to an integer
declared as int star pa
then the assignment
pa
equals
ampersand a
sub zero
sets pa to 0.2 the zeroth element of a
that is pa contains the address of a sub
zero
now the assignment
x equals star pa will copy the contents
of a sub 0 into x
if pay a points to a particular element
of array a
then by definition pa
points to the next element
nope
if pa points to a particular element of
an array a then by definition pa plus 1
points to the next element
and in general
a minus i points to i elements before p
a and p a plus i
points to i elements after
thus if p a points to a sub zero
star parentheses pa plus 1 closed
parenthesis refers to the contents of a
sub 1.
pa plus i is the address of a sub i
and star print
and star open paren pa plus i
is the contents of a sub i
these remarks are true regardless of the
type of the variables in the array a
the definition of adding one to a
pointer and by extension all pointer
arithmetic
is that the increment is scaled by the
size of the storage of the object that
is pointed to
thus in pa plus i
i is multiplied by the size of the
objects that pa points to before being
added to pa
the correspondence between indexing and
pointer arithmetic is evidently very
close
in fact a reference to an array is
converted by the compiler
to a pointer to the beginning of the
array
the effect is that the array name is a
pointer expression this has quite a few
useful implications
since the name of an array is a synonym
for the location of the zeroth element
the assignment
pa equals
ampersand a sub zero can also be written
as p a
equals a
rather more surprising at least at first
sight is the fact that a reference to a
sub i can also be written as
star open paren a plus i close paren
in evaluating a sub i
c converts it to star open paren a plus
i close paren immediately the two forms
are completely equivalent
applying the operator ampersand to both
parts of this equivalence it follows
that ampersand a sub i and a plus i are
also identical
a plus i is the address of the ith
element beyond a
as on the other side of this coin if p a
is a pointer
expressions may use it with a subscript
p a sub i
is identical to star open paren pa plus
i close print
in short
any array and index expression
can be rewritten as a pointer and an
offset and vice versa even in the same
statement
there is one difference between an array
name and a pointer that must be kept in
mind
a pointer is a variable
so pa equals a
and pa plus plus are sensible operations
but an array name is a constant not a
variable constructions like a equals pa
or a plus plus
or
p equals ampersand a
are illegal
when an array name is passed to a
function
what is passed is the location of the
beginning of the array
within the call function this argument
is a variable just like any other
variable and so an arrayname argument is
truly a pointer that is a variable
containing an address
we can use this fact to write a new
version of stirlin
which computes the length of the string
the sample code is on page 95 of the
book and you can see it in www.cc4e.com
code
page 95.
int stirlin open paren s close prin
char
star s semicolon
open curly brace
int n semicolon
four
open parenthesis n equals zero semicolon
star s not equal quote backslash zero
quote semicolon
s plus plus
close paren
n plus plus
return open print and close paren
semicolon
close curly brace
incrementing s is perfectly legal since
it's a pointer variable
s plus plus has no effect on the
character string in the function that
called sterlin but merely increments the
stir lens private copy of the address
as the formal parameters in a function
definition
char
s open square bracket close square
bracket
semicolon and
char
star s semicolon are exactly equivalent
which one should be written is
determined largely by how expressions
will be written in the function
when an array name is passed to a
function the function can at its
convenience believe that has been handed
either an array or a pointer and
manipulated accordingly
it can even use both kinds of operations
if it seems appropriate
and clear
it is possible to pass part of an array
to a function
by passing a pointer to the beginning of
the subarray
for example if a is an array
f open friend ampersand a sub 2 close
print
and
f open paren a plus 2 close print
both pass to the function f the address
of the element a sub 2
because ampersand a sub 2 and a plus 2
are both pointer expressions that refer
to the third element of a
within f the argument declaration can
read
f open paren
array
close paren int array open bracket close
bracket semicolon
dot dot dot or
f
open paren
array closed paren and star array
semicolon
so far as f is concerned the fact that
the argument
really refers to part of a larger array
is really of no consequence
section 5.4 address arithmetic if p is a
pointer then p plus plus increments p to
point to the next element of whatever
kind of object p points to
and p plus equals i increments p to the
point i elements beyond where it
currently does
these and similar constructions are the
simplest and most common form forms of
pointer or address arithmetic
c is consistent and regular in its
approach to address arithmetic its
integration of pointers arrays and
address arithmetic is one of the major
strengths of the language
let us illustrate some of the properties
by writing a rudimentary storage
allocator but useful in spite of its
simplicity
there are two routines alec open paren
and close paren returns a pointer p to n
consecutive character positions which
can be used by the caller of alec for
storing characters
free open paren p close print releases
the storage thus acquired so it can
later be reused
these routines are rudimentary because
the calls to free must be made in the
opposite order to the calls on alec
that is storage managed by alec and free
is a stack or last in first out
the standard c library provides
analogous functions which have no such
restrictions and in chapter 8 we'll show
how improved versions as well in the
meantime however
many applications really only need a
trivial alec to dispense little pieces
of storage of unpredictable sizes at
unpredictable times
the simplest
implementation is to have alec hand out
pieces of a large character array which
we will call alec buff
this array is private to allocan free
since they deal in pointers and not
array indices no other routine need know
the name of the array which can be
declared as external static that is
local to the source file containing
allocan free and invisible outside it
in practical implementations the array
may well not even have a name it might
be obtained by asking the operating
system for a pointer to some unnamed
block of storage
the other information needed is how much
alec buff has been used we use a pointer
to the next free element called alex cp
when alec is asked for n characters it
checks to see if there is enough room
left in alec buff
if so alec returns the current value of
alec p ie the beginning of the free
block and then increments it by n to
point to the next free area
free p
merely sets alec p to p
if p is inside alec buff
this next code example is on page 97 of
the textbook
you can see the code at www.cc4e.com
code
pound include stdio.h
to find null zero it's a pointer value
for in the error report
pound define alec size 1000 the size of
the available space
static char alec buff open square
bracket alex size close square bracket
semicolon
static chair
char star alec p equals alec buff next
free position initialized to the start
of the array
char
star alec open paren
and close paren return a pointer to n
characters
int n semicolon open curly brace
if alec cp plus n
less than or equal to
alec buff plus alec size close paren
open curly brace
meaning we have space
alex cp plus equals n return
alex cp minus n close parenthesis
semicolon
close curly brace else if there's not
enough room return open paren null close
paren semicolon close curly brace
free open paren p close print this
function will free the storage pointed
to by p
char star p
open curly brace if open paren p greater
than equal to alec buff and
p less than alec buff plus alex size
alex cp equals p
close curly brace
some explanations
in general a pointer can be initialized
just as any other variable can though
normally only meaningful values are null
discussed below or an expression
involving the address of a previously
defined data of the appropriate type
the declaration static char star alex cp
equals alec buff
defines alex cp
to be a character pointer and
initializes it to point to alec buff
which is the next free position when the
program starts
this could also have been written
static char stala star alex cp equals
ampersand alec buff sub-zero semicolon
since the array name is the address of
the zeroth element
whichever is more natural
the test
if open paren alec p
plus n less than or equal to alec buff
plus alex size checks if there's enough
room to satisfy a request for n
characters if there is
the new value of alec p
would be at most one beyond the end of
alec buff if the request can be
satisfied
alec returns a normal pointer notice the
declaration of the function itself
if not alec must return some kind of
signal that there's no space left c
guarantees that no pointer that validly
points to data will ever contain a zero
so a return value of zero can be used to
signal an abnormal event
in this case no space we write null
instead of zero however to indicate more
clearly that this is a special value for
a pointer
in general integers cannot be
meaningfully assigned to pointers but
zero is a special case
tests like if open for n alec p plus n
less than or equal to alec buff plus
alex size and
if open paren p greater than or equal to
alec buff and p less than alec buff plus
alex size shows several important facets
of pointer arithmetic first
pointers may be compared on certain
circumstances
if p and q point to members of the same
array then relations like less than
greater than equal etc work properly
p greater than q is true for example if
p points to an earlier member of the
array than q
the relations double equals and not
equals exclamation equals also work
any pointer can be meaningly compared
for equality or inequality with null
but all bets are off if you do
arithmetic or compu comparisons with
pointers that point to different arrays
if you're lucky you get obvious nonsense
on all machines
if you're unlucky your code will work on
one machine but collapse mysteriously on
another
second we've already observed that a
pointer and an integer can be added or
subtracted the construction p plus n
means the nth object beyond the one p
currently points to this is true
regardless of the kind of object p is
declared to point at the compiler scales
n according to the size of the objects p
points to
which is determined by the declaration
of p
for example on the pdp 11 the factors
are one for char
two for int and short and four for long
float and dub and float and eight for
double
pointer subtraction is also valid
if p and q point to members of the same
array
p minus q is the number of elements
between p and q
this fact can be used to write yet
another version of sterlin
sterling open for n s close paren char
star s semicolon open curly brace
char star p
equals s semicolon while star p not
equal backslash
a single quote backslash zero single
quote close paren p plus plus semicolon
return
open print p minus s close paren
semicolon close curly brace
in its declaration p is initialized s
that is to point to the first character
in the while loop each character in turn
is examined until backslash zero at the
end is seen
since backslash zero is zero and since
while tests only whether the expression
is zero it is possible to omit the
explicit test and such loops are often
written as
while open paren star p close paren p
plus plus semicolon
because p points to characters p plus
plus advances p up to the next character
each time
and p minus f's gives the number of
characters advanced over that is the
string length
pointer arithmetic is consistent if we'd
been dealing with floats which occupying
more storage than chars and if p were a
pointer to a float p plus plus would
advance to the next float
thus we could write another version of
alec which maintains say floats instead
of chars merely by changing char to
float throughout alec and free
all the pointer manipulations
automatically take into the account the
size of the object pointed to so nothing
else has to be altered
other than the operations mentioned here
adding or subtracting a pointer in an
integer subtracting or comparing two
pointers
all other pointer arithmetic is illegal
it is not permitted to add two pointers
or to multiply or divide or shift or
mask them or add float or double to them
section 5.5 character pointers and
functions
a string constant written as double
quote i am a string double quote is an
array of characters in the internal
representation the compiler terminates
the array with the character backslash
zero so programs can find the end
the length in storage is thus one more
than the number of characters between
the double quotes
perhaps the most common occurrence of a
string constant is arguments to
functions as in printf open paren double
quote hello comma world backslash n
double quote
when a character string appears like
this in a program
access to it is through a character
pointer what printf receives is a
pointer to the character array
character arrays of course need not be
function arguments if message is
declared as char star message
then the statement
message equals double quote now is the
time double quote semicolon assigns
message to a pointer to the actual
characters this is not a string copy
only pointers are involved
c does not provide any operators for
processing an entire string of
characters as a unit in the language
we will illustrate more aspects of
pointers and arrays by studying two
useful functions from the standard i o
library to be discussed in chapter 7.
the first function is stir copy open
paren s comma t which copies the string
t to the string s
the arguments are written in this order
by analogy to assignment where one would
say s equals t
to assign t to s
the array version is first
stir copy open paren s comma t close
paren char s open square bracket close
square bracket comma t open square
bracket close square bracket semicolon
open curly brace
int i semicolon
i equals zero semicolon while open paren
open for n s sub i
equals t sub i
close paren not equal quote backslash 0
quote close parenthesis i plus plus
semicolon
close curly brace
you'll note in that while statement that
there is a
copying of the actual characters as an
assignment and then the side effect of
the result of that assignment is
compared to the new line at the end of
string which terminates the while loop
for contrast here is a version of stir
copy with pointers and this is on page
100 of the textbook and you can see all
the code in the textbook at www.cc4e
code and again this is example number
two on page 100.
stir copy open paren s comma t close
paren
char
star s comma star t semicolon open curly
brace while open paren open paren star s
equals star t
close prin not equal single quote
backslash zero single quote close print
open curly brace
s plus plus comma
semicolon t plus plus semicolon close
curly brace
close curly brace to end the function
because the arguments are passed by
value stir copy can use s and t in any
way it pleases here they are
conveniently initialized pointers which
are marched along the arrays a character
at a time
until the backslash terminates
then t has been copied to s
in practice their copy would not be
written as we showed above
a second possibility might be and this
is the third example on page 100 of the
textbook
stir copy open vern s comma t close
paren char star s comma star t semicolon
open curly brace while
paren paren star s plus plus
equals star t plus plus close prin
not equal quote backslash zero quote
close paren
semicolon curly brace
this moves the increment and s and t
into the test part the value of star t
plus plus is the character that t
pointed to before t was incremented
the post fix plus plus doesn't change t
until after this character has been
fetched
in the same way the character is stored
in the old position of s before s is
incremented
the character is also the value that is
compared against backslash zero to
control the loop
the net effect
is that the characters are copied from t
to s up to and including the terminating
backslash zero
as the final abbreviation
of this solving this problem
we can observe that the comparison
against backslash zero is redundant so
the function is often written as and now
this is the first sample code on page
101
of the textbook
stir copy open paren s comma t close
paren char star s comma star t semicolon
open curly brace
while open paren
star s plus plus
equals
star t plus plus closed paren semicolon
curly brace
although this may seem cryptic at first
the notational convenience is
considerable and the idiom should be
mastered
if for no other reason then you will see
it frequently in c programs
the second routine
is stir comp open for n s comma t
which compares the character strings s
and t
and returns
negative zero or positive according to
as s is lexigraphically less than equal
to or greater than t
the value returned is obtained by
subtracting the characters at the first
position
where s and t disagree
this is the second example on page 101
of the textbook
which you can see at www.cc4e.com
code
stir comp open paren s comma t close
parent
char s open square bracket close square
square bracket comma t open square
bracket close square bracket semicolon
open curly brace int i semicolon i
equals zero semicolon
while
s sub i double equals t sub i
close paren open print s sub i plus plus
double equals single quote backslash
zero single quote close paren return
zero return open paren s sub i minus t
sub i
close paren semicolon close curly brace
the pointer version of stir comb
is the first example on page 102 of the
textbook
stir comp open paren s comma t close
paren char star s comma star t
open curly brace
4
open paren
semicolon
star s double equals star t
semicolon s plus plus comma t plus plus
close paren
if open for n star s equal equal single
quote backslash zero single quote close
paren
return open print 0 close paren
return open print star s minus star t
close paren semicolon close curly brace
since plus plus and minus minus are
either prefix or postfix operators the
combination of star and plus plus and
minus minus occur although less
frequently
for example star
plus plus p
increments p before fetching the
character that p points to
star minus minus p decrements p first
section 5.6 pointers are not integers
you may notice in older c programs a
rather cavalier attitude towards copying
pointers
it has generally been true that on most
machines a pointer may be assigned to an
integer and back again without changing
it no scaling or conversion takes place
and no bits are lost
regrettably this has led to the taking
of liberties with routines that return
pointers which are then merely passed to
other routines
the requisite pointer declarations are
often left out for example consider the
function stir save open paren s close
paren which copies the string s into a
safe place obtained by a call to alec
and returns a pointer to it properly
this should be written as
this is the first example on page 103 of
the textbook you can see the sample code
at www.ccfree.com
code
pound include stdlib.h
char star serv stir save open print s
close paren save a string somewhere
char star s semicolon open curly brace
char star p star alec open paren close
paren semicolon if open paren open paren
p equals alec open paren sterling open
paren s close paren plus one close paren
close print not equal null
close paren stir copy open paren p comma
s
close
paren semicolon return open paren p
close paren semicolon curly brace
in practice
there would be a strong tendency
mistaken tendency that is to emit
declarations this is the example 2 on
page 103
pound include stdlib dot h
stir save open paren s close paren
open curly brace char star p semicolon
if parentheses parentheses
p equals alec
open paren sterlin open paren s
close print plus one close print close
print not equal no close paren stir copy
open paren p comma s
close paren semicolon return open paren
p close print semicolon
this will work on many machines since
the default type for functions and
arguments is int
an int and pointer can usually be safely
assigned back and forth
nonetheless
this kind of code is inherently risky
for it depends on the details of the
implementation and machine architecture
which may not hold for the particular
compiler you use
it is wiser to be complete in all
declarations the program lind will warn
of such constructions in case they creep
in inadvertently
section 5.7 multi-dimensional arrays
in general
rectangular multi-dimensional arrays are
used in computational programs like a
weather simulation
and were
a way
back in the day to write c code that
could accept fortran multi-dimensional
arrays as parameters so that
computational or statistical libraries
can be written in c
arrays of pointers are a better mapping
to the typical operating system in
string manipulation use cases that are
more the core of c applications
we also call these ragged arrays because
each row can be a different length
this also works well as data is
dynamically allocated in c as compared
to the more static allocation approach
that's typical in fortran's
multi-dimensional arrays
now to the textbook
c provides for rectangular
multi-dimensional arrays although in
practice they tend to be much less used
than the arrays of pointers in this
section we will show some of their
properties
consider the problem of date conversion
from the day of the month to the day of
the year and vice versa for example
march 1st is the 60th day of a non-leap
year and 60 first day of a leap year
let us define two functions to do the
conversions day of year converts month
and day to the day of the year and month
day converts the day of the year into
the month and the day
since this ladder function returns two
values the month and day arguments will
be pointers
month day open parenthesis 1977 comma 60
ampersand m comma ampersand d close
parentheses
sets m to three and d to one which is
march first
these functions both need the same
information a table of the number of
days in each month 30 days half
september et cetera since the number of
days per month differs for leap years
and non-leap years it's easier to
separate them into two rows of a
two-dimensional array rather than try to
keep track of what happens in february
during computation
the array and the functions performing
the transformations are as follows
this is example
number one on page 104 of the textbook
and you can see the code at www.cc4e.com
code
static int day tab
open paren to close print open paren 13
close print equals
open curly brace
open curly brace
0 comma 31 and then a number of numbers
close curly brace comma open curly brace
0 comma 31 29 and then a bunch of
numbers close curly brace close curly
brace semicolon
day of the year
open paren year come a month come a day
int year come a month comedy semicolon
open curly brace
int i comma leap semicolon
leap
equals 0 year modulo 4 double equals 0
and
year modulo 100 not equal 0 or year
modulo 400 equals equals 0
semicolon for open paren i equals one
i less than month i plus plus close
paren
day plus equals day tab open square
bracket leap close square bracket
open square bracket i close square
bracket semicolon
return open paren day close paren
semicolon close curly brace
then the month day function
month day open paren year come a year
day come a p month come a p day close
paren
int
year come a year day star p month comma
star p day
semicolon
open curly brace int i come a leap
semicolon
leap equals year
percent four double equals zero
and year percent 100 not equal zero or
year percent 1400
double equals zero
for i equals one year day greater than
date tab open square bracket leap close
square bracket open square bracket i
close square bracket semicolon i plus
plus close parenthesis your day minus
equal day tab open square parenthesis
open square bracket leap close square
bracket open square bracket i close
square bracket semicolon star p month
equals i
p day equals year day semicolon close
paren
the array day tab has to be external to
both day of year and month day so they
can both use it
date tab is the first two dimensional
array we've dealt with
in c by definition a two-dimensional
array is really a one-dimensional array
each of which elements is also an array
hence subscripts are written as day tab
open square bracket i close square
bracket open square bracket j close
square bracket
rather than
day tab
open square bracket i comma j close
square bracket as in most languages
other than this a two-dimensional array
can be treated much the same in the same
way as other languages elements are
stored by rows that is the rightmost
subscript varies fastest as elements are
accessed in storage order
an array is initialized by list of
initializers and braces each row of a
two-dimensional array is
initialized by a corresponding sub-list
we started the array day tab with a
column of 0 so that month numbers can
run from the natural 1 to 12 instead of
0 to 11. since space is not a premium
here this is easier than adjusting
indices
if a 2 dimensional array is to be passed
to a function
the argument definition
declaration in the function must include
the column dimension the row dimension
is irrelevant since what is passed in as
before
it is a pointer
this is in this particular case it's a
pointer to objects which are arrays of
13 ins thus the array day tab
if it's to be passed to a function f the
declaration would be
f open friend date tab close paren int
day tab
open square bracket 2 close square
bracket open square bracket 13 close
square bracket semicolon
open curly brace dot dot dot close curly
brace
the argument declaration in f could also
be int date tab
open square bracket close square bracket
open square bracket 13 closed square
bracket semicolon
since the number of rows is actually
irrelevant
it could also be seen as
int open print star day tab close print
open bracket 13 closed bracket
semicolon which says that the argument
is a pointer
to an array of 13 integers
the parentheses are necessary since the
brackets have higher precedence than
asterisk without parentheses the
declaration int star day tab sub 13
close square bracket
semicolon is an array of 13 pointers to
integers as we shall see
in the next section
section 5.8 pointer arrays pointers to
pointers
since pointers are variables themselves
you might expect that there would be
uses for arrays of pointers
this is indeed the case let us
illustrate by writing a program that
will sort
a set of text lines into alphabetic
order than a stripped-down version of
the unix utility sort
in chapter three we presented a shell
sort function that would sort an array
of integers this same algorithm will
work except that now we have to deal
with lines of text which are of
different lengths and which unlike
integers can't be compared or moved in a
single operation
we will need a data representation data
structure that will cope efficiently and
conveniently with variable length text
lines
this is where an
array of pointers enters
if the lines to be sorted are stored and
in one long character array maintained
by alec perhaps then each line can be
accessed by a pointer to its first
character
the pointers themselves can be stored in
an array
two lines can be
compared by passing their pointers to
stir comp
when two out of order lines have to be
swapped or exchanged the pointers in the
pointer array are exchanged not the text
lines themselves
this eliminates the twin problems of
complex storage management and high
overhead that would go with moving the
text of the actual lines
the sorting process involves three steps
read all the lines of input
sort them and then print them in order
as usual it's best to divide the program
into functions that match this natural
division with the main routine
controlling things
let us defer the sorting step for a
moment and concentrate on the data
structures and the input in output
the input routine has to collect and
save the characters in each line and
build an array of pointers to the lines
it will also have to count the number of
input lines since that information is
also needed for sorting and printing
since the input function can only cope
with a finite number of input lines it
can return some illegal line count like
negative 1 if too much input is
presented the output routine only has to
print the lines in order in the order in
which they appear in the array of
pointers
this next code segment
is actually a combination of three
successive sample code segments uh
starting on page 106 of the textbook and
it's pretty complex
so you might be best it might be best
for you to see them on www.cc4e.com
slash code line 106 example one
okay
pound include stdio.h pound includes
string.h pound define lines 100. the
maximum lines of support
to be sorted
main open paren close paren
char
line ptr
open brick ombud square bracket lines
close square bracket semicolon int n
lines which is the number of lines read
if
open paren open paren n lines equals
read lines open paren line ptr comma
lines close praying close paren greater
than or equal to zero
close paren open curly brace sort open
paren line ptr comma n lines close paren
write lines open print line ptr comma n
lines close paren semicolon
close curly brace else
print f
open paren double quote input too big to
sort
backslash n
close double quote
close paren semicolon and close curly
brace to end the main program
this next routine is actually from page
107 of the textbook but we combined them
into one
pound defined maxland1000
readlines openpren line ptr comma max
lines close paren
char star line ptr open square bracket
close for a square bracket semicolon
this is an array of pointers to
characters
an array of pointers pointers being you
know long like four bytes characters
being generally one byte int max line
semicolon open curly brace
int
len comma n lines
semicolon char star p
star alec open print close paren comma
line
open square bracket max lane close
square bracket semicolon
so
just to recall alec is a function we do
we did later i mean did earlier that
allows us to allocate uh
some text of a
varying length and then lines so maxlen
is a place that we're going to
read each line into
beginning the code of read lines
n lines equals zero while open paren
open paren
len equals get line open paren line
comma max len close paren close friend
greater than or equal to zero close
paren
if
open print n lines greater than equal to
max lines close paren return open paren
minus one close paren semicolon
else if
open print open paren p equals alec open
paren len close paren close paren
double equals null
close paren return minus one
so those two tests basically make sure
that we
don't get too many lines and that we
have enough space in our
al dynamic data area that alec is
managing for us
so continuing with the if we're at the
else opens curly brace line sub len
minus one
equals
quote backslash zero quote semicolon
stir copy
p
comma line
close paren semicolon
line ptr sub n lines plus plus equals p
semicolon
close curly brace that finishes the else
segment return n lines semicolon and
close curly brace
to finish the read lines function
now
at a high level we're reading a line
into a
allocated automatic variable line
and then we are
calling alec to get another
cop place to copy that line then we're
making a copy of that line
and then we are remembering the pointer
to the beginning of that line in line
ptr and that's the
essence of it
okay
write lines open paren line ptr comma n
lines close paren char star line ptr
open square bracket close square bracket
semicolon
again
an array of pointer characters
int n lines semicolon
which is the number of character
pointers in line ptr open curly brace
int i semicolon
four paren i equals zero semicolon i
less than n lines semicolon i plus plus
close paren printf open paren
double quote percent s backslash n
double quote comma line ptr sub i close
paren semicolon close curly brace a
simple loop that goes through the array
of character pointers and then prints
each one out using printf
the main new thing is the declaration
for
line ptr char starline ptr sub
open square bracket lines close square
bracket semicolon says that line ptr is
an array of lines elements each element
of which is a pointer to a char
that is line ptr sub i is a character
pointer and star line pr ptr sub i
accesses a character
since line ptr itself is an array that
was passed to right lines it can be
treated as a pointer exactly in the same
manner as our earlier examples and the
function can be written instead as
right lines open paren line ptr comma n
lines close paren
char starline ptr open square bracket
close square bracket semicolon int and
line semicolon open curly brace
while open paren minus minus n lines
greater than or equal to zero close
paren
printf
open paren double quote percent s
backslash n double quote comma star line
ptr plus plus close paren semicolon
that code by the way was on page 108
example one
of the textbook
starline ptr points initially to the
first line but each increment of
line ptr advances it to the next line
while n lines is counted down
with input and output under control
we can proceed to sorting
the shell sort from chapter 3 needs
minor changes
the declarations have to be modified and
the comparison operation must be moved
into a function but the basic algorithm
remains the same which gives us some
confidence that it will still work
and this is the second example on page
108 of the textbook and you can see this
example at www.cc4e.com
code
start sort open paren v comma n close
paren
char star v open square bracket close
square bracket semicolon
and and semicolon open curly brace
so we're getting an array of pointers to
the beginnings of lines
and how many of those pointers matter
and the rest of it is shell sort
with the stir comp being used
to do the string comparison so it's a
three nested for loop
with a simple if test in it
so here we go
open curly brace for the sort function
int gap comma i comma j semicolon char
star
semicolon and that's a pointer to a
character
four open paren gap equals n over two
slash i mean semicolon
gap greater than zero semicolon gap
slash equals two close parenthesis 4
i equals gap semicolon i less than n
semicolon i plus plus close parenthesis
for open paren j equals i minus gap
semicolon j greater than or equal to
zero semicolon
j minus equals gap close paren open
curly brace
so that's sort of the shell part of the
shell sort and now we have to do our
comparison if
open paren stir comp open print
v sub j comma v sub j plus gap
close paren less than or equal to zero
close paren break and note that that's
only breaking the
third deep for loop which it just goes
and then runs the next iteration of the
second for loop
now we do the swapping
temp equals b sub j semicolon v sub j
equals a v sub j plus gap semicolon
v sub j plus gap equals temp now that's
just swapping
pointer values so the the strings that
are pointed to by these two pointers v
sub j and v sub j plus gap
if they're out of order we're going to
swap
the pointers in the array and move them
so that
if you then go through like we did in
write lines earlier
then um they come out in order but we
literally read the data once
we copy it once into the its final
destination using alec alec and stir
copy but once we sort it which is the
most complex part of the calculation
we're only moving the pointers back and
forth so the sort is very efficient and
requires no extra
memory than what we had before the sort
so that's really nice and it sorts in
place
so back to the text since any individual
element of v
which is an alias to line pointer ptr
is a character pointer temp could also
should also be one so one can be copied
to the other
we wrote the program about as
straightforwardly as possible so as to
get it working quickly it might be
faster for instance to copy the incoming
lines directly into an array made by
read lines rather than copying them into
line and then to a hidden place
maintained by alec but it's wiser to
make the first draft of something easy
to understand
and worry about efficiency later
the way to make this program
significantly faster is probably not by
avoiding an unnecessary copy of the
input lines
just instead replacing the shell store
sort by something quicker and better
like quick sort is much more likely to
make a real difference that matters
in chapter one we pointed out that
because while in for loops test the
termination condition before executing
the loop body even once they help to
ensure that the programs will work at
their boundaries in particular with no
input
it's illuminating to walk through the
functions of the sorting program
checking what happens if there is no
input text at all
section 5.9 initialization of pointer
arrays
consider the problem of writing a
function month name open paren and close
paren which returns a pointer to a
character string containing the name of
the mf month
this is an ideal application for an
internal static array
month name contains a private array of
character strings and returns a pointer
to the proper one when called the topic
of this section is how
that array of names is initialized
the syntax is quite similar to the
previous initializations this is sample
code from page 109 of the textbook which
you can see
at
www.cc4e.com code
char
star month name open paren close print
so the return value for this function is
a character pointer
int
n semicolon open curly brace static char
star name open square bracket close
square bracket equals open curly brace
quote
illegal month quote
comma
double quote january double quote comma
double quote february double quote comma
and so forth down to double quote
december double quote
close curly brace semicolon
the body of the
function is one line return open paren
open paren n less than 1 or n greater
than 12 close paren question mark
name sub 0
colon
name sub n
close paren semicolon close curly brace
the declaration of name which is an
array of character pointers is the same
as line ptr in the sorting example
the initializer is simply a list of
character strings
each assigned
to the corresponding position in the
array more precisely the characters of
the i string are placed somewhere else
and a pointer to them
is stored in name sub i
since the name size of the array name is
not specified the compiler itself counts
the initializers and fills in the
correct number
section 5.10 pointers versus
multi-dimensional arrays
newcomers to see are sometimes confused
about the difference between a
two-dimensional array and an array of
pointers such as name in the example
above
given the declarations int
a open square bracket 10 close square
bracket open square bracket 10 close
square bracket semicolon and int star b
open square bracket 10 close square
bracket semicolon
the usage of a and b may be similar
in that a sub 5 5 and b sub 5 5 are both
legal references to a single integer
but a is a true array all 100 storage
cells have been allocated and the
conventional rectangular substrip
calculation is done to find any given
element for b however the declaration
only allocates 10 pointers
each must be set to point to an array of
integers
assuming that each does point to a 10
element array
then there will be 100 storage cells set
aside plus the 10 cells for the pointers
thus the array of pointers uses slightly
more space and may require an explicit
initialization step but it has two
advantages
accessing an element is done by
indirection through a pointer rather
than by a multiplication and an addition
and the rows of the array may be of
different lengths that is each element
of b need not point to a 10 element
vector some may point to two elements
others may point to 20 and some to none
at all
although we have phrased this discussion
in terms of integers by far the most
frequent use of arrays of pointers is
like that shown in month name to store
character strings of a diverse lengths
section
5.11
command line arguments
in environments that support c there is
a way to pass command line arguments or
parameters to a program when it begins
executing
when main is called to begin execution
it is called with two arguments
the first conventionally called arg c is
the number of command line arguments the
program was invoked with the second arg
v is a pointer to an array of character
strings that contain the arguments one
per string
manipulating these character strings is
a common use of multiple levels of
pointers
i would note that back in 1978 the two
largest bodies of c code were likely the
at t unix kernel itself and unix
utilities like grep
ls or the login shell
so writing an operating system was fresh
on the mind of the authors while writing
this book
these topics find their way into the
text of this book
in a sense a likely second order goal of
the book was to train programmers that
might learn c
and then might help build and maintain
unix
the 1978 edition of this textbook fits
nicely into a series of att bell labs
technic reports like the portability of
c programs in the unix system written by
stephen c johnson and dennis m ritchie
published in the bell system technical
journal volume 57 number six part two
july through august 1978 pages
2021 through 2048.
you can see this one online if you
search for it
back to the
textbook the simplest illustration of
the necessary declarations
and use is in the program echo which
simply echoes its command line arguments
in a single line separated by blanks
that is if the command echo hello comma
world is given the output is hello comma
world
by convention arg v sub 0 is the name by
which the program was invoked so argc is
at least 1.
in the above example argc is three and
args arc v sub zero arc v sub one and
args v sub two are echo
hello comma and world respectively
the first real argument is arc v sub 1
and the last is
arg v
sub rxc minus 1
and if argc is 1 there are no command
line arguments after the program name
this is shown in the source code to echo
and this source code is on page 111 of
the textbook and you can see this source
code at www.cc4e.com
code
pound include stdio.h
pound includes string.h
main open paren argc comma arc fee close
paren int argc semicolon char star argv
open square bracket close square bracket
semicolon
open curly brace int i semicolon
for open paren i equals one semicolon i
less than rxc semicolon i plus plus
close paren
print f open paren
double quote percent s percent c
double quote comma
arg v sub i
comma
open paren i less than r c minus one
close paren question mark
single quote space single quote colon
single quotes
backslash n single quote close
parenthesis
semicolon close curly brace to end it
since argv is a pointer to an array of
pointers there are several ways to write
this program that involve manipulating
the pointer rather than indexing an
array
let us show two variations and this is
the example
number two on page 111 of the textbook
pawn include stdio.h pawn includes
string.h
main open paren rxc comma argv close
paren
int argc semicolon char star argv open
square bracket close square bracket
semicolon
open curly brace
while open paren minus minus arg c
greater than zero close paren printf
open paren double quote percent s
percent c
double quote comma star
plus plus arg v comma open paren rxc
greater than one close paren question
mark single quote space single quote
colon single quote backslash n single
quote close paren semicolon
close curly brace
since
arc v is a pointer to the beginning of
an array of argument strings
incrementing it by one plus plus rv
makes it point to the at the original
array arc v sub one instead of arc b sub
zero
each successive increment moves it along
to the next argument
star arc v is then the pointer to that
argument
at the same time argc is decremented and
when it becomes zero there are no
arguments left to print
another version the third version on
page 111 of the textbook
pound include stdio.h pound includes
string.h main open paren arg c com argv
close paren
int argc semicolon char star arc v open
square bracket close square bracket
semicolon open curly brace while
open paren minus minus arg c greater
than zero close paren
print f open paren open paren argc
greater than one close paren question
mark double quote percent s blank double
quote colon
double quote percent s backslash n
double quote comma
star plus plus arg v close paren
semicolon close curly brace
this
version so shows that the format
argument of printf can be an expression
just like any of the others this usage
is not very frequent but worth
remembering
as a second example
let's make some example enhancements to
the pattern finding program from chapter
4.
if you recall we wired the search
pattern deep into the program
and this is an obviously unsatisfactory
arrangement for flexible code following
the lead of the unix utility grep which
stands for the generalized regular
expression parser
let us change the program so that the
pattern to be matched is specified by
the first argument on the command line
this is example one on page 112 of the
book which you can see at www.cc4e.com
code
pound include sddio.h
pound includes string.h upon define max
line 1000
main open paren arg c comma arg v close
paren int r c semicolon char star arc v
open square bracket close square bracket
semicolon open curly brace
char line open open square bracket max
line close square bracket semicolon
if open paren argc not equal to close
paren printf
double quote usage colon find pattern
backslash n
double quote close paren semicolon else
while open pren getline open print line
comma max line close paren greater than
zero close paren
if
index open paren line comma arg v
sub 1 close paren greater than or equal
to 0 close paren printf
open paren double quote percent s double
quote comma line close paren semicolon
close curly brace
the basic model can now be elaborated to
illustrate further pointer constructions
suppose we want to allow two optional
arguments
one says print all the lines except
those that match the pattern
the second says precede its print each
printed line with its line number
a common convention for c programs is
that an argument beginning with a minus
sign introduces an optional flag or
parameter
if we choose minus x for accept to
signal the inversion and minus n number
to request line numbering then the
command find space minus x space minus n
the with the input now is the time for
all good men to come to the aid of their
party should produce
two comma for all good men
optional arguments should be permitted
in any order and the rest of the program
should be insensitive to the number of
arguments which were actually present
in particular the call to index should
not refer to arg v sub 2 where a single
flag argument and to arc v sub 1 when
there was no single flag furthermore
it's convenient for users if option
arguments can be concatenated and as in
find space dash nx space the
here is the program
and this program is on
page 113 of the textbook
and it is complex enough that i suggest
that you take a look at it at
www.cc4e.com
code
it's it's about 35 lines long
the commentary on the program hopefully
now you're watching looking at it arc v
is incremented before each optional
argument and argc is decremented if
there are no errors at the end of the
loop arg c should be 1 and star argv
should point to the
point to the pattern
note that
star plus plus arc v is a pointer to an
argument string
open paren star plus plus arc v close
paren
open square bracket zero square square
bracket
is its first character the parentheses
are necessary for without them the
expression would be star plus plus open
paren arg v sub subzero
close paren which is quite different and
wrong
an alternate valid form would be star
star
plus plus arg v
section 5.12 pointers to functions in c
a function itself is not a variable but
it is possible to define a pointer to a
function which can be manipulated passed
to functions placed in arrays and so on
we will illustrate this by modifying the
sorting procedure written earlier in
this chapter so that if the optional
argument minus n is given it will sort
the input lines numerically instead of
lexographically
a sort often consists of three parts a
comparison
which determines the ordering of any
pair of objects
an exchange which reverses their order
and a sorting algorithm which makes
comparisons and exchanges until the
objects are in order
the sorting algorithm is independent of
the comparison and exchange operations
so by passing different comparison and
exchange functions to it we can arrange
to sort by different criteria this
approach is taken in our new sort
the lexigraphic comparison of the two
lines is done by stir comp and swapping
by swap as before
we'll also need a routine num comp which
compares two lines on the basis of
numeric value and returns the same kind
of condition indication as stir comp
does
these three functions are declared in
main and pointers to them are passed to
sort
sort in turn calls the functions via
pointers we have skimped on error
processing processing for arguments so
as to concentrate on the main issues
this sample code is from page 115 of the
textbook which you can view at
www.cc4e.com
code
pound include stdio.h
pawn include string.h pawn defined lines
100
main open paren rxc comma arg v close
current
int argc semicolon
char star arg fee open square bracket
close square bracket semicolon open
curly brace
char star line ptr open for open bracket
lines close square bracket semicolon
this is the pointers to the text lines
so we're going to be reading
in the lines saving them and keeping an
array of the pointer and then we're
going to sort that way
int n lines semicolon
int stir comp open paren close print
comma num comp
open paren close paren which are
comparison functions
and swap open paren close print
semicolon int numeric equals zero and
this is going to be one if it's a
numeric sort
first we parse the arguments
if open paren arg c greater than one
ampersand ampersand arg v sub one sub
zero equal equal
quote minus quote
and arg v opens bracket one close
bracket open bracket one close bracket
double equals quote end quote close
paren numeric equals one
if open paren open paren n lines equals
read lines open paren line ptr comma
lines close paren close paren greater
than or equal to zero close paren open
curly brace
if open paren numeric close paren sort
open print line ptr n lines num comp
comma swap close paren semicolon else
sort open print line ptr
comma n lines
comma stir comp comma swap close paren
write lines line pr ptr comma n lines
close paren
close curly brace else print f open
paren double quote input too big to sort
backslash n
double quote close paren semicolon
stir comp num comp and swap are
addresses of functions
since they're known to be functions the
ampersand operator is not necessary in
the same way that it is not needed
before an array name
the compiler arranges for the address of
the function to be passed
the second step is to modify our sort
function
and this is the first example on page
116 of the textbook
sort open paren v comma n comma comp
comma e x c h exchange
close paren
char
star v open square bracket close work
square bracket
semicolon that's our pointer
array of pointers
int
and semicolon
int open friends start comp
close paren open print close paren comma
open paren star exchange
close paren open prayer and close paren
semicolon that declared the
type and the fact that these are
pointers to functions it's a little more
complex here in the called code
open curly brace int gap comma i comma j
semicolon
and now we're going to do the three
nested for loops for the
quick sort no shell sort
um
and then the only really change is in
the code checking to see if the
uh two items pair of items are out of
order and then what we do so
four open paren gap equals n over two
semicolon cap greater than zero
semicolon graph gap slash equals two
close paren
for open print i equals gap semicolon i
less than n semicolon i plus plus closed
paren
four open paren j equals i minus gap
semicolon j greater than or equal to
zero semicolon j minus equals gap close
paren open curly brace and now here
starts the different code
if open print open print star comp
close print
open paren v sub j comma v sub j plus
gap
close paren less than or equal to zero
close paren break
open print star ex exchange
close prin open print ampersand v sub j
comma ampersand v sub j plus gap
close paren semicolon close curly brace
for the for loop and then close curly
brace
for the sort function
and so really all we're doing is we're
checking the order of the two items b
sub j and b sub j plus gap
and if they're out of order i.e less
than or equal to zero i mean greater
than or equal to uh greater than zero
then we just exchange them with the
provided exchange function and so the
key thing here is it looks exactly like
the previous time we wrote this code
except we're calling
the pointer to the comparison function
and the pointer to the exchange function
which
is makes this flexible
so it can handle different kinds of data
back to the textbook
the declaration should be studied with
some care
int open paren star comp close paren
open paren close paren says that comp
is a pointer to a function that returns
an int
the first set of parentheses are
necessary without them int star comp
open prank close paren
would say that comp is a function
returning a pointer to an end which is a
quite different thing
the use of comp in the line if open
paren open paren star com close paren
open print v
sub j comma v sub j plus gap close print
less than or equal to zero close paren
is consistent with the declaration
comp is a pointer to the function and
star comp is the function
and
open paren star comp close paren
open paren v sub j comma v sub j plus
gap close
paren is the call to it the parentheses
are needed so the components are
correctly associated
we've only we've already shown stir comp
which compares two strings
here is num comp which compares two
strings on a leading numeric value
this is sample code from page 117 of the
textbook
which you can
see at www.cc4e.com
code
numcomp open paren s1 comma s2 close
paren char star s1 comma star s2
semicolon
open curly brace double a to f open
frame close paren comma v1 comma v2
v1 equals a to f open paren s1 close
paren
semicolon v2 equals a to f open print s2
close paren semicolon if
open paren v1 less than v2 close print
return open print -1
else if open print v1 greater than v2
close paren return open print 1 close
paren semicolon else
return open paren
0 close paren semicolon close curly
price
the final step is to add the function
swap which exchanges the two pointers
this is adapted directly from what we
presented earlier in the chapter
swap open paren px comma py close paren
char star px
open square bracket close square bracket
comma star py open square bracket close
square bracket semicolon
open curly brace char star temp
semicolon
temp equals star px semicolon star px
equals star py semicolon star py equals
temp semicolon close curly brace
there are a variety of other options
that can be added to the sorting program
some make challenging exercises
[Music]
this work
is based on the 1978 c programming book
written by brian w kernighan and dennis
m ritchie
their book is copyright all rights
reserved by at t
but is used in this work under fair use
because of the book's historical and
scholarly significance
its lack of availability and the lack of
an accessible version of the book
the book is augmented in places to help
understand its rightful place in a
historical context amidst the major
changes of the 1970s and 1980s as
computer science evolved from a
hardware-first vendor-centered approach
to a software-centered approach where
portable operating systems and
applications written in c could run on
any hardware
this is not the ideal book to learn c
programming because the 1978 edition
does not reflect the modern c language
using an obsolete book gives us an
opportunity to take students back in
time and understand how the c language
was evolving as it laid the groundwork
for a future with portable applications
chapter 6 structures
a structure is a collection of one or
more variables possibly of different
types grouped together under a single
name for convenient handling
while we talk about data structures and
how to use them in every language
this section is about understanding how
software developers carefully control
the low level shape of their data items
to solve their problems
when you first learn about the c struct
keyword you might think it's equivalent
to a python dict
a dynamic key value store like a php
array java myapp or javascript object
but nothing is further from the truth
these other languages provide us with
easy to use data structures where all
the challenging problems are solved
this chapter tells or told the creators
of python php java and javascript how to
solve the complex problems and build
convenient and flexible data structures
which we now all use in those
object-oriented languages
one way to look at this code in this
chapter is to think of it as a lesson on
how one might build python's list and
dict data structures
if the code in the chapter takes you a
little while to figure out
mentally make a note of thanks for all
the hard work that modern languages
invest to make their high level data
structures flexible and easy to use
back to the textbook
the traditional example
of a structure is a payroll record an
employee is described as a set of
attributes such as name address social
security number salary etc
some of these in turn could be
structures a name has several components
as does an address and even a salary
structures help organize complicated
data particularly in large programs
because in many situations they permit a
group of related variables to be treated
as a unit
instead of separate entities in this
chapter we'll try to illustrate how
structures are used
the programs that we will use are bigger
than many others in the book but are
still of modest size section 6.1 basics
let us revisit the date conversion
routines of chapter 5.
a date consists of several parts such as
the day month and year and perhaps the
day of the year and the month name
these five variables can all be placed
in a single structure like this
struct
date open curly brace
in day semicolon in month semicolon in
int year semicolon and year day
semicolon char
mun name
open square bracket for closed square
bracket semicolon curly brace semicolon
the keyword struct introduces a
structure declaration which is a list of
declarations
enclosed embraces an optional name
called the structure tag may follow the
word struct as with date here the tag
names this kind of a structure and can
subsequently be used as shorthand for
the detailed declaration
the elements or variables mentioned in a
structure are called its members
a structure member or tag and ordinary
ie non-member variable can have the same
name without conflict since they are
always distinguished by context
of course as a matter of style one would
normally use the same names only for
closely related objects
the right brace that terminates the list
of members may be followed by a list of
variables just as for any basic type
that is struct open curly brace dot dot
dot close curly brace
x comma y comma z semicolon
is syntactically analogous to int
x comma y comma z semicolon in the sense
that each statement declares x y and z
to be variables of the named type and
causes space to be allocated for them
a structured declaration that is not
followed by a list of variables
allocates no storage it merely describes
a template or the shape of the structure
if the declaration is tagged however the
tag can be used in later definitions of
the actual instances of the structure
for example given the declaration of
date above
struct date d
defines a variable d which is a
structure of type
date an external or static structure can
be initialized by the following by
following its definition with a list of
initializers for the components
struct date d
equals open curly brace 14 comma 7 comma
1776 comma 186 comma double quote j u l
double quote close curly brace semicolon
a member of a particular structure
is referred to in an expression by
construction of the form structure name
dot member
the structure member operator dot
connects the structure name in the
member name to set leap from the date in
structure d for example
leap equals d dot year modulo four
double equals zero
and d dot year modulo 100 not equal to
zero or d dot year modulo 400
double equal zero semicolon
or to check the month name
if open paren stir comp
open paren d dot mun name comma
double quote aug double quote close
paren double equals zero
close paren dot dot
or to convert the first character of the
month named lower case
d dot mon name sub zero equals lower
open paren d dot name sub zero close
paren semicolon
structures may be nested a payroll
record might actually look like struct
person open curly brace char name open
square bracket name size close square
bracket semicolon char address open
square bracket adder size
close square bracket semicolon long zip
code semicolon
long ss number semicolon double salary
struct date birth date semicolon struct
date hire date
semicolon close curly brace semicolon
the person structure contains two dates
if we declare emp as struct person amp
semicolon then emp.birthdate.month
refers to the month of birth
the structure member operator
dot associates left to right
section 6.2 structures and functions
there are a number of restrictions on c
structures the essential rules are that
only operations you can perform on a
structure are to take its address with
ampersand and access one of its members
this implies that structures may not be
assigned or copied to as a unit and that
they cannot be passed or returned
from functions
these restrictions will be removed in
forthcoming versions furnace
destructures do not suffer these
limitations however so structures and
functions do work together comfortably
finally automatic structures like
automatic arrays cannot be initialized
only external or static structures can
this prediction was indeed accurate
modern c compilers do support the
copying of a structure with a single
assignment statement given that a c
structure is just a fixed length block
of memory it's easy easy to generate
machine code to copy it a key bit to
remember that when the c structure is
copied it is done as a shallow copy
a shallow copy copies the values of the
variables and the pointers in the
structure but does not make copies of
any data which the pointers point to
a structure that contains other
structures i.e not pointers to
structures and those structures are
shallow copied as well
back to the text
let us investigate some of these points
by rewriting the date conversion
functions in the last chapter to use
structures since the rules prohibit
passing of a structure to a function
directly we must either pass the
component separately or pass a pointer
to the whole thing
the first
alternative uses of de avere which as we
wrote in chapter 5
d year day equals
day of year open for n d year comma d
dot month comma d dot day close paren
semicolon
the other way is to pass a pointer if
we've declared higher date as struct
date higher date semicolon and rewritten
day of year we could then say
higherdate.year day equals day of year
open paren ampersand higher date close
paren semicolon
to pass a pointer to higher date to day
of year the function has to be modified
because its argument is now a pointer
rather than a list of variables
this example code is on page 122 of the
textbook and you can see it at
www.cc4e.com
code
struct date open curly brace
int day semicolon int month semicolon
in
ear semicolon int year day semicolon and
mun name open square bracket four close
spread square bracket
semicolon closed curly brace semicolon
static int day tab
open square bracket two close square
bracket open square bracket 13 close
square bracket equals open curly brace
open curly brace zero come at 31 come at
28 come a 31 come a 30 come at 31 come
with 30 come a 31
31 come a 30
come a 31 come a 30 31 close curly brace
comma and then another list just as long
as that co with a closed curly brace and
a semicolon that just initialized the
lookup table for the days in each month
now on to the function
day of year open paren pd close paren
struct date star pd semicolon open curly
brace
and i come a day come a leap semicolon
day
equals pd
minus
greater than day semicolon
leap equals pd minus greater than year
percent for double equals zero
and
pd
minus greater than year percent 100 not
equal to zero
or
pd
minus greater than year percent 400
double equal zero semicolon
four open paren i equals one semicolon i
less than pd
minus greater than month semicolon i
plus plus close paren
day plus equals day tab
open square bracket leap close square
bracket open square bracket i close
square bracket semicolon
return open paren day close paren
semicolon close curly brace
the
declaration struct date star pd says
that pd is a pointer to a structure of
type date
the notion exemplified by pd
minus
greater than year
i think i'll call that at this point pd
right arrow because that's really what
it is it's the minus greater than looks
like an arrow to the right so i'm going
to call it right arrow but it's really
two characters
pd right arrow year is new
if p is a pointer to a structure then pd
right arrow member of structure refers
to the particular
member the operator right arrow is a
minus sign followed by a greater than
since pd points to the structure the
year member could also be referenced as
open paren star pd closed paren dot ear
but pointers to structures are so
frequently used that the right arrow
notation is provided both
as a convenient shorthand the
parentheses are necessary in open paren
star pd close paren dot ear because the
precedence of the structure member
operator dot is higher than
the pointer lookup operator asterisk
both right arrow and dot associate to
left from left to right so
p right arrow q right arrow mem
and
emp dot birthdate dot month r open paren
p right arrow q close paren right arrow
mem and open parent emp dot birth date
close paren dot month
for completeness here is the other
function month day rewritten to use the
structure
this is the first example on page 123 of
the text which you can look at the
source code at www.cc4e.com
code
i won't read the struct and the date the
destruct date definition in the struct
in
static in day tab definition we'll just
go month day
month day open paren pd close paren
struct date star pd semicolon
open curly brace
end i comma leap
semicolon
leap equals pd right arrow year
percent four double equals zero and pd
right arrow year percent 100 not equal
to zero or pd right arrow year
percent 400 double equals 0 semicolon
pd right arrow day equals pd right arrow
year day
four open print i equals one semicolon
pd right arrow day greater than day tab
subleap sub i semicolon
i plus plus close paren
pd right arrow day minus equals
day tab subleap sub i semicolon
pd right arrow month equals i semicolon
close curly brace
the structure operators
right arrow and dot together with
parentheses for argument lists and
square brackets for subscripts are the
top of the precedence hierarchy and then
thus bind very tightly
for example given the declaration struct
open curly brace
int x int star y
semicolon close
curly brace star p semicolon then
plus plus p right arrow x increments x
not p
because the implied parenthesization is
plus plus open paren p right arrow x
close paren
parentheses can be used after the
binding
open paren plus plus p
right arrow x increments p before
accessing x and open paren p plus plus
close paren right arrow x increments p
afterward
the last set of parentheses is
unnecessary
in the same way star p right arrow y
fetches whatever y points to star
p right arrow y plus plus increments y
after what
after accessing whatever it points to
just like star s plus plus
open paren star p
right arrow y
close paren plus plus increments
whatever y points to and star p
plus plus right arrow y
increments p after accessing whatever y
points to
section 6.3 arrays of structures
structures are especially suitable for
managing arrays of related variables
for instance consider a program to count
the occurrences of each c keyword
we need an array of character strings to
hold the names and an array of integers
to hold the counts
one possibility is to use two parallel
arrays keyword and key count as in
char star keyword open square bracket n
keys close square bracket semicolon
int key count open square bracket n keys
close square bracket semicolon but the
very fact that the arrays are parallel
indicates a different organization is
possible
each keyword entry is really a pair
char star keyword semicolon
int key count semicolon and there's an
array of the pairs
the structure declaration struct key
open curly brace char star keyword
semicolon int key count semicolon close
curly brace key tab open square bracket
n keys close square bracket semicolon
defines an array key tab of structures
of this type and allocate storage to
them each element of the array is a
structure this could also be written
struct key open curly brace char star
keyword semicolon int key count
semicolon
close curly brace semicolon
struct key key tab open square bracket
and keys close square bracket semicolon
since the structure key tab actually
contains a constant set of names it's
easiest to initialize it once and for
all when it's defined
the structural initialization is quite
analogous to the earlier ones the
definition is followed by a list of
initializers and closed embraces
struct key open curly brace char star
keyword semicolon int key count
semicolon close curly brace
key tab open square bracket close square
bracket equals open curly brace
double quote break comma 0 comma double
quote case comma 0 comma double quote
char comma 0 comma
and so forth
down to double quote unsigned double
quote comma 0 comma double quote while
double quote comma 0
closed curly brace semicolon
these
initializers are listed in pairs
corresponding to the structure members
it would be more precise to enclose
initializers for each row or structure
in the braces as in
open curly brace double quote break
double quote comma zero close curly
brace comma open curly brace double
quote case double quote comma zero
close curly brace comma and so forth
but the inner braces are not necessarily
when the initializers are simple
variables or character strings and when
all are present
as usual the compiler will compute the
number of entries in the array key tab
if the initializer is present and the
open square bracket close square bracket
is left
empty the keyword counting program which
begins with a definition of key tab the
main routine reads the input repeatedly
by calling a function get word that
fetches input one word at a time each
word is looked up in key tab
with a version of binary the binary
search function we wrote in chapter
three
of course the list of keywords has to be
given in increasing order for this to
work
here is the first example on page 125 of
the textbook
you can see this
at www.cc4e.com
code
pound include stdio.h
pound define max word 20
pound defined letter quote a quote
main open prem close paren open curly
brace
int n comma t semicolon
char word open square bracket max word
close square bracket semicolon
while open paren open print t equals get
word open paren word comma max word
close paren close paren not equal eof
close paren
if open friend t double equal letter
close paren
if double
open paren open paren n equals
binary open paren word come a key tab
comma n keys close paren close paren
greater than or equal to zero
close paren
key tab sub n dot key count plus plus
four open paren n equals zero semicolon
and less than n keys semicolon and plus
plus
if open open paren key tab sub n dot key
count greater than zero close paren
print f
double quote percent for d space percent
s backslash n double quote comma
key tab sub n dot key count comma key
tab sub n dot keyword close paren
semicolon and then a closed curly brace
to finish main
binary
to find the word in the in the table
binary open paren word comma tab comma n
close paren
char star word
semicolon struct key tab open square
bracket close work square bracket
semicolon
int n
open curly brace
int low comma high comma mid comma cond
low equals zero semicolon high equals n
minus one semicolon
while open paren low less than or equal
to high close paren open curly brace
mid equals paren low plus high close
paren over to
semicolon
if
open paren open paren conned equals stir
comp open paren word
comma tab comma open square bracket mid
close square bracket dot keyword close
print close friend less than zero close
paren hi
equals mid minus one semicolon else if
open paren con
greater than zero close paren low equals
mid plus one semicolon else
return open paren mid close paren
semicolon
close curly brace to finish the while
and then return open paren minus one
close paren semicolon
close curly brace and that's really a
rewrite of the binary function
from the earlier part where we're just
taking the keyword and count and
and look in and looking up in the array
but then using the dot keyword to find
the actual keyword
back to the text we'll show function get
word in a moment for now it suffices to
say it returns letter each time it finds
a word and copies the word into its
first argument
the quantity n keys is the number of
keywords in key tab although we could
count this by hand it's a lot easier and
safer to do it by machine especially if
the list is subject to change
one possibility would be to terminate
the list of initializers with a null
pointer and then the loop along key tab
just runs until the end is found
but this is more than as needed since
the size of the array is completely
determined at compile time the number of
entries is just the size of key tab
divided by the size of the struct key
c provides a compile time op unary
operator called sizeof which can be used
to compute the size of any object
the expression size of open paren object
close paren yields an integer equal to
the size of the specified object
the size is given in unspecified units
called bytes which are the same size as
a char closed paren
the object can be an actual variable or
an array or structure or the name of a
basic type like int or double or the
name of a derived type like a structure
in our case the number of keywords is
the array size
divided by the size of one array element
and this computation is used in a pound
define statement to set the value of n
keys
pound define n keys
open paren size of open or print key tab
close print
divided by size of open paren struct key
close paren close paren
now for the function get word we have
actually written a more general get word
than is necessary for this program
but it is not really much more
complicated
get word returns the next word from the
input where a word is either a string or
of letters or digits beginning with a
letter or a single character the type of
the object that is is the returned
function as a function value
it is the letter if the token is a word
eof render file or the character itself
if it's non-alphabetic
this sample code is on page 127 of the
textbook which you can see at
www.cc4e.com
code
pound define letter quote a quote pound
defined digit quote zero quote
get word open paren w comma limb close
paren
char
star w
colon semicolon
int lim semicolon open curly brace int c
comma t semicolon
if open paren type open paren c equals
star w plus plus equals get ch open
paren close paren close paren not equal
letter close print open curly brace
start w
equals quote backslash zero quote
semicolon
return open for nc close paren semicolon
close curly brace
that if statement has got some stuff
going on in it you might want to look at
it very closely
while open paren minus minus limb
greater than zero close paren open curly
brace
t
equals type open friend c
equals star w
plus plus equals get ch open paren close
paren
close point semicolon
if if open friend t not equal letter and
t not equal digit close paren
open curly brace unget ch open paren c
close paren semicolon
break semicolon close curly brace star
open paren w minus one close paren
equals quote backslash zero quote
semicolon
return open paren letter close paren
semicolon
close curly brace close curly brace
that that example code
has a lot of stuff about pointers and
incrementing pointers and dereferencing
pointers etc so take a good look at that
code
back to the text
get word uses the routines get ch and
unget ch which we wrote in chapter 4.
when the collection of alphabetic of an
alphabetic token stops get word has gone
one character too far that call to unget
ch pushes that character back on the
input for the next call
getword calls another function called
type to determine the type of each
individual character for input
here is a version that's only for ascii
this code is the second example on page
127 of the textbook at www.cc4e.com
code
type open paren c close paren in c
semicolon
yeah open curly brace if
open paren c greater than or equal to
quote a quote and c less than or equal
to quote z quote or
c greater than or equal to quote
uppercase a quote and c less than or
equal to
quote uppercase z quote close paren
return
letter semicolon
else if open paren c greater than or
equal to quote zero quote and c less
than or equal to quote nine quote close
paren return open friend digit close
paren semicolon
else
return open paren c close paren
semicolon
close curly brace
the symbolic constants letter and digits
can have any values that do not conflict
with
non-alphanumeric values and eof the
obvious choices are
quote a quote and quote zero quote
get word can be faster if calls to the
function type are replaced by references
to the appropriate array type the
standard c library provides macros like
is alpha and is digit which operate in
this manner
section 6.4 pointers to structures
to illustrate some of the considerations
involved with pointers and arrays of
structures let us write a keyword
counting program again
this time using pointers instead of
array indices
as an aside i would note that it's a
classic early assignment in any
programming language to do a word
frequency program here is a python
program from my python for everybody
course to count words from an input
stream
handle
equals open
open parenthesis single quote romeo dot
txt close single quote comma quote r
quote close parenthesis
words equals handle dot read open print
close print dot split open friend close
paren
counts equals dict open paren close
paren
four word in words colon
counts subword equals
get open paren word comma zero close
paren plus one print open parent counts
close paren
this section in this book implements a
less general word counting program in c
the code depends on several functions
from earlier in the book and the code
below is pretty complex where the
programmer only has access to low-level
language without powerful and
easy-to-use data types like python's
list or dict
it is likely that keto van rossen read
this book took a long look at this code
and designed the dick data structure in
python so the rest of us can write a
data parsing and word frequency
programming program in the above six
lines of code without worrying about
dynamic memory allocation pointer
management string length and a myriad of
other details that must be solved when
you're solving this program in c
since python is open source you can
actually look at the c code that
implements the dict object in a file
called dict object dot c
it is almost 6 000 lines of code and
includes other files or utility code
there thankfully we only have to write
one line of python to use it counts
equals dict open friend close paren
we will leave the complex bits to the c
programmers that build and maintain
this section is not showing us how to
use the python dict object
rather it is showing how one would build
a dick like structure using c
so
continuing with section 6.4 pointers to
structures
the external definition of key tab do
not need to change but main and binary
do need modification this is
example on page 129 of the textbook
and that is available at www.cc4e.com
code
pointer version of counting c keywords
main open paren close paren open curly
brace int t semicolon
char word open square bracket max word
close square bracket semicolon struct
key star binary open paren close paren
comma star p semicolon
while open paren open paren t equals get
word open paren word comma max word
close paren close paren
not equal e o f close paren
if open print t equal equal letter close
paren
if open paren open paren b equals binary
open paren word comma key tab comma n
keys close paren close paren not equal
null close paren
p right arrow key count plus plus
for p equals key tab p less than key tab
plus n keys semicolon p plus plus close
parenthesis
if open paren p right arrow key count
greater than zero
close paren printf
open paren
double quote percent for d space percent
s backslash n
double quote comma
p right arrow key count comma p right
arrow keyword
and now we look at the binary search
struct key star binary open paren word
come tab comma n close paren
char star word struct key tab open
square bracket close square bracket
semicolon
int n
open curly brace
int cond semicolon
struct key star low equals ampersand tab
sub zero
semicolon struct key star high equals
ampersand tab sub n minus one semicolon
struct key equals mid
while open paren low less than or equal
to high close paren open curly brace
mid equals low plus high minus low
divided by 2.
if open paren open for n cond
equals stir comp word comma mid
right arrow keyword close print close
paren
less than zero close paren
hi
equals mid minus one semicolon else if
close print con greater than zero close
paren
low equals mid plus one semicolon
else return open paren mid close print
semicolon
close curly brace to finish the while
and then return open paren null close
paren
close curly brace
there are several things worthy of note
here first the declaration of binary
must indicate that it returns a pointer
to the structure type key instead of an
integer this is declared both in main
and in binary if binary finds the word
it returns a pointer to it if it fails
it returns null
second
all the accessing elements of key dab is
done by pointers
this causes one very significant change
in binary
the computation of the middle element
can no longer be simply mid equals paren
low plus high close paren
divided by two
because the addition of two pointers
will not produce any kind of useful
answer even when divided by two and is
fact illegal this must be changed to
mid equals low plus open paren high
minus low close paren divided by two
which sets mid to the point to point to
the element halfway between low and high
you should also study the initializers
for low and high
it is possible to initialize a pointer
to the address of a previously defined
object and that is precisely what we
have done here
in main we wrote four open paren p
equals key tab semicolon p less than key
tab plus n keys semicolon p plus plus
close paren
if p is a pointer to a structure any
arithmetic on p takes into the account
the actual size of the structure so
p plus plus increments p by the correct
amount to get to the next element in the
array of structures
but don't assume that the size of a
structure is the sum of the sizes of its
members because alignment requirements
for different objects
potentially may cause holes in the
structure
finally an aside on program format when
a function returns a complicated type as
instruct key star binary open paren word
comma tab comma n close paren
the function name can kind of be hard to
see and or find with a text editor
alternately
another style is sometimes used
on two lines now struct key star on the
first line in binary open paren word
comma tab comma n close paren
the spacing is mostly a matter of
personal taste pick the form you like
and hold to it
section 6.5 self-referential structures
before we start this section a slightly
longer aside from your narrator
up to now i've resisted the temptation
to augment the book with my own bits of
code
but we have reached the single point in
the book where i feel that there is too
big of a conceptual leap between two
sections so i'm going to add some of my
own narrative between sections 6.4 and
6.5
the rest of this chapter talks very
nicely about binary trees and hash
tables both essential low-level data
structures in computer science and both
excellent ways to understand pointers
and how c can be used to build data
structures like the python dictionary
however
the authors skip separately describing
the structure of a dynamic dynamically
constructed linked list which is the
first and foundational collection data
structure in computer science it should
be understand be understood before
moving to tree and hash map structures
linked lists form the foundation of the
python list object java array object php
numeric key arrays and javascript arrays
the linked list can be dynamically
extended and items can be added in the
middle efficiently as well as being
pushed or popped on or off the front or
back of the list
linked lists are used also to implement
cues as well as other aspects of
operating system
i will attempt to mimic the author's
writing style in this new section of the
book i'll write some sample code using a
more modern dialect of c so it's easier
to run on a modern compiler
section
6.5.1 linked lists bonus
content suppose we want to read a file
and print the file in reverse order we
don't know how many lines will be in the
file before we read the file so we can't
simply use an array of pointers to
strings and character arrays like lines
in a sense we need a dynamic array that
grows as we encounter new lines when we
reach the end of the file we then just
loop through our stored lines from the
end to the beginning so we can print
them out in reverse order
one solution is to make a data structure
called a doubly linked list of character
strings
in addition to each line of data we will
store a pointer to the previous line and
the next line as well
as well as a pointer to the first item
we add to the list and then we'll call
this the head of the list and then the
most recent item we've added to the list
which we'll call the tail of the list
we will see a singly linked list as part
of the hashmap data structure in a
following section
a single link list can only be traversed
in a forward direction a doubly linked
list can be traversed either forwards or
backwards
given that our linked list of strings
will keep expanding as we get new lines
we avoid hard coding array sizes like
pound define maxlen1000 in the previous
chapter we were building a program to
sort a file
going back to the description of a line
in our doubly linked list it is clearly
a structure with three components struct
l node open curly brace char star text
semicolon struct l node star prev
semicolon struct l node star next
semicolon close curly brace
this recursive definition of l node
might look chancy but it's actually
quite correct it is illegal
for a structure contained to contain an
instance of itself but struct l node
star prev declares preeve to be a
pointer to an l node not an l node
itself
we'll write this code in a more modern c
dialect using modern memory allocation i
o routines provided by the standard c
library
this code is on page 130 of the textbook
available at
slash
www.cc4e.com
pound include stdio.h pound include std
live.h pawn includes string.h
pound define max line 1000 this is the
length of the line not the number of
lines struct l node open curly brace
char star text semicolon
struct l node star preview semicolon
struct l node star next semicolon close
curly brace semicolon
now we have our main program to print
the lines in reverse
and we will use int main open paren
close paren because we're coding in a
modern dialect of c
open curly brace struct l node star head
equals null semicolon struct l node star
tail equals null semicolon char line sub
max line semicolon
while
open paren f get s open paren line comma
max line comma s t d i n close paren not
equal null close print open curly brace
char star save equals open print char
star
close prin malloc open prin sterlin open
print line close paren plus one close
paren semicolon
stir copy
save come align
struct l node star new equals
open paren struct l node star close
paren malloc open paren size of struct l
node close paren close paren semicolon
new right arrow text equals save new
right arrow next equals null
new right arrow preview equals tail and
tail equals new
if
head
equals equals null
close paren head equals new semicolon
close curly brace to finish the while
now we'll print it all out
four open paren struct l node star
current equals tail semicolon current
not equal to null
semicolon current equals current right
arrow prev
close parenthesis open curly brace
printf open paren double quote
s close
double quote comma current right arrow
text close paren semicolon
close curly brace to finish the four and
then close curly brace
to finish the main
interestingly if we wanted to print the
list in forward order or if we did have
only a singly linked list our loop would
look as follows
four open paren struct l node star
current equals head semicolon current
not equal to null semicolon current
equals current right arrow next closed
paren open curly brace
printf open paren double quote percent s
double quote comma current right arrow
text
close paren
semicolon close curly brace
in general we use the variable names
head tail and current as well as next
and pre or similar names when writing
code that builds or uses a linked list
or so other programs will quickly
understand what we are talking about
after a while reading a for loop to
traverse a linked list becomes as
natural as reading a for loop that
progresses through a sequence of numbers
sections 6.5.2 binary trees
suppose we want to handle the more
general problem of counting the
occurrences of all the words in some
input
since the list of words isn't known in
advance we can't conveniently sort it
and use a binary search
yet we can't do a linear search for each
word that has arrived to see if it's
already been seen
the program would take forever
more precisely what is the expected
running time and it would grow
quadratically with a number of input
words
how can we organize the data to cope
efficiently with a list of arbitrary
words
our solution is to keep the set of words
seen so far sorted at all times
by placing each word into its proper
position in the order as it arrives
this should this shouldn't be done by
shifting the words in a linear array
though that takes too long instead we
will use a data structure called a
binary tree
the tree contains one node per distinct
word
each node contains a pointer to the text
of the word
a count of the number of occurrences of
the word
a pointer to the left child
node and a pointer to the right child of
node
no node may have more than one
at more than two children it might have
only zero or
one the nodes are maintained so that any
node in the left tree contains only
words that are less than the words at
the node and the right tree only
contains words that are greater
to find out whether a new word is
already in the tree one starts at the
root and compares the new word to the
word starting at that node
if they match we found it
if the new word is less than the tree
word the search continues down the left
otherwise the right child is searched
there is no child in the required
direction then the word is not in the
tree and
in plaque in fact the proper place for
it to be
is the missing child
this search process is inherently
recursive
since the search for many node uses a
search from one of its children
accordingly recursive routines for
inserting and printing will be the most
natural
going back to the description of a node
is clearly a structure with four
components
struct t node open curly brace char star
word
int count semicolon
struct t note star left semicolon struct
t node star right semicolon closed curly
brace
this recursive declaration of a node
might look chancy but actually it's
quite correct
it's
illegal for a structure to contain an
instance of itself but struck t node
star left semicolon declares left to be
a pointer to a node not a node itself
the code for the whole program is
surprisingly small given the handful of
supporting routines that we've already
written these are get word to fetch
input and alec to provide space for
squirreling the words away
the mahin routine simply reads words
with getword installs them in the tree
with tree
this is the first example on page 131 of
the textbook which you can see at
www.cc4e.com
code
pound include stdio.h pound defined max
word 20 pound defined letter single
quote a single quote
main open paren close paren open curly
brace struct t node star root comma star
tree open print close paren semicolon
char word open square bracket max word
close square bracket semicolon and t
semicolon
root equals null
while open paren open parent t equals
get word open paren word comma max word
close print close paren not equal eof
close paren
if open paren t double equal letter
close paren root equals tree open paren
root comma word close paren semicolon
tree print
open paren
root close paren semicolon close curly
brace
tree itself is straightforward
a word is presented by main to the top
level root of the tree
at each stage that word is compared to
the word already stored at the node and
is percolated down either to the left or
right subtree by a recursive called a
tree
eventually the word either matches
something already in the tree
in which case the count simply is
incremented or a null or pointer is
encountered indicating the node must be
created and added to the tree if a new
node is created tree rent turns a
pointer to it which is installed in the
parent node
this is
the example on page 132 of the textbook
at wwe
code
pound includes string dot h
struct t node open curly brace char star
word semicolon int count semicolon
struct t node star left semicolon struct
t node star right semicolon
close curly brace semicolon
struct t node star tree open paren p
comma w close paren we're going to
install
w at or below p
struck t node star p semicolon char star
w open curly brace struct t node star t
alec
open paren close paren semicolon char
star stir state stir save open for n
close paren semicolon
int conned semicolon
if open paren p double equal null
close paren open curly brace
we've got a new word p
equals t alec open print close paren to
make a new note
p right arrow word equals stir save open
paren w close paren semicolon p
right arrow count equals 1
p right arrow left equals p right arrow
right equals null
close curly brace else if
open paren open print con equal stir
comp w comma p right arrow word close
paren close paren
double equals zero close paren
p right arrow count plus plus
indicate that we've seen the word one
more time
else if open paren conned less than zero
close paren
lower will go into the left part of the
tree
p right arrow left equals tree
p right arrow left comma w
close paren semicolon else
p right arrow right
equals tree open friend p right arrow
right comma
w
close paren semicolon
return open paren p close paren
semicolon
close curly brace
and that's a bit of code it's not much
and it's beautiful
recursion is happening the return p at
the very end is really really important
because we're kind of always overriding
it but we're okay
so um
the overriding works its way back up to
the recursion because it's recursive
it's using pointers away we go
back to the text
storage for the new node is fixed by a
routine called t alec which is an
adaptation of the alec we wrote earlier
it returns a pointer to a free space
suitable for holding a tree node
we'll discuss this more in a moment the
new word is copied to a hidden place by
stir save the count is initialized and
the two children are made null
this part of the code is executed only
at the edge of the tree when a new node
is being added
we have unwisely for a production
program omitted error checking on the
values between returned by stir save and
t alec
tree print
prints the tree in left sub tree order
at each node it prints its left sub-tree
all the words less than this word then
the word itself then the right sub-tree
all the words greater
if you feel shaky about recursion draw
yourself a tree and printed with tree
print
it's one of the cleanest recursive
routines you can find
this example code is on page 133 of the
textbook which you can see at
www.cc4e.com
code
i won't read
the struct node code
just tree print
tree print open paren p close paren
struct t node star p semicolon open
curly brace if open paren p not equal to
null close parend
curly brace open curly brace tree print
open paren p air right arrow left close
paren semicolon printf percent 4d space
percent s backslash n double quote comma
p right arrow count comma p right arrow
word sum print close parenthesis
semicolon
tree print open print p right arrow
right close paren semicolon close curly
brace for the if and then close curly
brace for the tree print function
again i agree with the authors and that
is one of the cleanest and most
beautiful and most applicable uses of
recursion that you will probably ever
see in all your career
i'm not a fan of recursion in all uses
cases but you really can't do this any
other way well
back to the text
practic as a practical note if the pre
tree becomes unbalanced because the
words don't arrive in random order the
running time of the program can grow too
fast as a worst case if the forwards are
already in order
this program does an expensive
simulation of linear search there are
generalizations of the binary tree
notably
2 3 trees avl trees and i would add
balanced binary trees which do not
suffer from this worst case behavior but
we will not describe them here
before we leave this example it's also
worth a brief digression on a problem
related to storage allocators clearly
it's desirable that there only be one
storage allocator in a program
even though it allocates different kinds
of objects but if one allocator is to
process requests for say pointers to
chars and pointers to struck t nodes two
questions arise
first
does it meet the requirement of most
real machines that objects of a certain
types must satisfy alignment
restrictions for example integers must
often be located uneven addresses
second
what declarations can cope with the fact
that alec necessarily returns different
kinds of pointers
alignment requirements can generally be
satisfied easily at the cost of some
wasted space merely by assuring ensuring
the allocator always returns a pointer
that meets all alignment restrictions
for an example on the pdb11 it is
sufficient
that alec always returns an even pointer
since any type of object may be stored
at an even address the only cost is a
wasted character on the odd length
requests
similar actions are taken on other
machines
thus the implementation of alec may not
be portable but its usage is
the alec of chapter 5 does not guarantee
any particular alignment in chapter 8
we'll show how to do the job right
as an aside by now you know that when
the authors mentioned the pdp-11 they
are sharing some aspects of the
challenge of making c work on previous
generation computers with short memory
words and small amounts of memory and at
the same time making them work well on
the incoming generation of computers
with larger words and more memory
the research thought
and care that went into making sure the
c code was portable across multiple
generations of computer hardware is on
display in the previous paragraph
the question of the type declaration for
alec is a vexing one for any language
that takes its type checking seriously
in c the best procedure is to declare
that alec returns a pointer to char and
then explicitly coerce the pointer into
the desired type with a cast
therefore if p is declared as char star
p semicolon then
open paren struct t node star close
paren p converts it into a t node
pointer expression
thus t alec is written as
t node star t alec open paren close
paren open curly brace char star alec
return open paren open print struct t
node star close print alec open paren
sizeof open prin struct t node close
prin close paren close print
this is more than is needed for current
compilers but represents the safest
course for the future
i would add
that these concerns that the authors
mentioned in this section are also
nicely resolved in modern c compilers in
the nc version of c they introduce the
notion of the void type
the void type indicates the lack of a
type
much like null is used to indicate not a
valid pointer
or not a flying toy
in 1978 because the chart type was
generally the most native type on any
system it was often used as the generic
pointer needed to return memory from an
allocation function
in modern c we use pointers to void and
then cast the returning pointer
to be a pointer to whatever struct or
other data we just allocated
if we were writing alec the alec routine
in this book using modern c it would
return a pointer to white
the 1978 version is char star alec open
paren close paren and the modern version
is void star alec open paren close paren
we've left the book alone we haven't
used void throughout the book
but it is a testament to the foresight
of the authors
that all the pointer casting code in
this book still works today the same
regardless of whether the memory
allocation functions return char or void
pointers to the allocated data
sections 6.6 table lookup
as an aside in this section we finish
our quick tour of the implementations of
the three core data structures in
computer science
one the linked list two the tree and
three the hash map as described in this
section
a singly linked list is also part of a
hashmap implementation so you can
compare it
to the doubly linked list code
introduced in the earlier bonus section
6.5.1
this section is worth understanding well
because not only is it an excellent
review of pointers and structures but
also because one of the most common
questions
on a face-to-face programming interview
is draw a hashmap on the whiteboard and
explain how it works
this is an easy question if you study
and understand this section of the book
and almost impossible if you have not
in some ways this section is the most
intricate data structure that's
described in the book
it is why it is so popular in coding
interviews
chapters 7 and 8 talk about lots of
practical things like input output of
the unix operating system
elegant data structures and their use
are core concepts in computer science
understanding them highlights the
difference between a good programmer and
a computer scientist
in a sense understanding how a hashmap
is the secret handshake of computer
science
and it is the secret handshake
because of this book and this section of
this book
written back in 1978
and used in a course
that the person interviewing you may
have took when they were in college
hash maps were difficult for them to
understand back then and so if you
understand the concept then you must be
solid
so i hope you pay close attention to
this section and remember the handshake
back to the text
in this section we will write the
innards of a table lookup package as an
illustration of more aspects of
structures this code is typical of what
might be found in the symbol table
management routines of a macro processor
or a compiler
for example consider the c pound define
statement when a line like pound define
yes one is encountered the name
replacement text
the name yes and the replacement text
one are stored in a table
later when the name yes appears in a
statement like inward equals yes
semicolon it must be replaced by one
there are two major routines that
manipulate the names and replacement
texts
install open paren s comma t close paren
records the name s and replacement t in
the table
s and t are just character strings
lookup open paren s close print searches
for s in the table and returns a pointer
to the place where it was found or null
if it wasn't there
the algorithm used is a hash search the
incoming name is converted to a small
positive integer which is then used to
index into an array of pointers
an array element points to the beginning
of a chain of blocks describing the
names that have the hash value
and if it is null then no names have
hashed to that value
a block in the a block in the chain is a
structure containing pointers to the
name the replacement text and the next
block in the chain
a null next pointer marks marks the end
of the chain
struct and list open paren
char star name semicolon char star def
semicolon
struct
endless star next semicolon close curly
brace semicolon
the pointer array is just pound define
hash size 100
static struct and list star hash tab
open square bracket hash size close
square bracket semicolon
the hashing function which is used by
both lookup and install simply adds up
the character values in the string and
forms the remainder modulo
the array size this is not the best
possible
algorithm but it has the merit of
extreme simplicity
hash open paren s close paren char star
s semicolon open curly brace int hash
val
four
open curly brace hash val equals zero
star s not equal quote single quote
backslash zero single quote semicolon
close paren
hash val plus equals star s plus plus
semicolon
return open paren hash val modulo
percent hash size close paren semicolon
close curly brace
as an aside
hashing functions are one of the
foundational notions in computer science
hashing functions are used for
everything from high performance
in-memory structures
organizing databases
data digital signing network packet
checksums security algorithms and much
more
the above text is a really great example
of a really simple hashing function
you should understand this simple
presentation well so that when you
encounter a more complex implementation
or use of hashing you can fall back on
this text to understand that at its core
hashing is a very simple concept
so much of this chapter is a succinct
example of some of the most powerful
concepts in computer science
please don't look at the eight code
lines of code above and think i got that
and just jump to the next bit
this chapter is showing you the way of
the master programmer
wax on
wax off
be patient
slow down
and enjoy your time here
back to the text the hashing process
produces a starting index in the array
hashtag if the string is to be found
anywhere it will be in the chain of
blocks beginning there
the search is performed by lookup
if lookup finds the entry already
present it just returns a pointer to it
if not it returns null
here's the code struct and list star
lookup open paren s close paren
char star s
semicolon open curly brace
struct and list star np semicolon
for
open paren np equals tab sub hash open
paren s close paren
close square bracket semicolon np not
equal null semicolon np equals np right
arrow next close parenthesis
if stir comp open print s comma np right
arrow name close paren double equals
zero return open print np close paren
semicolon
return open print null close print
semicolon close curly brace
install uses lookup to determine whether
the name installed is already present if
so the new definition must supersede the
old one
otherwise a complete newly new entry is
created
install returns no
if for any reason there's no room for a
new entry
struct and list star install open friend
name common death close paren
jar star name comma star def semicolon
open curly brace
struct
endless star np comma star lookup open
print close brand semicolon char
stir save comma star alec open print
close paren semicolon
int
val semicolon
if open paren open paren np equals
lookup open paren name close paren close
print double equal null
close paren open curly brace i.e it's
not found np
equals open paren struct end list star
close paren alec open paren size of open
paren star np close paren close paren
semicolon
np equals null return null that means
the allocation failed
if open paren open paren np right arrow
name
equals
stir save open paren name close print
close paren double equals null close
paren return
open paren
null close paren semicolon
hash val
equals
open paren np right arrow name close
brand semicolon
np next equals
tab open square bracket hash val close
for bracket second semicolon
hash tab open square bracket hash valve
close spur bracket equals np semicolon
we're actually pushing these new ones to
the head of this singly linked list
and so those last two
statements push the the most recent top
of the list
forward and then replace with the new
one at the top of the list the list does
not stay in any order
so
we have a closed curly brace to end all
that if for the not found code
close curly brace else this is the
already code click already their code
free
open paren np right arrow def close
paren semicolon
free the previous definition
that's the string part of the
the
the pound define
if open paren np
right arrow def
equal stir save open paren def close
print close print
equals null close print return open
paren null close paren semicolon
return open print np close print
semicolon close curly brace so that last
bit there was to
if you have a pound define with the same
keyword and a different later you have
it later a different uh definition you
can replace the definition so that last
bit was replacing the definition
again this code is a pretty intricate
it's really both the hash table and a
singly linked list going on at the same
time so take a close look at this on
page 136 of the book
stir save merely copies the string given
its argument to a safe space obtained by
a call to alec we've showed this code in
chapter five since calls to alec and
free may occur in any order and since
alignment matters the simple version of
alec
is just not adequate here
see more in chapters 7 and 8.
as an aside one of the reasons that the
authors make vague forward-looking
statements we know that they talk about
dynamic memory is that large-scale
memory management in a programming
language is still a subject of active
research 40 years later
back in 1978 it was absolutely not a
settled topic you can see this when the
authors build a simple non-production
memory allocation scheme with their own
alec and free routines backed by a fixed
length static extern array of characters
dynamic allocation is essential to
writing competency programs but it is
likely that the production grade dynamic
memory support was still somewhat
non-portable when the book was written
so they used simple self-contained
implementations in this book
modern dynamic memory support is through
the mala c alec and free functions in
the standard library these functions
request dynamic memory blocks from the
operating system and manage those areas
on behalf of your c code
on unix and unix-like systems the memory
allocation layer asks the underlying
operating systems for blocks of memory
through the sbrk interface
even with virtual memory programmers
must carefully manage their use of
dynamically allocated memory because
memory is never unlimited
section 6.7 fields
when storage space is at a premium it
may be necessary to pack several objects
into a single machine word
one especially common use is a set of
single bit at flags in applications like
compiler symbol tables
externally imposed data formats such as
interfaces to hardware devices also
often require the ability to get at
pieces of a word
as an aside we are going to go now from
low level programming to even lower
level programming
the unix operating system is written in
c and unix needs to have for example an
implementation of the internet protocol
so it can be connected to the internet
one of the most important internet
protocols is the transmission control
protocol tcp
in order to implement tcp you need to
send very precisely formatted data
across the network the data is very
tightly packed in order to save precious
network bandwidth the exact format of a
tcp header is described in the tcp
wikipedia page
if you look at the header you will find
that it bits 96 through 99
tcp expects a four bit integer that
defines the data offset
exactly what this data means is less
relevant unless you're actually writing
the tcp implementation but it does
demonstrate that we need to control our
data layout at times on a bit by bit
basis
this section covers how we can use
struct to build up a tcp header in c
which can be parsed and set without
using masking and shifting operations
with hard-coded numbers
the section below is simpler than
constructing a valid tcp header using a
carefully packed struct but it does lay
the groundwork for these more complex
situations
now back to the text
imagine a fragment of a compiler that
manipulates a symbol table
each identifier in a program has certain
information associated with it for
example whether or not it's a keyword
whether or not it's external and or
static and so on the most compact way to
encode such an information is a set of
one-bit flags in a single char or int
the usual way this is done is define a
set of masks
corresponding to the relevant bit
positions as in
pound-defying keyword 0-1 pound-define
external 0-2 and pound defined static 0
4. the numbers of course must be powers
of 2 so that the shifting works
then accessing the bits become a matter
of bit fiddling with shifting masking
and complementing operators which were
described in chapter 2.
certain idioms of fear appear frequently
flags
vertical par equals external vertical
bar static
turns on the external and static bits
and flags while flags ampersand equal
tilled open paren external or static
closed paren semicolon turns them off
and if open paren open print flags
ampersand paren external vertical bar
static close paren close print equal
equal zero
dot dot dot is true if both bits are off
although these idioms are readily
mastered as an alternative c offers the
capability of defining and accessing
fields within a word directly rather
than by bitwise logical operators
a field is a set of adjacent bits within
a single int the syntax of field
definition and access is based on
structures for example the symbol table
palm defines above could be replaced by
the definition of three fields
struct
unsigned is keyword colon one semicolon
unsigned is extern colon one semicolon
unsigned is static colon 1 semicolon
closed curly brace flags
this defines a variable called flags
that contains three 1-bit fields the
number following the colon
represents the field width in bits
the fields are declared unsigned to
emphasize that they are really unsigned
quantities
individual fields are referenced as
flags.is keyword
flags.is extern etc just like other
structure members
fields behave like small unsigned
integers and may partic participate in
arithmetic expressions just like the
other integers thus the previous
examples may be written much more
naturally as
flags is underscore extern equals flags
is static equals one semicolon
turn the bits on
flags is extern equals flags is static
equals one semicolon to turn the bits on
flags dot is extern equals flags dot is
static equals zero turns them off
and if open paren flags dot is extern
double equals zero and flags dot is
static double equals zero close paren
dot dot to test them
a field may not overlap an int boundary
if the width would cause this to happen
the field is aligned to the next in
boundary fields need not be named
unnamed fields with a colon and width
only are used for padding the special
width 0 may be used to force alignment
to the next int boundary there are a
number of caveats that apply to fields
perhaps the most significant
fields are assigned left to right on
some machines and right to left on
others reflecting the nature of
different hardware
this means that although fields are
quite useful for maintaining internally
defined data structures the question of
which end comes first have to has to be
carefully considered when picking apart
externally defined data
other restrictions to bear in mind
fields are unsigned they may only be
stored in ins or equivalently unsigned
they are not arrays and they do not have
addresses so the ampersand operator
cannot be applied to them
section 6.8 unions
a union is a variable which may hold at
different times
objects of different types and sizes
with the compiler keeping track of the
size and alignment requirements
unions provide a way to manipulate
different kinds of data in a single area
of storage without embedding any machine
dependent information in the program for
example again from a compiler symbol
table suppose constants may be ins
floats or character pointers the value
of a particular constant must be stored
in a variable of the proper type yet it
is most convenient for table management
if the value occupies the same amount of
storage and is stored in the same place
regardless of its type
this is the purpose of a union to
provide a single variable which can
legitimately hold one of several types
as with fields the syntax is based on
structures
union
u tag open curly brace int ival
semicolon float f val semicolon char
star p-val semicolon closed curly brace
u-val
the variable u-val will be large enough
to hold the largest of these three types
regardless of the machine it is compiled
of
compiled on
the code is independent of hardware
characteristics any one of these types
may be assigned to uval and then used in
expressions so long as the usage is
consistent the type retrieved must be
the type most recently stored it is the
responsibility of the programmer to keep
track of what type is currently stored
in the union the results are machine
defendant dependent if something is
stored as one type and extracted as
another type
syntactically members of a union are
accessed as union name dot member or
union pointer right arrow member
justice for structures
if the variable you type is used to keep
track of the current type start in uval
then one might see code as if open paren
you type double equals int close paren
printf
paren
double quote percent d backslash n
double quote comma
uval dot ival close parent semicolon
else if
open paren you type double equal float
close paren
print f
open paren double quote percent f
backslash n double quote comma u val dot
f val
close paren semicolon else if open paren
you type double equals string close
paren print f
double quote percent s backslash n
double quote comma u val dot p val close
paren semicolon
else printf
open paren double quote bad type percent
d and you type backslash n double quote
comma you type
close paren semicolon
unions may occur in structures and
arrays and vice versa the notion for
accessing a member of a union in a
structure or vice versa is identical
that to that for nested structures
for example in the structure array
defined by struct
open curly brace char star name
semicolon int flags semicolon
and you type semicolon
union open curly brace
int ival semicolon float f val semicolon
char star p val semicolon
close curly brace u val semicolon close
curly brace sim tab open square bracket
end sim close square bracket
the variable i val is referred to as
sim tab sub i dot u val dot ival
and the first character of the string p
val by star
sim tab sub i
dot uofl.pival
in effect a union is a structure in
which all the members have offset zero
the structure is big enough to hold the
widest member and the alignment is
appropriate for all types in the union
as with structures the only operations
currently permitted on unions are
accessing a member and taking the
address
unions may not be assigned to pass to
functions or returned by functions
pointers to unions can be used in a
manner identical to pointers to
structures
as it aside the above limitations on
unions are just no longer accurate like
structures modern c compilers can assign
the contents of the union to another
union variable you can also pass unions
into functions by value and receive a
union as the return type of a function
the storage allocator in chapter 8 shows
how a union can be used to force a
variable to be aligned on a particular
kind of storage
boundary section 6.9 type def
c provides a facility called typedef for
creating new data type names for example
the declaration type def space int space
length semicolon
makes the name length a synonym for end
the type length can be used in
declarations cast etc in exactly the
same ways int can be
length len comma maxlen semicolon length
star lengths open square bracket close
four bracket semicolon
similar the declaration type def char
star string semicolon makes string a
synonym for char star or a character
pointer which then may be used in
declarations like string
p
comma line ptr open square bracket lines
close square bracket comma alec open
paren close paren semicolon
note that the type being declared in a
typedef appears in the position of a
variable name
not right after the word typedef
syntactically typedef is like the
storage class
extern static etc
we've used uppercase letters in these
examples to emphasize the names
a more complicated example we could make
typedefs for the tree nodes shown
earlier in the track chapter
typedef struct t node open curly brace
char star word semicolon hint count
semicolon struct t node star left
semicolon struct t node star right
semicolon close curly brace
tree node comma star tree ptr
this creates three two new type keywords
called tree node which is a structure
and tree ptr which is a pointer to the
structure
then the routine t alec could become
tree ptr t alec open paren close print
open curly brace char star alec
open print close paren semicolon return
open paren open paren tree ptr close
print alloc open print size f open paren
tree node close print close paren closed
brand semicolon closed curly brace
it should be emphasized that a typedef
declaration does not exactly create a
new type in any sense
it merely adds a new name for some
existing types nor are there any new
semantics
variables declared this way have exactly
the same property as variables who
whose declarations are spelled out
explicitly
in effect typedef is like defined
except that since it's interpreted by
the compiler it can cope with textual
substitutions that are beyond the
capabilities of the c macro preprocessor
for example
typedef int
open paren star
pfi close print
open for enclosed print semicolon
creates
the type pfi
to mean
pointer to a function returning integer
which can be used in context like
pfi stir comp comma num comp comma swap
in the sort program in chapter 5.
there are two main reasons for using
typedef declaration
the first is to parameterize a program
against portability problems if type
defs are used
for the data types which may be machine
dependent only typedefs need to change
when the program is moved
one common situation is to use typedef
names for various integer quantities and
then make an appropriate set of choices
of short int and long for each host
machine
the second purpose of type defs is to
provide better documentation for a
program a type called tree ptr may be
easier to understand
than one declared only as a pointer to a
complicated structure
finally there's always the possibility
that the futures a compiler or some
other program such as lind may make use
of the information contained in typedef
declaration to perform some extra
checking on the program
this work
is based on the 1978 c programming book
written by brian w kernighan and dennis
m ritchie their book is copyright all
rights reserved by at t
but is used in this work under fair use
because of the book's historical and
scholarly significance
its lack of availability and the lack of
an accessible version of the book
the book is augmented in places to help
understand its rightful place in a
historical context amidst the major
changes of the 1970s and 1980s as
computer science evolved from a
hardware-first vendor-centered approach
to a software-centered approach where
portable operating systems and
applications written in c could run on
any hardware
this is not the ideal book to learn c
programming because the 1978 edition
does not reflect the modern c language
using an obsolete book gives us an
opportunity to take students back in
time and understand how the c language
was evolving as it laid the groundwork
for a future with portable applications
chapter 7 input and output
input and output facilities are not part
of the c language so we've de-emphasized
them in our presentation thus far
nonetheless real programs do interact
with their environment in much more
complicated ways than those we've shown
before
in this chapter we will describe this
standard io library
a set of functions designed to provide a
standard i o system for c programs
the functions are intended to present a
convenient programming interface yet
reflect only operations that can be
provided on most modern operating
systems
the routines are efficient enough that
users should seldom feel the need to
circumvent them for efficiency
regardless of how critical the
application
finally the routines are meant to be
portable
in the sense that they will exist
in compatible form on any system or c
exists and that programs which confine
themselves
to facilities provided by the stated
library can be moved from one system to
another essentially without change
we will not try to describe the entire
io library here we are more interested
in showing the essentials of writing c
programs that interact with our
operating system environment
section 7.1
access to the standard library
each source file that refers to the
standard library function must contain
the line pound include stdio.h near the
beginning
the file
stdio.h defines certain macros and
variables used by the i o library
the use of angle brackets less than and
greater than instead of the usual double
quotes directs the compiler to search
for the file in a directory containing
the standard header information
in unix this is often somewhere like
slash user slash include
furthermore it may be necessary when
loading the program to specify the
library explicitly for example on the
pdp-11 unix system the command to
compile a program would be
cc
source files etc
dash ls capital s
where dash l capital s indicates loading
from the standard library
section 7.2
standard input and output
catch our input char
the simplest input mechanism is to read
a character at a time from the standard
input generally the user's terminal or
keyboard with getchar getchar returns
the next input character each time it's
called
in most environments that support c
a file may be substituted for the
terminal by using the less than config
convention
if a program prog uses get char then the
command line prog less than infile
causes probe to read infile instead of
the terminal
or keyboard
the switching of input is done in such a
way that prog is oblivious to the change
in particular the string less than
infile is not included in the command
line arguments in argv
the input switching is also invisible if
the input comes from another program by
a pipe mechanism
the command line other probe vertical
bar prog
runs two programs other prog and prog
and arranges for the standard input for
prog to come from the standard output of
other prog
cat char returns the value eof when it
encounters end-to-file on whatever input
is being read the standard library
defines the symbolic eof constant to be
-1 with a pound defined in the file
stdio.h
but test should be written in terms of
eof not negative 1. so is to be
independent of the specific value for
output put char open paren c close paren
puts the character c on the standard
output which is also by default the
terminal
or screen
the output can be directed to a file by
using greater than
if probe uses put char prog greater than
out file will write the standard output
onto outfile instead of the terminal
on the unix system a pipe can also be
used
prog vertical bar another prog puts the
standard output of prog into the
standard input of other prog
again
prog is not aware of the redirection
output produced by printf also finds its
way to the standard output and calls to
put char and printf may be interleaved
a surprising number of programs read
only one input stream and write only one
output stream
for such programs i o with getchart
putchar and printf may be entirely
adequate and is certainly enough to get
started
this is particularly true given file
redirection in a pipe file for
connecting the output of one program to
the input of the next
for example consider the program lower
which maps
input to lower case
this is an example on page 145 with a
textbook that you can see at
www.cc4e.com
code pound include stdio.h
pound includes c type dot h
main open print close paren
open curly brace int c
while open paren open paren c equals get
char open paren close paren close print
not equal to eof close paren
put char
is upper open paren c close paren
question mark two lower open paren c
close paren colon c close paren
semicolon close curly brace
the functions is upper and two lower are
actually macros defined in c type dot h
the macro is upper tests whether its
argument is an uppercase letter
returning non-zero if it is and zero if
it's not the macro two lower converts an
uppercase to lowercase letter
regardless of how these functions are
implemented on a particular machine
their external behavior is the same
so programs that use them are shield
shielded from the knowledge of their
character set
to convert multiple files you can use a
program
like the unix cat to collect files cat
file1 file2.verticalbar
lower greater than output and thus avoid
learning how to access files from a
program
the cad example is presented later as
example code in this chapter
as an aside
the standard io library functions
getchar and put char can actually be
macros and thus
avoid the overhead of a function call
per character we'll show this how this
is done in chapter 8.
section 7.3 formatted output printf
the two routines printf for output and
scanf f4 input which we describe in the
next section permit translation to and
from character representations of
numerical quantities
they also allow generation or
interpretation of formatted lines
we've used printf informally throughout
the previous chapters here is a more
complete and precise description
printf open paren control com arg1 comma
card 2 etc close paren
printf converts formats and prints its
arguments on the standard output under
this under the control of the string
control the control string contains two
type of objects ordinary characters
which are simply copied to the output
stream
and conversion specifications each of
which causes conversion and printing of
the next successive argument to printf
each conversion specification is
introduced by the character sense sign
and ended by a conversion character
between the percent and the conversion
character there may be a minus sign
which specifies left adjusted of the
left adjustment of the converted
argument in its field
a digit string specified a minimum field
width
the converted number will be printed in
a field at least this wide and wider if
necessary
if the converted argument has fewer
characters than the field it will be
padded on the left or right if the left
adjustment indicator's been given to
make up the field width
the padding character is normally blank
in zero if the field width is specified
with a leading zero
this zero does not imply an octal field
with
a period
which separates the field width from the
next digit string
a digit string
that specifies the precision which
specifies the maximum number of
characters to be printed from a string
or the number of digits to be printed to
the right of the decimal point of a
float or a double
a length modifier the letter l
which indicates that the corresponding
data item is along rather than an end
conversion characters and their meanings
are
d
the arguments converted to decimal
notation o the argument is converted to
unsigned octal notation without a
leading zero
x
the argument is converted to unsigned
hexadecimal notation without the leading
0x
u the argument is converted to unsigned
decimal notation
c
the argument is taken to be a single
character
s the argument is a string
characters from the string are printed
until a null character is reached or the
number of characters indicated by the
present precision specification is
exhausted
e the argument is taken to be a float or
a double and converted to decimal
notation of the form
optional minus sign
m dot nnn
capital e plus or minus xx where the
length of the string of the ends is
specified by the precision the default
by precision
the default precision is 6.
note that the precision does not
determine the number of significant
digits printed in the f format
g
says use percent e or percent f which
ever is shorter
and non-significant zeros are not
printed
if the character after the percent is
not a conversion character the character
is simply printed thus percent may be
printed as percent percent
most of the format conversions are
obvious and have been illustrated in the
earlier chapter
one exception is the precision field as
it relates to strings the following
table shows the effect of a variety of
specifications in printing hello comma
world which is 12 characters we put
colons around each field so you can see
its actual width
colon percent 10 s colon
colon hello world colon
it's 12 characters long
and so we get 12 characters printed
because we haven't really told it to
strictly limit that
colon percent minus 10 s colon
colon hello comma world colon no extra
spaces
again 12 characters are used even though
if we said 10 it expands it to 12 and
the fact that it's left justified seems
how we're printing more than the width
of the field
doesn't make any difference
colon percent 20 s colon
colon eight spaces then hello comma
world colon
eight spaces are put in on the left
because it by default is right justified
colon
percent minus 20 s colon
prints colon hello comma world and then
eight spaces and then colon
we've told it to left justify so the
eight spaces are added to fill it out to
20 spaces after hello world
colon percent 20.10 s colon
gives us colon and then 10 blanks and
then hello comma w o r colon
now in this case we've told it we really
only want 10 characters from the string
and so the the ld is truncated
percent minus 20.10 s colon
hello comma w o r
and then 10 spaces
and it's less justified so the ten
spaces are at the end
right before the colon
colon percent dot 10 s colon colon hello
comma wor colon so now the overall field
that's printed is exactly 10 characters
and it is the leftmost 10 characters
warning
printf uses its first argument to decide
how many arguments follow and what their
types are it will get confused and you
will get nonsense answers if there are
not arguments enough arguments or they
are of the wrong
type as an aside formatted output is
difficult the design of c printf was
inspired by the earlier format statement
in fortran and alcohol in order to
compete with those languages c needed to
ship with solid support for formatted
output the approach chosen by c
percolated into c like languages php and
java simply have a function called
printf that mimics most of the c formats
python has evolved its approach to
formatted output over the years an early
initial solution had a syntax that used
percent to provide c like formatting
there was also a format method on the
string object
for example
x
equals 421.34
print open paren double quote x is
percent 7.2 f
double quote percent open paren x comma
close paren close paren
that uses the percent operator and sends
a tuple but the syntax of percent seven
point two f is the same another option
is
print open paren double quote x is
open curly brace y colon 7.2 f
close curly brace double quote dot
format open paren y equals x close paren
close paren
this sends a set of key value pairs
and it's a little clunky
the latest and least clunky way to do it
in modern python is what we call f
strings
and the code is print
f double quote
print open paren f double quote x is
open curly brace x colon 7.2 f close
curly brace double quote close paren
but even after all this evolution much
of this output formatting still traces
its design inspiration from the nc
printf capabilities back in 1978.
formatted input scanf
the function scanf is the input analog
of printf providing many of the same
conversion facilities but in the
opposite direction
scanf open paren control com arg1 comma
r2 etc close paren scanf reads
characters from standard input
interprets them according to the format
specified in control and stores the
results in the remaining arguments the
control argument is described below
the other arguments each of which must
be a pointer
indicate where the converting
corresponding converted input should be
stored
the control string usually contains
conversion specifications which are used
to direct interpretation of input
sequences
the control string may contain blanks
tabs or new lines we call these white
space characters which are ignored
ordinary characters
not
percent which are expected to match the
next non-white character space character
of the input stream
conversion specifications consisting of
the character percent an optional
assignment suppression character
asterisk
and an optional number specifying the
maximum field width and a conversion
character
a conversion specification directs the
conversion of the next input field
normally the result is placed in the
variable pointed to by the corresponding
argument
if assignment suppression is indicated
by the asterisk character however the
input field is parsed but then simply
skipped no assignment is being made
an input field is defined as a string of
non-white space characters extent it
extends to either the next white space
character or until the field width if
specified is exhausted
this implies that scanf will read across
line boundaries to find its input since
new lines are white space
the conversion character indicates the
interpretation of the input field the
corresponding argument must be a pointer
as required by the call by value
semantics of c
the following conversion characters are
legal
d
a decimal integer is expected on input
the corresponding argument should be an
integer pointer
o
an octal integer at with or without a
leading zero is expected on input the
corresponding argument should be an
integer pointer
x
a hexadecimal integer with or without
the leading zero x is expected in the
input this corresponding argument should
be an integer pointer
h
a short integer is expected in the input
the corresponding argument should be the
point a pointer to a short integer
c
a single character is expected the
corresponding argument should be a
character pointer the next input
character is placed at the indicated
spot
the normal skip over white space
characters is suppressed in this case to
read the next non-white space character
use percent one s
s
a character string is expected the
corresponding argument should be a
character pointer pointing to an array
of characters large enough to accept the
string and turn the terminating
backslash zero which will be added
f
a floating point number is expected the
corresponding argument should be a
pointer to a float
the conversion character e is a synonym
for f
the input formats for floats is an
optional sign a string of numbers
possibly containing a decimal point and
an optional exponent field containing an
upper or lower case e followed by
possibly a signed integer
the conversion character d o and x may
be preceded by l the letter l
to indicate that a pointer to a long
rather than end appears in the argument
list
similarly the conversion characters e or
f may be preceded by the letter l to
indicate that it's a pointer to a double
rather than a float in the argument list
for example the call
int i
float x
char
name open square bracket 50 close square
bracket close
a semicolon
scanf open parenthesis double quote
percent d space percent f space percent
s
double quote comma ampersand i comma
ampersand x comma name
close paren semicolon with the input
line
25 space 54.32
e minus 1 space thomson
we'll assign the value 25 to i
the value 5.432
to x and the string thompson properly
terminated with a backslash 0 to name
the three input fields may be separated
by as many blanks tabs and new lines as
desired
the call
int i semicolon float x semicolon char
name open square bracket 50 close square
bracket semicolon
scanf double quote percent to d space
percent f
space
percent star d
space percent to s
double quote comma ampersand i comma
ampersand x common name close
parentheses
with input 56789 space 0 1 2 3 space
4 5 a 7 2 will assign 56 to i
7 89.0 to x
skip over 0 1 2 3 and place the string
45 in name
the next call to any input routine will
begin searching at the letter a
in these two examples
name
is a pointer and thus must not be
preceded by an ampersand
as another example the rudimentary
calculator of chapter 4 can now be
written with scanf to do the input put
conversion
this is example code on page 150 the
textbook which you can see at
www.cc4e.com
code
pound include stdio.h
main open paren close paren open curly
brace double sum comma v semicolon sum
equals zero
while open paren scanf open paren double
quote percent l f
double quote comma ampersand v
close parenthesis not equal eof close
parentheses printf open parenthesis
double quote backslash t
percent.2f backslash n
double quote comma sum plus equals v
close parenthesis semicolon close curly
brace
scanf stops when it's in when it
exhausts control string or when some
input fails to match the control
specification it returns as its function
residual value the number of
successfully matched and assigned input
items this can be used to decide how
many input items were found
on end to file eof is returned note that
this is different from zero which means
that the next input character does not
match the first specification in the
control string the next call to scanf
resume searching immediately after the
last character already returned
a final warning the arguments to scanf
must be pointers
by far the most common error is writing
scanf open paren double quote percent d
percent comma n
close paren semicolon instead of scanf
open paren double quote percent d double
quote comma ampersand n close paren
semicolon
section 7.5 in memory format conversion
the functions scanf and printf have
siblings called scan f and s printf
which perform the corresponding
conversion but operate on a string
instead of a file the general format is
s printf open paren string comma control
comma arg one comma r two dot dot close
paren
s scan f open paren string comma control
comma arg one comma r two et cetera
close paren
sprint s print f formats the arguments
in arg1 arg2 etc according to control as
before but it places the result in a
string instead of on the standard output
of course string had better be big
enough to receive the result as an
example
if the name is a character array and n
is an integer then
s printf open paren name comma
double quote temp percent d double quote
comma n
arg2 etc these arguments must be pointer
the
call scanf open paren name comma double
quote temp percent d double quote comma
ampersand n
close parenthesis semicolon
sets n to the value of the digits
following
temp in name
section 7.6 file access
as inside the next two sections do a
nice job of covering file input and the
notion of the standard error with simple
sample code
but the authors are also making a subtle
point about unix
and how the design of c makes it easy to
build unix utilities
by the end of section 7.6 we see a 29
line program that is pretty much a
complete implementation of the core
functionality of the unix cat command
part of the philosophy of unix was to
build commands that are each simple
building blocks that can be composed
using standard input standard output
redirection as well as pipes
these next two sections are a gentle
celebration of the design principles
that underlie the unix operating system
also
while we're talking about the linkage
between c and unix there is a
unix-related easter egg earlier in the
chapter
see if you can find it
bonus points if you already noticed it
the programs written so far have all
read the standard input and written the
standard output which we have assumed
are magically predefined for a program
by the local operating system
the next step in i o is to write a
program that accesses a file which is
not already connected to the program
one program that clearly illustrates the
need for such operations is cat which
concatenates a set of name files onto
standard output cad is used for printing
files on a terminal and is a general
purpose input collector for programs
which do not have the capability of
accessing files by name for example the
command cat
x dot c y dot c prints the contents of
the files x dot c and y.c on the
standard output
the question is how to arrange for the
named files to be read that is how to
connect the external names the user that
the user thinks of to the statements
which actually read the data
the rules are simple before it can be
read or written the file has to be
opened by the standard library function
f open
f open takes an external name like x dot
c or y dot c does some housekeeping and
negotiating with the operating system
some details of which do not need to
concern us and returns an internal name
which then must be used for subsequent
reads or rights of the file
the internal name is actually a pointer
called the file pointer to a structure
which contains information about the
file such as the location of a buffer
the current character position in the
buffer whether the file is being read or
written and similar
users don't need to know the details
because part of the standard i o
definitions are obtained from stdio.a
and it's a structured definition called
file
the only declaration needed for a file
pointer is exemplified by
file star f open open paren close paren
comma star fp semicolon
that says that fp is a pointer to a file
and f open returns a pointer to a file
note that file is a type name like int
not a structure tag it's implemented as
a typedef details on how all this works
on the unix system are given in chapter
eight
the actual call to f open in a program
is
fp equals
f open open paren name comma mode close
paren semicolon
the first argument of f open is the name
of the file as a character string the
second argument is the mode also a
character string which indicates how one
intends to use the files
allowable modes are read
are
write w or append a
if you open a file which does not exist
for writing or appending it is created
if possible
opening an existing file for writing
causes the old constants to be discarded
trying to read a file that does not
exist is an error and there may be other
causes of error as well like trying to
read a file when you don't have
permission
if there is any error f open will return
the null pointer with a value of null
which for convenience is also defined in
stdio.h
the next thing needed is a way to read
or write the file once it is open
there are several possibilities of which
get c and putsy are the simplest
getc returns the next character from a
file
it needs the file pointer to tell what
file thus
c
equals getc open paren fp close paren
places in c the next character from the
file referenced by fp and eof when it
reaches end of file
put c is the inverse of get c
put c open paren c comma f p close paren
puts the character c on the file fp and
returns c
like getchar and putchar gets the input
c may be macros instead of functions
when a program is started three files
are automatically opened and file
pointers are provided for them
these files are the standard input the
standard output and the standard error
output the corresponding file pointers
are called stdin
sddi out and stder
normally these are all connected to the
terminal but stdn and std out may be
redirected to files or pipes as
described in section 7.2
getchar and putchar can be defined in
terms of getc put c std in and std out
as follows
pound define get char open for n close
paren get c open paren stdin close paren
pound define put char open paren c close
paren put c open for n c comma std out
close paren
for formatted input or output files the
function f scan f and f printf may be
used these are identical to scanf and
printf
save that the first argument is a file
pointer that specifies the file to be
read or written the second string is the
control the
second argument is the control string
with these preliminaries out of the way
we are now in a position to write the
program cat to concatenate files
the basic design is one that has been
found convenient for many programs if
there are command line arguments they
are processed in order if there are no
arguments the standard input is
processed this way the program
can be used standalone or part of a
larger process
this example is on page 153 of the
textbook and you can see it at
www.cc4e.com
code
pound include stdio.h
main open paren argc comma argv closed
paren
int argc semicolon
char star argv
open square bracket close square bracket
semicolon
open curly brace
file star fp comma star f open open
chrome close print semicolon
if open paren rxc double equals one
close paren
there is no standard there's no
arguments so we're going to copy the
standard input
file copy open paren
stdin close paren semicolon else
while open paren minus minus rxc greater
than zero
close paren
if
open paren open paren fp equals f open
open paren star plus plus arc v comma
quote r quote close paren close paren
double equals null close paren open
curly brace
print
f open print double quote cat colon
can't open
space percent s backslash n double quote
star comma star r v close paren
semicolon
break semicolon
close curly brace else open curly brace
file copy open paren fp close paren
semicolon f close open paren fp close
print semicolon
close curly brace for the if then else
and then close curly brace for the main
and now we have the file copy function
we're going to open read all the
contents of a file pointer and send it
to standard output
file copy open paren fp close paren
file star fp semicolon open curly brace
int c semicolon while open paren open
for n c equals get c open paren fp close
print close paren not equal eof close
paren put c open paren
c comma std o ut close paren semicolon
close curly brace
the file pointers std in and std out are
predefined in the i o library as the
standard input and the standard output
they may be used anywhere an object of
type file star can be they are constants
however not variables so don't try to
assign to them
the function f close is the inverse of f
open it breaks the connection between
the file pointer and the external name
that was established by x f open freeing
the file pointer for another file
since most operating systems have some
limit on the number of simultaneously
open files a program may have it's a
good idea to free things when they're no
longer needed as we did above in cat
there's also another reason for f close
on an output file it flushes the buffer
in which put c is collecting output
fclose is called automatically for each
open file when a program terminates
normally
section 7.7 error handling stder and
exit
the treatment of errors in the previous
implementation of cat is not ideal the
trouble is that if one of the files
can't be accessed for some reason the
diagnostic is printed at the end of the
concatenated output
that is acceptable if the output's going
to a terminal but it's really bad if
it's going to a file or some other
program via pipeline
to handle this situation better a second
output file called stderr is assigned to
the program in the same way that stdin
and std out are
if at all possible output written on
stderr appears on the user's terminal
even if the standard output
is redirected
let's revise cat to write its error
messages onto the standard output file
this is really only a couple of lines of
code different between the example on
page 153 this is the example on page 154
of the textbook which of course you can
see at
www.cc4e.com
code
pound include stdio.h
pound include stdlib.h
open paren argh c comma arc v close
paren int argc semicolon
char star arc v open square bracket
close square bracket
semicolon open curly brace
file star fp comma star f open
open paren close paren semicolon
if open for n r c double equal one close
paren
here we have no arguments
file copy open paren s t d i close
parent semicolon else
while open paren minus minus argc
greater than zero close paren
if open paren open paren fp equals f
open open print star plus plus arg v
comma
double quote r double quote close paren
and close for n double equal null
close paren open curly brace
f print f open paren std e r r comma
double quote cat colon
can't open
percent s backslash n double quote comma
star r v close paren semicolon
exit open paren one close brand
semicolon close curly brace else open
curly brace file copy open paren fp
close paren semicolon
file close open print fp close paren
semicolon close curly brace to finish
the if and then exit
open paren zero close paren semicolon
close curly brace
to the uh change the finish the main
and file copy we is the same from the
previous so
this program signals errors two ways the
diagnostic output produced by fprintf
goes to stderr so it finds its way to
the user's terminal instead of
disappearing down a pipeline pipeline or
into an output file the program also
uses the standard library function exit
which terminates execution when it's
called the argument of exit is available
to whatever process called this one so
the success or failure of the program
can be tested by another program that
uses this one as a sub process
by convention a return value of 0
signals all as well and various non-zero
values signal abnormal situations
exit calls f-close for each open output
file to flush any buffered output then
calls a routine named underscore exit
the function underscore exit causes
immediate termination without any buffer
flushing of course it may be called
directly if desired
section 7.8 line input and output
the standard library provides a routine
f git s which is quite similar to the
getline function we've used throughout
the book
the call fcds open paren line comma max
line comma fp close paren reads the next
input line including the new line from
the file fp into the character array
line
at most max line minus 1 characters will
be red the resulting line is terminated
with backslash zero normally f cades
returns line on end to file it returns
null
our getline returns line length and zero
friend to file
for output the function f put s writes a
string which need not contain a new line
to a file f put s open paren line comma
fp close paren
to show there's nothing magic about the
functions like f get s and f put s here
they are copied directly from the unix
standard io library
this
code example is on page 155 of the
textbook which you can view at
www.cc4e.com
code
char
star
f get s open paren s comma n comma iop
close paren
char star s semicolon
in n semicolon register file star iop
semicolon
open curly brace
register int c semicolon register char
star cs semicolon
cs equals s semicolon
while open paren minus minus n greater
than zero double ampersand open paren c
equals get c open paren iop close print
close paren not equal eof close paren
if
open paren open paren star cs plus plus
equals c close print equal equal
quote backslash n quote close paren
break semicolon
star cs equals
quote backslash zero quote
semicolon return
open paren open paren c
double equals e o f
and c s double equals s close paren
question mark null
colon s close paren semicolon close
curly brace
the function f put s is as follows
f put s open paren s comma iop close
paren
register char star s register file star
iop semicolon open curly brace
register int c semicolon while open
paren c equals star s plus plus close
paren
put c open for n c comma iop close paren
semicolon close curly brace
section 7.9 some miscellaneous functions
the standard library provides a variety
of functions a few which stand out is
especially useful we've already
mentioned the string functions sterlin
stir cpy
stir cat and stir comp here are some
others
character class testing and
conversion several macro rows perform
character tests and conversions
the function is alpha open paren c close
print returns non-zero if c is
alphabetic zero if not the function is
upper open paren c close paren is
returns non-zero if c is upper case
zero if not
is lower open paren c close paren is
non-zero if c is lower case is zero if
not
is digit open paren c close paren is
non-zero fc is a digit zero if not
is space open friends c close paren
is non-zero if c is blank tab or new
line zero if not
two upper open paren c close paren
convert c to upper case
two lower open parenthesis close paren
convert c
to lower case those all worked on single
characters
on get c
the standard library provides a rather
restricted version of the function
ungetch which we wrote in chapter four
it's called ungetc
ungetc open paren c comma fp close paren
pushes the character c back onto the
file fp
only one character of pushback is
allowed per file
unget c may be used with any of the
input functions in macros like scan f
get c or get char
system call the function system open
paren s close paren executes the command
in the character string s
then resumes the execution of the
current program the contents of s
depends strongly on the local operating
system
as a trivial example on unix the line
system open for end double quote date
double quote close paren semicolon
causes the date program to be run it
prints the time and date of the day on
unix
storage management
the function c alec is rather like the
alec we have used in previous chapters
see alec open paren n comma size of
open paren object close paren close
paren
returns a pointer to enough space for n
objects of the specified size or null if
the request cannot be satisfied the
storage is initialized to zero the
pointer has the proper alignment for the
object in question but it should be cast
to the appropriate type as in
char star c alec open friend close paren
semicolon int star ip semicolon ip
equals open paren int star close paren c
alec open paren n comma size of open
paren int close paren close paren
semicolon
c free open paren p close print
free space pointed to by p
where p is originally obtained by a call
to see alec there are no restrictions on
the order in which space is freed but it
is a ghastly error to free something
not obtained by calling seahawk
chapter 8 shows the implementation of a
storage allocator like c alec in which
the allocated blocks may be freed in any
order
this work
is based on the 1978 c programming book
written by brian w kernighan and dennis
m ritchie
their book is copyright all rights
reserved by at t
but is used in this work under fair use
because of the book's historical and
scholarly significance
its lack of availability and the lack of
an accessible version of the book
the book is augmented in places to help
understand its rightful place in a
historical context amidst the major
changes of the 1970s and 1980s as
computer science evolved from a hardware
first vendor-centered approach to a
software-centered approach where
portable operating systems and
applications written in c could run on
any hardware
this is not the ideal book to learn c
programming because the 1978 edition
does not reflect the modern c language
using an obsolete book gives us an
opportunity to take students back in
time and understand how the c language
was evolving as it laid the groundwork
for a future with portable applications
chapter 8 the unix system interface
the material in this chapter is
concerned with the interface between c
programs and the unix operating system
since most c programs are on unix
systems this should be helpful to a
majority of the readers
even if you see on a different machine
however you should be able to glean more
insight into c programming from studying
these examples
this chapter is divided into three major
areas input output file system and a
storage allocator the first two parts
assume a modest familiarity with the
external characteristics of
unix
chapter 7 was concerned with a system
interface that is uniform across a
variety of operating systems on any
particular system the routines of the
standard library have to be written in
terms of the i o facilities that are
actually available on the host system
in the next few sections will describe
the basic system entry points for i o
and uni on the unix operating system and
illustrate how parts of the standard
library can be implemented with them
but
as an aside the dual nature of c and
unix has been on display throughout the
book
and while this chapter is called the
unix system interface
in a sense it's less about unix in
itself and very much about why c is such
a great programming language
let me explain
before unix and c became the norm
operating systems and operating system
utilities those commands were used
interactively and batch jobs were quite
often written in the assembly language
of the computer which it was supporting
often there were not well-documented api
calls between utilities in assembly
language and the assembly language which
implemented the operating system
smart
vendor programmers would just look at
the operating system code and write
their utility code to work with it
this section shows that a language that
has features like structures arrays
pointers
a preprocessor and unions was
sufficiently rich
so that we could document all the
intricate interfaces with an operating
system using a relatively high level
language and then we could write our
utility code like cat
in a high-level language as well
in this chapter the authors are almost
shouting
quit using assembly language to build
your operating system and utility code
further they are showing us examples
designed to answer the question that
might come from programmers used to the
old ways like can we do
x y z and c
the author's emphatic answer in the
increasingly intricate code samples is
c is not a toy language that's only
something used by a few att computer
scientists in a research lab
if you're doing serious system stuff
that needs maximum performance and
readability and reliability use c
this chapter shows c in all its glory
and shows why it was such an important
language
to enable the world of technology we
have 40 years later
at the end of the chapter we'll talk a
little bit about see how c enabled the
creation of easier to use programming
languages and why it was so important to
invent c inspired languages like python
ph g and and php and java
once c became the established systems
programming language
section 8.1
file descriptors
in the unix operating system all input
and output is done by reading or writing
files because all peripheral devices
even the user's terminal are files in
the file system
this means that a single homogeneous
interface handles all communications
between a program and peripheral devices
in the most general case before reading
or writing a file it is necessary to
inform the system of your intent to do
so
a process called opening the file
if you're going to write on a file it
may also be necessary to create it
the system checks for your right to do
so
does the file exist do you have
permission to access it and if all is
well returns to the program a small
positive integer called the file
descriptor
whenever i o is to be done on the file
the file descriptor is used instead of
the name to identify the file
this is roughly analogous to the use of
read open paren five comma dot dot dot
and write open paren six comma dot dot
dot in fortran
all information about an open file is
maintained by the system
the user refers to the file only by the
file descriptor
since input and output involving the
user terminal is so common
special arrangements exist to make this
convenient
in the command interpreter the shell
runs a program it opens three files with
files descriptors 0 1 and 2 called the
standard input standard output and
standard error output
all of these are normally connected with
a terminal so if a program reads file
descriptor 0 and writes to file
descriptors 1 and 2 it can do terminal i
o without worrying about opening the
files
the user of the program can redirect
input output to and from files with less
than and greater than
for example probe less than in file
greater than out file
in this case the shell changes the
default assignments for file descriptors
0 and 1 from the terminal to the named
files
normally file descriptor 2 remains
attached to the terminal so error
messages can go there
similar observations hold if the input
or output is associated with a pipe
in all cases it must be noted that the
file assignments are changed by the
shell not the program
the program does not know where its
input comes from nor where its output
goes so long as it uses file 0 for input
and 1 and 2 for output section 8.2
low level i o read and write
this lowest level of i o in unix
provides no buffering or any other
services
it is in fact a direct entry into the
operating system all input and output is
done by two functions called read and
write
for both the first argument is a file
descriptor
the second argument is a buffer in your
program where the data is to come from
or go to
the third argument is the number of
bytes to be transferred the calls are
and read equals read open paren fd comma
buff comma n close brand semicolon
and written equals write open paren ft
fd comma buff comma n close paren
semicolon
each call returns a byte count
which is the number of bytes actually
transferred
on reading the return the number of
bytes returned may be less than the
number of number asked for a return
value of zero bytes implies end to file
and negative one indicates an error of
some sort for writing the return value
is the actual number of bytes written it
is generally an error if this isn't
equal to the supposed number that was
asked to be written
the number of bytes to be written read
or written is quite arbitrary the two
most common values are 1 which means 1
character at a time or unbuffered and
512 which corresponds to the physical
block size on many early peripheral
devices
this ladder size will be most efficient
even but even a character at a time i o
is not inordinately expensive
putting these facts together we can
write a simple program to copy its input
to its output
the equivalent of the file copying
program written for chapter one
in unix
this program will copy anything to
anything
since input and output can be redirected
to any file or device
this example is on page 161 of the
textbook which you can
view at w www.cc4e.com
code
pound include standard stdio.h
pound defined buff size
512. this is the best size for pdp 11
unix
modern computers it probably should be
larger
main open print close print open curly
brace
char buff open square bracket buff size
close square bracket semicolon
int n
semicolon while open paren open paren n
equals read open paren zero comma buff
comma buff size close paren close paren
greater than zero close paren right open
paren one comma buff comma n close paren
semicolon close curly brace
if the file size is not an exact
multiple of buff size some read will
return a smaller number of bytes to be
written by write
the next call after that read will
return zero
it is instructive to see how read and
write can be used to construct higher
level routines like get char and put
char for example here is a version of
get char which does unbuffered input
this is the second example on page 162
of the textbook
pound include
stdio.h pound define
cmask0377
and this is a mask an octal mask to make
sure characters are greater than zero
get char open paren close paren open
curly brace
char c
semicolon return open paren open paren
read open paren 0 comma ampersand c
comma 1 close print greater than 0 close
print question mark
c ampersand c mask
colon e o f
semicolon close curly brace
c must be declared char because read
accepts a character pointer the
character being returned must be masked
with 0 3 7 7 to ensure that it's
positive otherwise
sign extension might make it negative
the constant 037 is appropriate for
ascii
and the pdp-11 but not necessarily for
every other machine
the second version of get char does its
input in big chunks
and hands out the characters one at a
time
this is the
first example on page 162 of the
textbook which you can see at www.ccf
code
pound include stdio.h
pound define cmask0377
pound define buff size 512.
now we do the buffered version of get
char
get char open friend close paren open
curly brace
static char buff open square bracket
buff size close square bracket
static char star buff p equals buff
semicolon static int n equals zero
semicolon
those variables are static so that they
they are long lived and exist from call
to call
the beginning of the code if open paren
n double equals 0 close print open curly
brace n equals read
open paren 0 comma buff comma buff size
close paren semicolon
buff p equals buff semicolon close curly
brace return
open paren open paren minus minus n
greater than equal to zero close paren
question mark star buff p plus plus
ampersand c mask colon eof close print
semicolon close curly brace
section 8.3 open create close unlink
create is not created it's create
without the e so i'll just call it creat
for now
other
than the default standard input and
output and error files you must
explicitly open files in order to read
or write them there are two system entry
points for this
open and create open is rather like the
f open discussed in chapter seven except
that instead instead of returning a file
pointer it returns a file descriptor
which is just an int
int fd semicolon
fd equals
open
open paren name comma rw mode close
paren semicolon
as with f open the name argument is a
character string corresponding to the
external file name the access mode
argument is different however rw mode is
a zero for read one for right and two
for read write access
open returns negative one if any error
occurs otherwise it returns a file valid
file descriptor
it is an error to open a file that does
not exist the entry point create is
provided to create new files or to
rewrite old ones
fd equals create open paren name comma p
mode close paren semicolon
returns a file descriptor if it was able
to create the file name
and negative one if not if the file
already exists create will truncate it
to zero length it is not an error to
create a file that already exists
if the file is brand new create creates
it with the protection mode specified in
the p mode argument
in the unix file system there are nine
bits of protection information
associated associated with each file
controlling read write and execute
permission for the owner of the file for
the owner's group and for all others
thus a three-digit octal number is the
most convenient
format for specifying permissions
for example zero seven five five
specifies read write and execute
permission for the owner and read and
execute permission for group and for
everyone else
to illustrate here
a simplified version of the unix utility
cp a program that copies one file to
another the main simplification is that
our
version only copies one file and does
not permit the second argument to be a
directory
and this example code is on page 163 of
the textbook which you can see at
www.cc4e.com
code
found include stdio.h
pound include std live.h pound defined
buff size
512
pound defined p mode 0 6 4 4 rw read and
write for owner read for group and
others
int
open paren arg c comma arg v
close paren
the format will be we're going to have
two files copy file one file two
int
argc semicolon char star arc v open
square bracket close square bracket
semicolon open curly brace int
f1 comma f2 comma n semicolon char buff
buff size
semicolon
if open paren
arg c not equal to three close paren
error open paren double quote usage
colon cp from 2
double quote common null
close paren semicolon
if
open paren open paren f1 equals open
open paren arg v sub one comma zero
close print close paren equal equal
minus one close paren error
open for n double quote cp colon can't
open percent s double quote comma arg v
sub 1
close paren semicolon
if
open paren open paren f2 equals create
open print arc v sub 2 comma p mode
close paren close paren
equal equal minus 1
close paren air open friend quote cp
colon can't create percent s
double quote comma arg v sub 2
close paren semicolon
while open paren open print n equals
read open paren f1 comma buff comma buff
size close paren close print greater
than zero close paren
if open paren write open print f2 comma
buff comma n close paren not equal
and close paren air
open paren double quote cp
colon right ear double quote comma null
close paren semicolon
exit open paren
zero close paren semicolon close curly
brace that's the end of the main program
the error
routine is going to print the error
message
air open paren s1 comma s2 close paren
char star s1 comma star s2 semicolon
open paren
printf open paren s1 comma s2 close
paren semicolon printf double quote
backslash n double quote close paren
semicolon
exit open paren 1 close paren semicolon
close curly brace
there is a limit on the number of files
which the program may have open
simultaneously according any program
which intends to process many files must
be prepared to reuse file descriptors
the retain close breaks the connection
between a file descriptor and an open
file and frees the file descriptor for
use with some other file
termination of a program by exit or
return from the main program
closes all open files
the function unlink open print file name
close print removes the file name from
the file system
section 8.4
random access seek and l-seek
file i o is normally sequential each
read or write takes place at a position
in the file right after the previous one
when necessary however a file can be
read or written in any arbitrary order
the system call lseq provides a way to
move around in a file without actually
reading or writing
lseq open paren fd comma offset comma
origin close paren semicolon
forces the current position in the file
whose descriptor is fd to move to the
position offset which is taken relative
to the location specified by origin
subsequent reading or writing will begin
at that position
offset is a long
fd and origin are ints origin can be 0 1
or 2 to specify that the offset is to be
measured from the beginning
from current position or from the end of
file respectively
for example to append to a file seek to
the end before writing
l seek open print ft
comma 0l
comma 2 close print semicolon to get
back to the beginning i.e rewind to the
beginning
l seek open paren fd comma 0l comma 0
parentheses semicolon
note that the 0l argument could also be
written as open parent long close paren
0.
with lseq it's possible to treat files
more or less like large arrays at the
price of slower access
for example the following simple
function reads any number of bytes from
any arbitrary place in a file
get open paren fd comma pause comma buff
comma n close paren
int fd comma n
long pause semicolon char star buff
semicolon open curly brace
l seek open parenthesis fd comma pause
comma 0 close paren semicolon
return open paren read open paren fd
comma buff comma n close paren close
paren semicolon close curly brace
in pre-version 7 unix the basic entry
point to the i o system is called seek
seek is identical to lseq except that
its offset argument is an int rather
than a long
accordingly since pdp 11 integers only
have 16 bits the offset specified for
seek is limited to 65535
for this reason origin values of 3 4 and
5 cause seek to multiply the given
offset by 512 which is the number of
bytes in one physical block on a 11 and
then interpret origin as if it were 0 1
or 2 respectively thus to get to an
arbitrary place in a large file requires
two seeks the first one selects the
block
then one which has origin equal to one
and then moves to the desired desired
byte within the block
once again we see c in unix straddling a
major improvement in computer hardware
in 1978.
the natural name for a function to
randomly move around a file would be
seek but in early versions of unix seek
took an integer as the offset but on
small word computers like pdp-11 have an
integer that can't represent a large
number so seek used a complex set of
rules to handle larger files
the only logical thing was to have the
offset be along and then for upwards
compatibility make a new function called
lseq that we use to this day
section 8.5
an example implementation of f open and
get c
let us illustrate how some of these
pieces fit together by showing an
implementation of the standard library
routines f open and get c on the pdp 11.
recall that files in the standard
library are described by file pointers
rather than file descriptors
a file pointer is a pointer to a
structure that contains several pieces
of information about the file a pointer
to a buffer so the file can read in
large chunks
count of the number of characters left
in the buffer a pointer to the next
character position in the buffer and
some flags describing read write mode
and the file descriptor the data
structure that describes a file is
contained in the file stdio.h which must
be included by pound include in any
source file that uses routines from the
standard library
it is also included by functions in that
library
in the following excerpt from the pdp-11
stdio.h
names which are intended for use only by
functions of the library begin with
underscore
so they are less likely to collide with
the names of a user program
as a side note i won't read the
underscores
because they
confuse your understanding so the
underscores are there in the code you
can look at it online
but i'm not going to read the
underscores
so this is basically some definitions
for stdio.h
pound define buff size
pawn define and file 20.
type def struct io buff open curly brace
char star ptr
int
cnt semicolon char star base semicolon
int flag semicolon int fd semicolon
close curly brace
file semicolon
extern file iob
open square bracket end file
close square bracket semicolon pound
define stdin
open paren ampersand iob sub zero close
paren
pawn define std out
open paren ampersand iob sub one close
paren pound define std air open paren
ampersand iob sub 2 close print
pawn define read 01 pound define right
o2 pondifying unbuff 04 pound define big
buff zero one zero
upon define eof
zero two zero pondifying air
zero four zero pound defined null zero
pawn define eof open prin
minus one close paren
upon define gets e open paren p
close paren open paren minus minus open
paren p close paren right arrow cnt
greater than or equal to zero question
mark
star open paren p close paren right
arrow ptr plus plus
ampersand zero three seven seven colon
fill buff open paren p close print close
print palm define get char
open paren close friend
get c
open paren std high n close paren
pound define put c
open parent x comma p close paren
open paren minus minus open paren p
close paren right arrow cnt greater than
or equal to zero question mark
star
open paren p close paren
right arrow ptr plus plus equals open
paren x close print colon
flush buff open paren open paren x close
paren comma p close print close paren
pound define put char open paren x close
paren put c open paren x come std out
close paren
the f c in macro normally just
decrements the counts advances the
pointer and returns the character
we do this in a very long defined
continued by a backslash if the count
goes negative however get c calls the
function fill buff to replenish the
buffer real initialize the structure
contents and return a character a
function may present a portable
interface yet itself contain
non-portable constructs
cat c masks the character with zero
three seven seven which defeats the sign
extension done by the pdp 11 and ensures
that all characters will be positive
although we will not discuss any details
we've included the definition of put c
to show that it operates in much the
same way as getsy calling a function
flush buff when its output buffer is
full
the function f open and fill buff can
now be written most of f open is
concerned with getting a file opened and
positioned at the right place
and setting the flag bits to indicate
the proper state
f open does not allocate any buffer
space this is done by fill buff when the
file is first read
you can look at this sample code from
page 167 at www.cc4e.com
code
i won't read it here because it's pretty
long and intricate so you'll have to go
watch it online or view it online
back to the text the function fill buff
is rather more complicated the main
complexity lies in the fact that phil
buff attempts to permit access to the
file even though there may not be enough
memory to buffer the i o if the space
for a new buffer cannot be obtained from
cat c alec all is well
if not
filbuff does unbuffered i o using a
single character stored in a private
array
the first call to get c for a particular
file finds a count of zero which forces
a call a fill buff if phil buff finds
that the file is not open for reading it
returns eof immediately
otherwise it tries to allocate a large
buffer and failing that a single
character buffer setting the buffering
information in flag appropriately
once the buffer is established phil buff
simply calls read to fill it
and sets the count and pointers
and returns the character at the
beginning of the buffer
subsequent calls to fill buff will find
a buffer already allocated
the only remaining loose end is how
everything gets started the array iob
must be defined initialized and
initialized force
stdin std out and std err
file iob open square bracket and file
close square bracket equals open curly
brace open curly brace null comma 0
common null comma underscore read comma
0 comma close curly brace comma and
that's the standard in
the next one is
open curly brace null comma 0 common
null
comma underscore right comma 1 comma
close curly brace comma and that's the
standard out definition the
the sub 1 position and then the next one
is open curly brace null comma 0 common
null comma underscore right
vertical bar
underscore on buff comma 2 close print
and that is the standard error entry
close curly brace semicolon
the initialization of the flag part of
the structure shows that std standard in
is to be read standard out is to be
written and standard out is to standard
error is to be written unbuffered
section 8.6
example listing directories
i would note that the sample code in
section 8.6 shows how we can write
applications like ls to interact with
directories in a unix file system
however the code in this section is not
portable to modern unix systems so we'll
leave the code as it is in this section
it's a good idea to read the code and
get an outline of how to work with
directories on unix if you want to write
code to handle directories you'll need
to consult more modern documentation
given the complexity of the code in this
section we are not going to include it
in the
copy of this book in this particular
media
similarly
section 8.7
example a storage allocator
consists of a lot of really complex code
and so we will leave that for you to see
online
at
www.cc4e.com book
slash chap08.md
dynamic memory is hard
modern languages like python ruby and
java give us high level objects like
strings lists and dictionaries
these structures automatically expand
and correct contract and can be copied
into a temporary variable used and then
discarded modern languages depend on
efficient memory allocation
a problem when dynamic memory is heavily
used is a fragmentation of the free
space
you can get to the point where you have
plenty of memory but each of the free
memory areas is so small that you can't
allocate a new memory block
when this happens the runtime
implementations of these systems run a
step called garbage collection where
everything pauses and free areas are
moved around to make sure that the free
memory is in a few large contiguous
areas
rather than many small non-contiguous
areas
language developers have been improving
garbage collection algorithms for the
past 40 years and there is still
much work to do
now that the authors have established
all the reasons that make see the ideal
portable systems programming language
which i hardly agree with
it's time to talk about where c comes up
short as a general purpose language for
those of us not working on the source
code to linux the most challenging
aspect of c is the lack of dynamic
structures that we can use without the
need to carefully allocate use without
the regard to the length of dynamically
allocated memory and not worry about
calling c free every single time we call
c alec
if a programmer without strong
programming skills a good understanding
of a testing regimen and a proper
defensing defensive programming attitude
is let loose in c they will invariably
write poor code
their c code will make poor use of
resources run the system out of memory
or produce code that is riddled with
security holes and bugs that seem to
randomly appear
a decade after c emerged and became
popular guido van rossum designed a
language called python
it was one of a number of languages that
was built using c and added an
object-oriented layer that greatly
simplified writing programs that used
dynamic memory and added guard rails so
programmers did not unintentionally
write dangerous or insecure code the key
value-add features that make python more
appropriate for general purpose
programming are the string object list
object and dis dict object that handle
all aspects of creating and using
variables and collections of variables
the book has one foot note unix is a
trademark of bell laboratories
but of course there's more
actually the trademark for unix is no
longer owned by at t it is owned by the
open group but that is a story for
another day
the unix story arc includes att unix
berkeley software de distribution which
we call bsd sun microsystems minix linux
the open software foundation unix
international and others
the short version of that story is that
at t unix was poised to take over the
world as an open source product long
before the words open source were ever
spoken
at t should have and could have defined
open source and changed everything by
the early 1980s
except for a few at t intellectual
property lawyers it took over a decade
for computer science to pivot away from
a nearly exclusive focus on c and a t
unix
the linux operating system was open
source from its inception and became the
standard barrier for unix-like operating
systems
and continues to be the way most of us
encounter quote unix
it is almost certain that the computer
that served this media to you runs linux
but that is a story for another time
in 1978
unix and c were in their glory days and
showed the entire computer science field
and technology industry the right way
forward
from that point forward hardware could
evolve independently from software
with the systems programming language
and operating systems patterns sorted
the previous 40 years have seen an
amazing innovation in hardware
capability and performance
this 1978 c programming book by brian w
kernighan and dennis m richie was the
big bang moment for modern computing and
computer science
we owe them a debt of gratitude for
making whatever we do today possible
if you have made it to the end of this
chapter in this book as your narrator i
would like to congratulate and thank you
it has been an honor to record and
narrate a book of such historical
significance for you
cheers
this work
is based on the 1978 c programming book
written by brian w kernighan and dennis
m ritchie
their book is copyright all rights
reserved by at t
but is used in this work under fair use
because of the book's historical and
scholarly significance
its lack of availability and the lack of
an accessible version of the book
the book is augmented in places to help
understand its rightful place in a
historical context amidst the major
changes of the 1970s and 1980s as
computer science evolved from a hardware
first vendor-centered approach to a
software-centered approach where
portable operating systems and
applications written in c could run on
any hardware
this is not the ideal book to learn c
programming because the 1978 edition
does not reflect the modern c language
using an obsolete book gives us an
opportunity to take students back in
time and understand how the c language
was evolving as it laid the groundwork
for a future with portable applications
[Music]
you